STARTED -- THIS WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
COMMITTEE.
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE COMMITTEE TO
HEAR.
TESTIMONY ON SOME OF THE BILLS
WILL GET RIGHT STARTED ALL OF
YOU HERE ARE ON TIME THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WE CAN'T.
START ON TIME.
OF WILL BEGIN -- DO WE HAVE ANY
PRISONERS HERE.
SIR BRADFORD HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT PRESENTING HER.
WONDERFUL CLEAVE WONDERFULLY
CRAFTED BILL.
I'M CENTER OKAY WITH A STARTING
RIGHT NOW.
GOOD MORNING MR WHAT YOUR HEART
WELL I I'M GOING TO START WITH
SB [inaudible]
ONE FIVE FIVE ALL RIGHT.
SB ONE FIVE FIVE IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE THAT IMPROVES TO
EXISTING STATE ENERGY PROGRAM TO
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY OF ALL
ENERGY PROVIDERS I'M.
HERE TO ACCEPT THE CAN COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I THANK THE
GERMAN AND STAFF FOR WORKING TO
THIS POINT.
AS YOU HEARD REPEATEDLY
PROCUREMENT IS BECOMING LESS
RELIABLE MORE COMPLICATED
GREATER UNCERTAINTY DEMANDS MORE
NOT LESS ACCOUNTABILITY.
OF ALL PARTIES SB ONE FIVE FIVE
DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW
REQUIREMENTS JUST PROVIDES
BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY IT'S
SIMPLY SHORES EXISTING RULES.
ARE FOLLOWED SO THE STATE CAN
ASSESS OUR PS COMPLIANCE IN A
TIMELY WAY.
RELIABILITY PLANNING INCLUDES
MULTI MULTI YEAR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY.
AND PROCUREMENT PLANNING
INCLUDES EXISTING OF LONG TERM
CONTRACT PROCUREMENT -- FROM SB
THREE FIFTY IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE'RE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT -- BY VICE
BY THE RULES WITH ME TODAY IS
MATT FRIEDMAN FROM TURN AND
COLIN.
QUESTION ANY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
YES THANK YOU OF A COMMITTEE FOR
A HAVING HERE CHAIRMAN I HUESO
MY NAME IS COLIN CASH THE ON THE
VICE PRESIDENT SO I CALIFORNIA'S
AND RESPONSIBLE FOR A POWER
SUPPLY.
CALIFORNIA MUST CAREFULLY
PLANNED FOR IT'S A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE TO ENSURE THAT
ELECTRICITY SERVICES RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE FOR ALL CUSTOMERS.
TO DO THIS WE NEED TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE AND INTEGRATED
PLAN.
THAT IS APPLICABLE TO ALL THOSE
CERVANTES WHICH INCLUDES THE
UTILITIES THE ENERGY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS.
AS WE REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FIRED FUELS AND INCREASE
OUR RELIANCE ON RENEWABLE AND
CLEAN ENERGY.
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE A LOT OF
THIS CLEAN AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
HAS LIMITATIONS ON HOW IT CAN
OPERATE.
THEREFORE IT'S GONNA BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CENTRALLY PLANNED.
AND HOLD ALL LOW SERVING
ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR WHAT IS BILL.
WHERE DOES BILL AND WHEN IT IS
BUILT?
SB THREE FIFTY CREDIT IN
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS REFER TO AS THE I. R. P..
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS TASK.
HOWEVER CCA'S INDIA'S PIECE
WHICH WILL SOON BE MORE THAN
HALF OF THE CPC'S JURISDICTIONAL
LOAD.
HAS BEEN LARGELY RESISTANT TO
HAVING THEIR IRP RESULTS
DIRECTLY REGULATED BY THE CPUC.
AND THIS IS AN UNTENABLE
POSITION.
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC GRID NEEDS
TO BE PLANNED FOR HER THOUGHTFUL.
AND COMPREHENSIVE MANNER AND IT
WILL FAIL IF DOZENS OF ALICE
SEES CAN OPERATE INDEPENDENT OF
GREAT NEEDS.
THEREFORE SO I CALIFORNIA'S IN
VERY MUCH SUPPORTS SB
[inaudible]
ONE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN REPRESENTING THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I'M SB ONE FIFTY FIVE WOULD
SIMPLY AUGMENT THE ABILITY AND
THE AUTHORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
PC TO OVERSEE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
AND INTEGRATED RESOURCES
PLANNING PROGRAM OBJECTIVES.
THE RAPID EXPANSION OF COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION AND THE
EXPANSION OF DIRECT ACCESS THAT
WAS AUTHORIZED LAST YEAR.
ARE CREATING SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO THE RETAIL MARKETS THAT ARE
GONNA REQUIRE DILIGENT OVERSIGHT
OF ALL RESOURCE PLANNING AND
RELIABILITY BY STATE REGULATORS.
ALL OF THESE ENTITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
PROGRAM TARGETS.
THE P. YOU SEE HAS DONE VERY
LITTLE HISTORICALLY TO REVIEW
THE PROCUREMENT PLANS SUBMITTED
BY LOAD SERVING ENTITIES OTHER
THAN THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
I'M IN ORDER TO DETERMINE --
WHETHER THESE PLANS ARE ADEQUATE
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS ARE ON TRACK
IF YOU SEE SIMPLY NEEDS TO
CONDUCT MORE MEANINGFUL REVIEWS
OF ANNUAL PROGRESS AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH RESPECT ANY
DEFICIENCY.
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS
PROCESS IS BROKEN.
I'M IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWENTY THIRTEEN COMPLIANCE CYCLE.
THREE DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDERS
FAILED TO COMPLY WITH THEIR
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
TARGETS.
THEY SUBMITTED REQUESTS FOR
WAIVERS IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIVE
YEARS LATER -- THESE REQUESTS
WERE SUBMITTED SO FAR AFTER THE
COMPLIANCE DEADLINE THEY STILL
HAVE YET TO BE RESOLVED HERE IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN I'M THE PC
SHOULD NOT BE ASKED FIRST TO
WEIGH IN ON THE ADEQUACY OF
THESE PLANS MANY YEARS AFTER THE
COMPLIANCE DEADLINES HAVE PASSED
SO WE THINK THIS BILL PROVIDES A
COMMONSENSE CHECK POINT.
THAT ALLOWS FOR A STATUS REPORT
TO BE PROVIDED THAT IS
MEANINGFUL REVIEWED.
ON SB ONE FIFTY FIVE WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY --
FOR ALIGNING THE IOP PROGRAM
OBLIGATIONS WITH THE 60%
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
TARGET THAT WAS ADOPTED JUST
LAST YEAR IN SB.
ONE HUNDRED BY THE RESOURCE
PLANS HAVE TO ADDRESS MULTI YOUR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY NEEDS AND THE
LONG TERM CONTRACTING
OBLIGATIONS UNDER EXISTING LAW.
WE TINK THAT THESE CHANGES
WOULD ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO
COORDINATE PARTICIPATION BY LOW
SERVING ENTITIES IN THE I. R. P.
PROCESS IN THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROGRAM AND AS PART OF THE OUR
PS PROGRAM SO WE REALLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THINK IT'S A
COMMONSENSE MODEST MEASURE
FORWARD AND ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS -- CUSTOMERS
WHO WERE WHO SERVED BUT YES PEAS
AND CCA'S ALSO SERVED BY -- USE
THEY GET SERVICES FROM ALL THREE
IT JUST MAKES SENSE TO US THAT
THEY HAVE ONE CENTRALIZED
REGULATORY BODY THAT THEY CAN GO.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROCEEDINGS AND HAVE A VOICE AND
FOR THAT REASON WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STEVE YOU'LL --
YOU I TELL YOUR MY POSITION ON
THIS AND PARTICULARLY TO THREE
NINETY NINE FIFTEEN BE.
TEN I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO THIS --
BY GETTING DATA OUT OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE OUT OF THE
PROCESS.
THERE'S A HANDSHAKE BETWEEN THE
P. YOU SEE ANY ENERGY COMMISSION
THE ENERGY COMMISSION DOES THE
REPORTING.
THE THAT COMMISSIONERS APPROVE
THAT IN AND THE P. YOU SEE.
I SEE I A I A I WAS AT THE
BUSINESS MEETING TO TO TELL THEM.
THAT -- THEIR DATA THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT OUT -- NET OUTPUT LOW.
KILOWATT DATA.
AND WHAT I'VE DONE I TAKE IN --
THANK YOU FOR DATA.
AND I PUT IT UP AGAINST.
SENATE POINTED OUT ABOUT SIXTY
OF THEM.
WHERE THEY WERE GETTING MORE
THAN OF SO?
HI I HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WILL
ANSWER ALL OF THAT STUFF I I'VE
GOT.
I IS.
YOU SUPPORT PROJECTS SIR I
SUPPORT THE PROJECT.
WE NEED TO STOP DOING ANALOG
MODELING.
I GO TO DISCRETE EVENT MODELING.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
OKAY FINE ON THAT WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU WILL CALL YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HOWEVER WE WOULD KNOW
TO THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE ANY ON
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE DERIVE
FROM THE INITIAL RP CYCLE WHICH
IN MANY.
CASES WITH THE TEST CYCLE THANK
YOU -- GOOD MORNING CAM MEMBERS
LORD AS HE MANAGED TO SEND GAS
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HOW DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION?
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE LC
CA I'M AS LONG AS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ACCEPTED WE ACTUALLY
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY VERY WELL I DO WANNA DO ASK
SPECIFICALLY WHERE YOU GOT TO
THE NUMBER TWO THOUSAND FOUR
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS AND IF THAT
IS -- BASED ON IN A REAL SCIENCE
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE NEED IN THE
STATE.
YEAH THAT WE FOUND WILD.
RESEARCH GRANTS WERE.
KERN IS LEGISLATION.
CONVERSATION WITH INDUSTRY.
FOR SO I WOULD ASSUME ALL THAT
IS ACCURATE DATA AND NOT MADE UP
NUMBERS.
AND WILL.
IN WHAT TIME DO YOU THINK.
THAT AMOUNT TO BE [inaudible]
PRODUCED.
AND I WOULD THINK CHILI APPROACH
HIM BETTER.
ADDITION TO ANSWER THAT.
ARE SO MAYBE MAYBE IF WE CAN GET.
SCOTT WHICH APPEAR OR AND I WANT
TO GET TO KIND OF SPECIFICALLY
THE NUMBER OF THE TWO TO FOUR
THOUSAND BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
EXACTLY THOUGHT ON THIS BILL --
I'M SORRY IT'S ON THE THE PUMP
STORAGE BILL THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO BUT YOU SAID YOU
WERE GONNA DO.
ONE FIFTY FIVE OKAY I'M YEAH
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT WE'RE ONE FIVE
FIVE RIGHT I WENT TO ME FOR A
LOOP.
YEAH THAT'S PUMP STORAGE
[inaudible]
OKAY THAT.
I WAS I WAS NOT FOLLOWING.
THE PRESENTATION BUT I WAS NOT
UNDERSTANDING.
WHY THEY WEREN'T REALLY SPEAKING
TO OKAY?
THIS IS THE THAT MAKE SENSE WHY
THIS VOTE RESOURCE ADVOCACY I
RIDE -- I WANTED TO ASK IF.
YOU'RE OKAY WITH AMENDMENTS SAID
YES I ACCEPT IT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WITH IT WILL
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE HAVE A WE CAN'T BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT WILL
THEN WILL -- AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME WE'LL MOVE A BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS AT THE PLEASURE OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT BILL WHICH WILL LARA
SB.
SIX SEVEN SIX AND SB SIX SEVEN
SIX WILL ENSURE THE STATE START
I MEAN FULLER -- TO MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS TO REPAIR IMPACTS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING.
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE TO
MEMBERS AGAIN THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
EASY CHARGING EXPECTED TO ADD
NEARLY ONE GIGAWATTS OF LOW TO
OUR GRID DURING PEAK DEMAND.
EVERYONE PAYS FOR ACTION
GENERATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE NO
SIR TO MEET OUR GROWING DAILY
PEAK.
VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION CAN
SHIFT LOWER.
OUT OF THE DAILY PEAK AND
MITIGATE AGREED CONGESTION AMONG
OTHER BENEFITS THE STATE HAS
BEEN DISCUSSING VEHICLE. FOR
YEARS IT'S TIME THAT WE REALLY
GETS YEARS AND ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AND WITH ME THE DAVID
WASHROOM BURKE.
ARE FROM E. MOTOR WORKS AND
MELISSA ROMERO FROM CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
HUESO IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU CENTER FOR PATRICK
FOR YOU COULD YOU SIR I JUST
WANTED.
TO AGAIN ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
RIGHT UP TO THE MEMBER.
GO AHEAD SIR.
SO GOOD MORNING AGAIN TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANKS FOR
BRADFORD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS TOPIC MY NAME IS DAVID
SCHLOSSBERG GONNA REPRESENTING
MOTOR WORKS -- WERE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATION
MANUFACTURER AND ENERGY SERVICES
PROVIDER.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVEN SIX
WHICH WOULD CREATE A MARKET
TRANSFER NAY TRANSFORMATION
INITIATIVE FOR VEHICLE RENDON --
INTEGRATION SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN ALL THE AMBITIOUS POLICIES
WE HAVE IN THE STATE -- A ROOM
WE'VE ADOPTED OVER THE PAST
DECADE TO RAPIDLY DE CARBONIZED
ARE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRATION IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF ENSURING THAT
ARE LARGE INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
IS DONE IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES
THE ECONOMIC VALUE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS BOTH THE V. R.
OWNERS AS WELL AS THOSE NOT YET
ADOPTING YOU VIS.
BY ENSURING THAT THE INCREASE IN
ELECTRIC DEMAND FROM EVEY
CHARGING IS USED IN A LEASE AS A
LEASE COST RESOURCE TO INTEGRATE
CALIFORNIA'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
TARGETS.
AND TO ENSURE THAT YOU VIEW
CHARGING PROVIDES NOT.
ALL REPAIRS AND REDUCES NOT
RAISES ELECTRICITY COSTS.
THE BILL HERE WOULD CREATE AN
ANNUAL TARGET BASED ON THE
FORECAST OF EASY CHARGING LOAD
OVER A GIVEN YEAR ESTIMATED FOR
EACH CHALICES PORTFOLIO -- LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES.
AND IT'S ACHIEVABLE THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF TECHNOLOGY
ADOPTION MARKET FORMATION
CUSTOMER PROGRAMS AND INNOVATIVE
RATE DESIGN.
THIS BILL IS TIMELY AN ESSENTIAL
AND GIVEN THE IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT THE STATE IS
COMMITTED TO VEHICLE EXTRICATION.
AND CHARGING STATION DEPLOYMENT
AS WELL AS THE TRANSITION WILL
SEE AN EASY MARK.
DESK DECADE NEXT DECADE AS WE
MOVE FROM EARLY ADOPTERS. TO THE
MASS MARKET VVS IT'S ACCEPTABLE
FOR ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
LED THE NATION IN PASSING
CLIMATE POLICIES THAT WILL
TRANSITION US TO A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE.
AND AS WE LOOK TO THIS CLIMATE
TARGETS WE MUST PLAN AHEAD TO
ENSURE FLEXIBLE ABOUT GREED BUT
BALANCING AS WE TRANSITION TO
HER PERCENT RENEWABLE CARBON
FREE ENERGY.
INCORPORATING IN NOT PLANNING
PRACTICES THAT WILL MINIMIZE
COST INCREASES AND MAXIMIZE NET
RATE REPAIR BENEFITS.
AS MORE MORE FAMILIES SWITCH TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THERE WILL BE
MORE EBS PLUGGING INTO THE GRID
AND CHARGING.
I'M MORE -- MORE EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS WILL COME ON LINE.
WITH THIS WILL COME IN INCREASED
ELECTRICAL DEMAND ON OUR GRADE
WHICH PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICALLY PLAN FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRATION.
THIS MEANS INTEGRATING EVEY
ISN'T EASY INFRASTRUCTURE IN A
WAY THAT INCREASES THE USE OF
RENEWABLES AND ALSO REDUCES THE
COST OF ENERGY.
SB SIX SEVENTY SIX IS A
NECESSARY STEP IN SETTING CLEAR
TARGETS FOR THIS EVEY GREAT INTO
INTEGRATION AND THIS BILL WILL
PUT CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUTURE THAT
WILL AVOID THE USE OF NON
RENEWABLE POWER PLANTS.
BY PROVIDING RELIABLE ENERGY FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING DEMAND
WHILE MAXIMIZING THE USE OF
RENEWABLES. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE CAN AND
SHOULD INTEGRATE RENEWABLE
ENERGY THROUGHOUT THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRAION IN
ORDER TO POSITIVELY IMPACT THE
CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR LIKE TO
READ.
AS WE CHARGE A HAD TO OUR
RENEWABLE AND CARBON FREE
TRANSITION THANK YOU.
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YOUR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A TIMELY --
MEASURE IN ORDER TO COORDINATE --
THE STATE'S ADVANCED ENERGY AND
ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION GOALS
WHILE IT IS COST EFFECTIVE THANK
YOU.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING VANESSA GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF HYUNDAI NORTH AMERICAN
SUPPORT.
THE DEALER IN SUPPORT TABLE
WE'VE ALMOST GOT CURTAILED IS MY
CHAD RENEWABLES THE IN APRIL AS
WE ALL DID THE ALL LAST YEAR.
WELL I SAW DAVE.
THANK YOU.
ANYTHING FROM THE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS OPPOSITION -- BUT DO
WE HAVE OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL.
THERE WAS PART OF THE US CENTER
SKINNER.
YES I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR I'M
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AT THE
MEDICINE MEN SIX YES MA'AM AND
ON THE MAKE WATCHES VERY GOOD.
I WONDERED -- I ALSO.
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT
FIRST ALLOWED FOR OUR TIME
UTILITIES TO START PURCHASING
UTILITY GREAT STORAGE I'M.
IN FAVOR OF BUSINESS SEVEN SEVEN
YOU'RE YOU'RE NO -- STILL ON THE
THANK YOU.
ONCE YOU GET TO THE WE'RE ON A
ITEM TWELVE RUN ON TIME HE HAS
HE HAS LIKE SIXTEEN BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA FIX US SENATE
REDFORD'S GONNA FIX ENTIRE
ENERGY GREAT TODAY ONE DAY YEAH.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL AS THE
AMENDED SUGGESTION.
THANK YOU.
AND IT IS LOOK CONFUSING BUT
ANYWAY OF THANK YOU.
OF WILL MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT
BILL.
NO BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE.
WE NEED A QUORUM. ONE TWO ONE
NINE SIX WE NEED ONE MORE
[inaudible]
I COUNTY [inaudible]
SURE.
WHEN WHEN WE DO I WANNA BE ADAMS
CO?
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
OKAY.
I AM THIRTEEN AS IN ALL SEVEN AS
FOUR SEVEN OH FOUR THANK YOU
WITNESSES -- SB SEVEN OH FOUR
MAKES SEVERAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM THAT WILL
INCREASE PARTICIPATION AMONG
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME.
CALIFORNIANS MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
WILL LARA UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
TO THE PROGRAM FOR US TO THE
WONDERFUL GROUPS LIKE FOSTER
YOUTH INFORMALLY INCARCERATED --
ALSO VALUE EVALUATE WHETHER WE
SHOULD INCLUDE BROADBAND AND
LIFELINE AS ONE WAY TO ADDRESS
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IS TO ISSUE
THAT WE DEALT WITH WHEN I WAS IN
ASSEMBLY ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WE
LOOKED AT IT AND IT'S ONE THAT
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT EVERYONE
AGREES THIS PROGRAM DESERVES.
IMPROVEMENTS SB -- SEVEN OH FOR
WILL BEGIN THAT WORK -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA VOTING
WITH ME IS VINCE IN LAY WITH.
GREEN LINE INSTITUTION AND NAY
AND JOHNSON IS GOING TO BE HERE
FROM TO CONNECT -- SAID ABOUT --
FOR VINCENT LAY WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE WE ADVOCATE FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT BECAUSE BROADBAND AND
TELEPHONE SERVICES ARE CRITICAL
TOOLS FOR ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY --
IF 1% MORE CALIFORNIA GETS.
BROADBAND THAT'S FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND MORE JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND NEARLY EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR -- ADDED
TO OUR ECONOMY EACH YEAR SINCE
TWENTY TEN WHEN WE DEREGULATED
BROADBAND -- PRICES HAVE GONE UP
ADOPTION HAS GONE DOWN AND THIS
CANNOT HAPPEN -- SO WHILE WE
NEED A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO
CLOSE ITS DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
LOWER PRICES -- THIS BILL IS A
GOOD FIRST STEP THAT'S HOW WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
VERY WELL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROJECT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MEMBERS -- I WANTED TO ASK ON
THIS BILL.
FORMS ARE TRANSPLANT
[inaudible]
IF -- OKAY.
OKAY DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS ARE I THINK
THIS IS A STRICT FOR MEASURE AS
I STATED TO ISSUE THAT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH -- A LIFELINE
NO AS WE SEE MORE MORE CUSTOMERS
MOVE AWAY FROM A LAND LINE AND
ACCESS COMMUNICATIONS THROUGH.
OUR WIRELESS DEVICES IS JUST TO
COMMONSENSE MEASURE IN IT A AT
AN INCREASED PARTICIPATION
SERVICE REQUEST FOR OUR LEAD
APPEARS WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW
LAST.
OF THE CLERK TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
WHAT'S SO HERE WHAT'S SO HERE
MOORLACH BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG DIED.
DIED HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE HILL.
MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER.
HI SKINNER HERE STERN.
GEN HERE'S DOWN DOWN HERE WINNER.
VERY WELL THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
CAN I ENTERTAIN A MOTION CASH.
THIS IS NOT A WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK LET.
WE ENTERTAIN MOTION ON ON THIS
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN OH FOUR THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO.
I WAS SO I AM MORE LACK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHIANG.
DIED DIED AYE HERTZBERG.
I HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER ALL
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
DOWN NO WIENER.
WELL THE ROLE OPEN THREDSON
MEMBERS.
CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON SB
[inaudible]
ONE ONE FIVE FIVE DOWN.
WE HAVE A MOTION CLIP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SB ONE FIVE FIVE
DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LESS SO.
AND THIS IS AN AMENDMENT -- THIS
IS -- MOTION. TO APPROVE WTH
AMENDMENTS WEST SO I SO I AM
MORE LUCK.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHING I DIED.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO
SKINNER.
IN OUR AYE STERN STERN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE WIENER [inaudible]
ENOUGH.
OKAY WILL -- HAS ENOUGH VOTES
WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN CAN
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON SB.
SIX THANKS I LIKE TO MOVE IT IN
MASSIVE THE GOOD SENATOR AND
IT'S A GREAT BUILD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF POSSIBLE.
SO THAT WOULD BE A MOTION TO
APPROVE WITH AMENDMENTS AND I
THINK WE'RE ADDING TO THE CO
AUTHORS -- CENTER STONE AND
SENATORS.
I WOULD REQUEST TO BE IS CO
AUTHOR ALSO IF THE AUTHORS WILL.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX SEVEN SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESTELL. FIVE WAS SO I MOORLACH
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHING FANG I
DIED.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE STONE AYE WIENER.
HAS NOT.
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO REDUCE.
SEVEN FOUR OKAY.
NO ONE EVEN WAY.
FOR ANOTHER ONE EVERYBODY'S BEEN
WAITING.
FOR ANOTHER.
ONE BILLION EVERYBODY WITH
CONSTERNATION.
ITEM FOURTEEN SIR SB.
SEVEN TWO SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN
TWO YES SB.
SEVEN SEVEN TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO WILL
FILL THE GAP AND ENERGY
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOES ON LONG TERM --
DURATION BOLTS STORAGE
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL CALLS FOR
THE CAL I SO TO PRODUCE AT LEAST.
TWO THOUSAND AND UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF BULK
STORAGE AND RE COVER THOSE COSTS
VIA TRANSMISSION RATES.
RENEWABLE ENERGY IS INNER MAN BY
NATURE.
IF WE WANT TO G. R. TWENTY FORTY
FIVE ZERO CARBON POWER GOALS WE
NEED BALK ENERGY STORAGE TO HELP
BALANCE.
ED THIS WILL BENEFIT ALL ENERGY
PROVIDERS WE CAN DEBATE EXACTLY
WHEN WE WILL NEED THIS RESOURCE
BUT BY THE TIME WE ACT WILL BE
PROBABLY TOO LATE WE CANNOT WAIT --
FOR WAY TO FIX THIS PROBLEM WE
CANNOT -- BOUNCE NOBLES -- ON
DOMINATE AGREED IF WE DO NOT
HAVE A LOT OF STORAGE AND
SPECIALLY BOOKSTORES WE KEEP
CITING BIG CLIMATE GOALS.
A REQUIREMENT FOR GRIT THIS BILL --
LOOKS TO HELP WITH THAT PRACTICE --
IN MY I'M SORRY IT TO ME BILLS
ANIMALS STEP -- THE LEGISLATIVE
ARE ACTING ON SHORT TERM
DURATION US MISS SKINNER STATED
SHE INTODUCED TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN VIEWS TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN NOW IT'S TIME TO ACT ON LONG
TERM.
STORAGE -- BUT THIS IS STILL NOT
A US SILVER BULLET BY ANYWAY ON
WITH TECHNOLOGY THERE.
ARE STILL OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT A BASIC GRID
NEED BIG RESOURCES THAT CAN --
MIMIC NATURAL GAS SPEAKER PLANTS
AND DISCHARGE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
ENERGY OVER DAYS AND WEEKS -- SO
ON IT -- TOO IT'S MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
IF WE WAIT TILL I AREAS -- AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS MEASURE
TODAY WITH MRS RDS FROM STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES CARRY OUT OF
BACK FROM NEXTERA AND GLANFORD.
FERAL FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL GO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
CENTER DOESN'T HELP THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
OPERATOR BE HERE WITH YOU THIS
MORNING -- AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL HAS BEEN VERY STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF HIGHER RPMS.
WHICH SUPPORTED THE SP ONE
HUNDRED KNOWING THAT MOSTLY SOME
OF THOSE JOBS WERE NOT ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE CREATING GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
WORK.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT PROJECTS
LIKE THIS WHEN I SLEEP VARIETY
THE RELIABLE CAPACITY DICEY GET
US TO THE TO THE ONE HUNDRED
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
GOALS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT IS WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STEADFAST SUPPORT OF COMMON
GOALS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S GRID RELIABILITY AS WELL.
THIS IS ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GET US TO SB
ONE HUNDRED TO GET US TO THOSE
GOALS AND TO SHOWCASE TO OTHER
STATES AROUND US THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN ACTUALLY BE A PRODUCER SO
THAT WE CAN.
HELP BECOME THAT LEADER THAT WE
ARE CLAIMING TO BE WE CANNOT GET
TO OUR GOALS IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
RELIABILITY.
THIS IS IMPORTANT PROJECT AND
CENTER PROJECTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS POLICY WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KERRY HOW
TO BECOME REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THE WAY OF WEST GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR NEXT -- ENERGY NEXT
OR ENTITIES BEEN AN ELECTRIC
GENERATOR PROVIDER IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND IS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST RENEWABLE
GENERATOR AN OPERATOR.
WE ON TWENTY SEVEN WIND AND
SOLAR FACILITIES REPRESENTING
NEARLY NEARLY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE STATE
ARE CLEAN ENERGY.
WE ARE ALSO INVESTORS INC IN
ENERGY STORAGE BOTH BOTH IN
FRONT AND BEHIND THE METER AS
WELL AS INVESTORS A LONG
DURATION STORAGE AS WELL AS
BEING A TRANSMISSION PROVIDER.
WHERE INVESTORS AND EVERY
ELEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
ENERGY ECONOMY?
WE SUPPORT SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
THE NEXT STEPS AND GET THE NEXT
UPGRADE TO CARBONIZATION
REQUIRES VISION AND LEADERSHIP
SAID THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
GOALS IS CONSTRUCTED.
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE TO MEET
ITS CARBON OBJECTIVES.
BOOK INTERVIEW STORAGE ASSURES
BUT THE CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN ENERGY AND THAT CUSTOMERS
RECEIVE THE BENEFIT OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
THE STATE FOUND THAT LONG
DURATION STORAGE IS THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE PATH FORWARD WITH
HIGH LEVELS OF RENEWABLE
INVESTMENT AGGRESSIVE CURTAIN
CALLS.
SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO ELEGANTLY
NAVIGATES A GAP IN THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT EXISTS
TODAY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE SCALE
ELECTRICITY PROJECTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO COST EFFECTIVELY ME
CALIFORNIA'S CARBON GOALS.
BUT THE TWENTY THIRTY IN THE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE TARGETS.
THERE OVER TWENTY SIX LOWERED
SERVING ENTITIES IN THE STATE
TODAY NO SINGLE LOAD SERVING AND
TODAY IS LARGE ENOUGH TO PROCURE
LARGE SCALE INFRASTRUCTURE ON
THEIR OWN.
THIS MEANS THAT WITHOUT ACTION
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
TO MEET THE STATE'S CARBON DE
CARBONIZATION GOALS WILL
ASSURING GROUP RELIABILITY WILL
BE OFF THE TABLE.
SB SEVEN SEVENTY PROVIDES AN
ANSWER TO BOTH THE COST RECOVERY
IN INFRASTRUCTURE SCALE PROBLEM
BY ASKING THE ISO FOR THIS
LIMITED PURPOSE TO PROCURE BOOK
ENERGY STORAGE IN A MANNER
SIMILAR TO HOW IT SECURES
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS.
DíAS ALWAYS BEST POSITION FOR
KERR BOOK STORAGE BECAUSE IT
ALREADY HAS A PROCESS IN PLACE
TO PROCURE TRANSMISSION PROJECTS.
THIS PROCESS COULD BE APPLIED
DIRECTLY TO BOOK ENERGY STORAGE
WHICH HAS A SIMILARLY LONG
DURATION CONSTRUCTION TIME.
AND AN END HAS A COST ALLOCATION
MECHANISMS FOR FOR PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT MULTIPLE.
TIME CUSTOMER CLASSES IT ALLOWS
CUSTOMERS TO MOVE AROUND WHAT WE
STARTED INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE.
I SAW ALSO THE COST RECOVERY
MECHANISM THAT SUPPORTS THE
FINANCING OF INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT AND ALLOWS THE STATE TO
HARNESS COST SAVINGS WELL SURE
SCHERING EQUITABLE COST RECOVERY.
THROUGH -- THREE REGULATED RATES
IN SHORT SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
BILLS OFTEN EXISTING INEFFICIENT
FRAMEWORK.
CALIFORNIA MUST INVEST IN BOOK
ENERGY STORAGE NOW TO ENSURE
THAT THE RENEWABLE INTEGRATION
SOLUTIONS ARE THERE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU BUT GOOD MORNING A STEVE
CREWS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF KANDOR WATER FORTY OF PENSION
HE FOR FOR GRAN FAIL BUT WE WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF GOOD PROJECTS OUT THERE --
SAN DIEGO -- IS IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF PLANNING ITS OWN --
PUMP STORAGE PROJECT. TO THE
SANTA CENTER RESERVOIR -- AS
STATED IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME A
TO THE PLANNING AND SECURE
INVESTMENT FOR THIS PROJECT SAN
DIEGO'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL --
AT BUILDING LARGE SCALE PROJECTS
AND SO WE THINK SEVEN SEVEN TWO
SENSE OF THEIR PURPOSE SIGNALS --
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD -- THIS PROCESS SO WE
APPRECIATE THE CENTER BRADFORD
INTRODUCTION AND AND NOW --
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU
VERY GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL THE WESTERN STATES
COUNTS OF SHEET METAL WORKERS.
AND THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
UNION -- IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WOULD SB ONE
HUNDRED WAS HELD UP IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE WERE OPPOSED IT WAS THIS
SINGULAR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT WE
WOULD NEED THIS LEVEL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE THAT GOAL
ATTAINABLE IS THE REASON THAT WE
CAME IN SUPPORT OF THAT BILL
HELP MAKE THAT A REALITY.
AND WE SEE THIS IS LIKE A
COMPLETION OF THAT PROCESS AND
WOOD URGENT I'VE A THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN HUESO ON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON GARY PASSED FOR
WITH THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS.
WE HAVE BEEN LAW.
ACTIVELY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE ARE ARE
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTERS OF THE
STATE'S EFFORTS. TO ACHIEVE A
RENEWABLE ENERGY SUPPLY.
AND THIS IS IN A CENTRAL PART OF
CONCERN.
TO THE SENIORS OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH WILL SOON BE THE LARGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC WITHIN THE STATE.
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS FOR HEALTH
CARE.
ENERGY SUPPORT.
UP AND AND EQUIPMENT IS POWERED
BY ENERGY WE CANNOT.
HAVE A A A AN INTERRUPTIBLE OR
AN INTERMITTENT SUPPLY OF ENERGY.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT BALK
STORAGE CAPACITY OF THE STATE.
AND WE DISASTROUSLY SUPPORT
SANDRA BRADFORD TO BILL.
AND CONGRATULATE HIM FOR TAKING
A LEADERSHIP ON THANK YOU.
STEVE YOU ARE AN A AND SUPPORT --
TO WE HAVE NEED TO CONSIDER THAT
IT'S MY DE CANCEL THERE I HILL.
WE NEED.
DUE TO AND NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
ENOUGH DATA.
TO TO GET SMART TO CONTINUE ON
THAT.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
PLANNING ANALOG -- SCHEDULING IS
INHERENTLY BATCHING Q..
THE GREAT IS INHERENTLY JUST IN
TIME.
YOU NEED TO SEE A DISCRETE EVENT
SCHEDULING TO DO THAT -- WHAT'S
AGAIN I HAVE THAT CAL I SO --
WE'VE ALREADY CURTAILED ALMOST
AS MUCH AS WE DID LAST YEAR SO
THERE'S THAT DEFINITE NEED WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AND ALL NOPE
TRANSMISSION.
WE NEED TO BE CREATIVE ABOUT HOW
THIS STORAGE.
PATTERN IS CREATED IT WOULD BE
BEST TO BEEP CREATED IT AT THE
LOW JUST LIKE YOU HAVE A BATTERY
IN YOUR PHONE THANK YOU.
WHERE TOP ON THE HAVE THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION I'M A LITTLE
BIT BETWEEN THERE KELLY A
SUPPORTS THE PROCUREMENT OF GRID
INTEGRATION RESOURCES HOWEVER
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
AMENDED. TO NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC
AMOUNT OF STORAGE AND HAVE THAT
BE DETERMINED BY THE P. UC AND
CTC BASED ON THE I. R. P.
PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY WE THINK THE COST
OF THAT STORE SHOULD BE BASED ON
EACH LSTS CONTRIBUTION. TO
ELECTRIC SYSTEM CONDITIONS
CREATING A NEED FOR THE ENERGY
STORAGE IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU
HAVE AN OPTIMIZED PORTFOLIO AND
ARE RELYING LESS ON THAT STORAGE
YOUR COST SHOULD BE LESS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
WEIDEMANN I'M A TWEENER --
USUALLY SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
AWESOME BILLS THIS ONE'S JUST
SORT OF GOOD.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF GREENTECH
ACTION FUND WHICH IS THE
ADVOCACY ARM OF THE ENERGY
FOUNDATION.
AND WE SUPPORT LONG DURATION
BOOK STORAGE AND WE PLAY APPLY
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
MOVIE THIS LEGISLATION FOR TO
GET THE DISCUSSION GOING.
AROUND THE NEED FOR A LONG
DURATION BOOKSTORE JIM CALLIS.
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE HAVE AT THE
BILL IS THAT THE DEFINITION
AROUND WHAT LONG DURATION BOOK
STORAGE IS.
IS A BIT NARROW.
AND WE'RE WORRIED THAT IT'S
CONFINED TO ONE PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE THERE'D
BE INCUBATED TODAY THAT ARE VERY.
VERY PROMISING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YOU'VE GOT THE ABILITY TO STORE
ENERGY AND MOLTEN SALT YOU'VE
GOT SOME BATTERY TECHNOLOGIES
THAT HAVE NOT HIT THE MARKET YET
THAT ARE AMAZING.
THAT CAN DISCHARGE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR PLUS TIME CYCLE FOR LONG
DURATION FOR STORAGE.
YOU'VE GOT SUBTERRANEAN PUMP
HYDRO WE'VE GOT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE
IN THE WAY THAT DEFINITIONS
DRAFT IN THE BILL TODAY IT WOULD
EXCLUDE ALL THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
FROM TAKING PLACE.
IN A PROCUREMENT PROCESS HAS
BEEN MANDATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK WHEN WE
DO PROCUREMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE OPEN THESE
UP. TO ALL FORMS OF TECHNOLOGY
SO THEY CAN GET COMPETITIVELY
NEUTRAL LANDSCAPE AND EVERYBODY
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE.
AND PROVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
BEST TECHNOLOGY TO SERVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
I MIGHT HAVE TO MAKE SOME ROOM
APPEAR ON THE DICE FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
WHAT?
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JAZZ MONEY JONES FOR THE
INDEPENDENT -- ENERGY PRODUCERS
WE REPRESENT A LARGE NUMBER OF
RENEWABLES WE'D LOVE TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND BUILDING THOSE
EMPLOYING SOME OF MY LABOR
COLLEAGUES.
UNFORTUNATELY -- WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL -- A. L. BUT WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO PUMP STORAGE OR ANY
OTHER BOB VOLK'S -- BALK SYSTEM
STORAGE -- WE HAVE A TIME OF
GREAT TURMOIL IN ELECTRIC SECTOR --
I'M FRANKLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
HONORINE EXISTING COMMITMENTS MY
MEMBERS MADE THE CLEAN ENERGY
HERE THAT'S VERY REAL WE HAVE
ONE UTILITY IN BANKRUPTCY TO
THAT ARE TEETERING AND WALL
STREET LOOKING WITH JOHN TO SIZE.
AS TO EVERYBODY ELSE HERE SO I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT THIS IS NOT
THE TIME TO BE ADDING ANOTHER.
THREE TO TEN BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF ASSETS INTO THE SYSTEM --
THIS PUMP STORAGE SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT BEEN TO
DETERMINE AS NEEDED -- IN OUR
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN WHICH I
THINK YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY THIS BODY IN SB
THREE FIFTY PUT THAT FORWARD TO
BASICALLY DETERMINE WHAT IS COST
EFFECTIVE AND WHAT ISN'T -- THIS
IS NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED AS AS
NEEDED IN TWENTY THIRTY NOR HAS
IT APPEARED IN THE CAL I ESOS
TRANSMISSION -- PLANNING PROCESS
AND THAT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO DO
HERE IS TO BASICALLY IDENTIFY
THIS RESOURCE AS NECESSARY AS A
NECESSARY TRANSMISSION ASSETS
WHICH WILL BE COVERED IN FOR
WORK REGULATED RATES.
YOU LOSE ALL CONTROL OVER THAT --
THE THE SOLICITATION LIMITS
COMPETITION -- THERE'S  THERE'S
A PHRASE IN THERE THAT HAS TO BE
AT LEAST FOUR HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
WHY THAT NUMBER IF SOMEONE HAS A
GREAT IDEA THAT'S SMALLER THAN
THAT.
WHY CAN'T THEY PLAY IT ALSO HAS
TO BE BUILT IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTRICALLY THERE'S NO REASON
FOR THAT IN THERE ARE RESOURCES
AROUND THE WEST IT MIGHT BE ABLE
TO FILL THAT I GET THE INTEREST
IN TRYING TO GRAY CALIFORNIA
JOBS?
BUT THIS IS JUST.
LIKE PUTTING A KICK ME SIGN --
ON THIS PROGRAM FROM THE FROM
THE COMMERCE CLAUSE SITUATION --
SO IT -- THAT THAT THAT IS A
CONCERN -- SO IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD HERE LET'S MAKE A
TRULY COMPETITIVE AND THE WAY
THIS IS STRUCTURED IN WRITTEN
IT'S NOT COMPETITIVE.
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
LAST YEAR YOU ALL HEARD A LOT
ABOUT FROM SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
THE FACT THAT WE SHOULD NOT
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA DEPENDED
SYSTEM OPERATOR.
BECAUSE A FORK -- THAT FOR
NETWORK IS GOING TO USE OF HEAVY
HAND TO BASICALLY TRY TO CONTROL
OUR RESOURCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS PROJECT IS
FEDERALLY JURISDICTIONAL.
THE LICENSES FEDERAL
JURISDICTION IS CITED UNDER
FEDERAL JURISDICTION THE I. S.
O. WHICH IS A FEDERALLY
REGULATED -- UTILITY IS REQUIRED
TO SOLICIT THIS RESOURCE AND ALL
THE RATE MAKING IS UNDER -- FOR
A JURISDICTION -- SO I KNOW --
IT'S FOOLISH OF ME TO ASK FOR
CONSISTENCY BUT I THINK THAT IF
WE'RE YOU KNOW IF WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS LET'S NOT
BE LET'S NOT BE PICKING AND
CHOOSING BECAUSE THAT KIND OF
GOES FROM INCONSISTENCY
HYPOCRISY SO.
I WOULD BASICALLY ARGUE THAT --
WE NEED TO GET OUR OUR OUR OUR
OUR BRAIN AROUND THAT I THINK
IT'S TIME TO SLOW THIS DOWN --
WE'VE GOT TIME TO LOOK AT THIS
THE I. R. PETERS ANOTHER ONE
COMING UP MAYBE THIS WILL BE THE
SHOWS UP -- THERE ARE LESSONS TO
BE LEARNED ELSEWHERE THERE ARE
PUMP STANDALONE PUMP HYDRO
SYSTEMS THAT RUN INTO PROBLEMS
IN THE U. S. AND IN EUROPE AND I
THINK YOU ALREADY HEARD THAT --
MY UTILITY -- **** DECIDED THE
IOWA HILL -- PROJECT WAS A
LITTLE -- IT WAS A LITTLE RICH
IN A B. AND AND THAT SO WE
SHOULD LEARN FROM HIS EXPERIENCE
AND NOT YOU TO COMMIT OURSELVES
TO OTHER THREE TO TEN BILLION
DOLLARS -- IN NEW COST THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MINUTES WE TO LEASES AS ASIAN
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC AND
ELECTED TO LISA PROVIDE
ELECTRICITY TO ABOUT 25% OF THE
STATE.
WE SHARE THE AUTHOR'S INTEREST
IN PROPONENTS INTERESTED IN A
STABLE LOW CARBON GRADE AND WE
BELIEVE THE ENERGY STORAGE IS
PART OF THAT SOLUTION.
BUT WE ARE OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN SEVEN TWO OUR MEMBERS ARE
OPEN TO PROCURING THIS TYPE OF
RESOURCE AND AS YOU HEARD SMALL
AT ONE OF OUR MEMBERS ACTUALLY
LOOKED INTO THIS -- PROJECT HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA AND AND
WOOD PROCURED IF IT MAKES
ECONOMIC SENSE TO DO SO BUT WE
HAVE CONCERT SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT BEING COLLECTIVELY FORCED
TO DO THE PROCUREMENT THROUGH
LEGISLATION -- ABSENT ANY
IDENTIFIABLE PROCUREMENT NEED
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS.
AB WE AGREE WITH ANALYSIS THAT
THERE ARE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE ANSWERED HOW
MUCH IS NEEDED WHERE IS IT
NEEDED AND WHEN IS IT NEEDED WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE ANALYSIS AND
PLANNING IS NEEDED BEFORE MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THE CAMINO HOUSES ALSO POINTS
OUT THAT PEER USE ARE ON TRACK
TO MEET THEIR TWENTY TWENTY OUR
PS GOALS AND ARE WORKING TOWARDS
A TWENTY THIRTY GOALS.
SENIOR AIDES MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL MEETING OR
EXCEEDING THOSE OUR PS
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE OF THEIR
EFFECTIVE PROCUREMENT POLICIES
THAT INSURE THE CONSIDERATION OF
A DIVERSE.
PORTFOLIO OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES WHAT THE SAME TIME
KEEPING RATES LOW FOR THEIR RATE
PAYERS.
AS AN EXAMPLE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ON BEHALF OF TWELVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA USE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY REVIEWED OVER HUNDRED
FORTY PROPOSALS AND SIGNED
CONTRACTS. FOR OVER NINETEEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF RENEWABLES
WHILE KEEPING RATES THIRTEEN
CENTS PER KILOWATT LOWER AND THE
I. O. U. RATES.
DESPITE THIS SUCCESSFUL
PROCUREMENT ON BEHALF FOR THE P.
O. USE SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
MANDATES ENERGY THAT WE DO NOT
BELIEVE IS NEEDED AT THE CURRENT
TIME.
FINALLY WE ALSO AGREE WITH
ANNOUNCES THAT SOME PATIENTS AS
WARRANTED AND THE PROPONENTS
STIPULATE THAT THERE IS AN
URGENCY TO CONSTRUCT THESE
PROJECTS.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE AGAIN THAT
A USER ON TRACK TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS IN THAT
THERE IS A POLICY IN PLACE UNDER
SB. ONE HUNDRED FOR A JOINT
ASSESSMENT TO BE CONDUCTED BY
THE CDC THE P. YOU SEE AND THE
AIR BE TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
NEEDED. TO REACH A 100% ZERO
CARBON BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE THAT
ANALYSIS IS DUE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT THE VERY LEAST.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONSIDER
THAT ANALYSIS BE BEFORE MOVING
FORWARD ON THESE BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTS AND THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY.
IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING I'M FILING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AND I'VE ALSO
INCORPORATED SOME COMMENTS FROM
OTHER ENVIRONMENT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WILL BE LINING UP TO DO TO
ME TO SOME LITTLE BIT --
LIKEWISE ORGANIZATION SUPPORT
ENERGY STORAGE PROJECTS BECAUSE
OF THE THE BENEFIT. TO THE GRID
STABILITY AND COMPLIMENTING
INTERMENT AND RENEWABLE
RESOURCES SUCH AS WIND AND SOLAR
WHICH PORT OF BUT RESPECTFULLY
MO WE MUST OPPOSE SB SEVEN SEVEN
TWO BECAUSE IT'S YOU KNOW A BIG
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL IS IS
REALLY ABOUT BREATHING NEW LIFE
INTO ONE SPECIFIC --
CONTROVERSIAL NORMALLY DAMAGING
PUMP STORAGE HYDRO PROJECT IN
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT AND THAT'S
THE THE EAGLE CREST PUMP STORAGE
PROJECT -- YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A
FILL IN THE WORKPLACE FOR THREE
DECADES ALREADY WITH AN
ACCEPTABLE COST TO CALIFORNIA'S
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE RATE
PAYERS IN THE NOBLE AND FUTURE.
AND YOU KNOW OUR OTHER.
FOR IN TESTIMONY TO A TEST ON
HIS EVERY SPOKEN TO THE REPAIR
IMPACTS AND AND TO TO THE BURKE
ISSUES THAT ARE EVEN OUTLINED --
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY
THOUGH IS ANYTHING THAT REALLY
INCREASES COSTS TO RATEPAYERS --
ELECTRICITY -- ON THEIR BILLS
BECOMES A DISINCENTIVE TERM TO
MOVE TOWARDS ELECTRIFICATION OF
OUR OF OUR CAR FLEET IN OF
ITSELF.
COM THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN ONE OF
THE BIG INCENTIVES AND DRIVERS
FOR ADOPTION OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES -- SO THEN MEASURES
THAT THAT ALTERNATELY WE ALL
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE
COSTS TO RATEPAYERS WILL HAVE
THAT THAT NEGATIVE IMPACT AS
WELL.
UNLIKE THE SENT THE PROPOSED
SEND YOU SENT -- TO PROJECT IN
SAN DIEGO THAT'S OPPOSED BY THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY
OR ANY OTHER PROPOSED FROM START
PART IN CALIFORNIA.
THE EAGLE CHRIS PROJECT IN
PARTICULAR RELIES ON PUMPING
AGING GROUND WATER FROM AN
ALREADY OVER DRAFTED DOESN'T
OXFORD IN ORDER TO FEEL
RESERVOIRS -- AND WITHIN AN
AQUIFER THAT IS THE CASE IT'S
SOME IT'S BOUNDED ON THREE SIDES
BY THE NATIONAL PARK BY JOSHUA
TREE NATIONAL PARK -- AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE VERY
SENSITIVE ECOLOGICAL HABITAT
AREAS -- THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE'S IN THE BUSINESS OF OF
DEDICATING PARK SPACE -- FOR
AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE THIS AND
SO THE FACT THAT THIS IS BOUNDED
ON ON BRIEF.
ALMOST FOUR SIDES -- COMPLETELY
BIVA AND THE NATIONAL PARK
ITSELF.
IS WHAT REALLY IS DRIVING A LOT
OF OUR OWN ANXIETY ON ON THIS
PROJECT.
SO THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE
RENDON TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
EAGLE CHRIS GROUNDWATER PUMPING
WOULD QUOTE BECAUSE DAMAGING
OVER JEFF CONDITIONS BY PUMPING
THOUSANDS OFACRE FEET OF WATER
FROM AN ALREADY OVER DRAFT IT
DOESN'T OFFER.
WITH NO GROUND WATER RESEARCH
COMPLETED BUT STATE THE NATIONAL
PARK SERVICE RESEARCH SERVES AS
THE MOST RELIABLE IN INDEPENDENT
SCIENCE ON HIS -- THE PROJECT
OPPONENTS CLAIM THAT THEIR
PROJECT WILL NOT HARM THAT IS A
ROCK FOR BECAUSE THE OPERAS
RECHARGE RATE IS THIRTEEN
THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
BUT THE PARK SERVICE'S RESEARCH
ESTIMATES THAT THE RECHARGE RATE
IS LIKELY CLOSER 230-002-6000
ACRE FEET A YEAR -- THE FRACTION
OF THE OF WHAT'S NEEDED -- THE
PROJECT ONE TURNOVER DRAFTING
ABOUT FOR WILL ALSO LIKELY
AFFECT ROUNDED UP IN AN
ECOSYSTEMS AND THE REGIONAL
SPRINGS THAT SUSTAIN A LOT OF
THE WILDLIFE.
AND NATIVE PLANT HABITAT.
IN JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK.
THIS KIND OF GROUND WATER MINING
WOULD BE IN VIOLATION
ESSENTIALLY IT TO SAY POLICY IN
FEDERAL LAND USE PLANS.
INCLUDING THE DESERT RENEWABLE
ENERGY CONSERVATION PLAN -- AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ORIGIN OF A ON SB
SEVEN SOME.
TO STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR.
GREG C<c.cyan> RISING ON THE</c>
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY I WOULD
LIKE TO WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT TO OTHER
ISSUES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DISCUSSED US FAR.
NUMBER.
ONE THE CAL I SO WHEN IT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WAS ESTABLISHED AS AN
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD PROVIDE
THAT THE CALLOUS SO IS NOW A
GENDER.
ACQUIRING GENERATION AND SO
THEY'RE NO LONGER INDEPENDENT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ASSURING
THAT THEIR YOUTH FACILITY IS
USED IN FACT THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGE THREE LINE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
TALKS ABOUT.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF ASSURING
THAT THAT THE COST OF THIS THING
ARE GOING TO BE SHARED BY ALL.
OF THE PARTICIPANTS ON THE CAL I
SO SYSTEM SO IT'S GOING TO REYES.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT NEED IT THE SECOND IMPORTANT
ISSUE IS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE LEVIN
SECTION NINE STATES CLEARLY.
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE PROVISION
OF ELECTRIC SERVICE. FORTY PLUS
CITIES COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ACCEPTED THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY FOR THEIR CITIZENS.
THIS REMOVES THAT RESPONSIBILITY
FROM THEM AND GIVE IT TO THE I
ALSO WE RESPECTFULLY URGE OR NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS DELANEY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION AND
HAIDAR STORE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS MANY MISSION
IN ANY ON BEHALF OF THE LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION -- WE
AGREE THAT IMMIGRATION RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED BUT THIS ISN'T QUITE
THE RIGHT WAY WE POST BILL.
AND MICHAEL BOCA DOOR WITH THE
AG ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF THE STATE'S FARMERS
FOOD PROCESSORS TERRY'S AND
WINERIES.
ALSO IN STRONG OPPOSITION YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM RATE PAYERS
SO I WANT TO REMIND YOU OVER THE
NEXT NINETY DAYS YOU'RE GOING TO
BE DEALING WITH WILD FIRE ISSUES
IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND ABOUT FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF THE COULD END UP ON
RATE PAYERS.
THIS ADDS TO THAT BURDEN WE
CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE YOU'RE
GONNA TO BE YOUR OWN SACRAMENTO
ALL CITIES BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE GONNA GO BY THE
WAYSIDE.
BECAUSE OUR ELECTRIC RATES ARE
SO HIGH IN THE STATE THANK YOU.
ONE OF THEM IT ON A WITHOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA WE SINCERELY
OPPOSE -- THIS PROJECT SIMPLY OR
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
SHOULDN'T BE PUMPING OF
GROUNDWATER OUT OF THE DESERT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY
SAMPSON ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
MY ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN OPPOSITION.
THIRTY YEARS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
REPRESENTING THE FOOD PROCESSING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA JUST LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MISTER BILL BUT THEY'RE ALL VERY
CONCERNED FROM RUSSIA INDUSTRIAL
RATE PAYER PERSPECTIVE THE
PORTABILITY.
OF OF ENERGY IN THE STATE.
LAUREN COMMON BE ALBUM SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MAY NOT POSITION TODAY
IN ORDER NO VOTE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATT FREEMAN ON BEHALF
OF TURNED WE HAVE A CONCERN
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
AND IN PARTICULAR WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL DIRECTLY INVITES THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION TO GET INVOLVED IN
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE PLANNING
POLICY. FOR THOSE PAYING
ATTENTION.
THE APPOINTEES TO THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION BY
THIS PRESIDENT ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY SYMPATHETIC TO
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLIMATE GOALS BUT THIS BILL.
BAGGS THEM TO GET INVOLVED
BECAUSE IT MEANT MADE BY THE I
SO WOULD BE REVIEWED AND
APPROVED BY FOR WORK.
NATIONAL STAKEHOLDERS WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN THE VIEWS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE IRRELEVANT
TO THAT DETERMINATION WE THINK
THIS WOULD BE A HUGE MISTAKE IN
SEATING STATE AUTHORITY TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IT MAY PRODUCE VERY
SIGNIFICANT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS --
I HAVE A FEW COMMENTS BUT I
WANTED -- TO DEFERRED TO CENTER
HERTZBERG BECAUSE HE'S GOT A
ANOTHER MATTER TO TEND TO CENTER
HERTZBERG DID YOU WANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOHN I APPRECIATE YOUR
GENEROSITY IN THAT REGARD.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR YET ANOTHER BRILLIANT
IN THE ANNALS ANALYSIS HERE THEY
JUST DID A FANTASTIC JOB AND
DOING THE HOMEWORK IT'S ALWAYS
NICE TO SEE.
THAT QUALITY OF WORK.
ON I SAT IN THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AND SAID AND I SAY IT AGAIN
TODAY I AM A GIGANTIC.
I HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY IN MY
PREVIOUS IN IN MY INTERREGNUM
LIFE BETWEEN GOVERNMENT SERVICE.
TO TO TO WATCH AND SEE A LOT OF
THESE FACILITIES AND AND THOUGHT
THEY HAD GREAT CAPACITY AND HAVE
DONE GREAT THINGS WHAT WORRIES
ME ABOUT WHAT WE SEE BEFORE US
AND AND IN THE END IT ALL THE
ADVOCATES IS NOT JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THIS.
MEASURE I SPOKE TO THE AUTHOR
ABOUT IT -- IT'S NOT JUST A KNEE
JERK REACTION IS HARD FOR ME TO
TO TO DO THIS GIVEN THE MY
PEOPLE WHO MY HOLDEN HIGHEST
REGARD BUT IT PRESENTS SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES SOME OF
WHICH WILL I'LL JUST QUICKLY
ARTICULATE.
A AND I APOLOGIZE.
SB FIFTIES ANOTHER COMMITTEES OF
THESE COMPETING MEASURES WE'VE
GOT TO DEAL WITH.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED THIS KIND
OF EXISTENTIAL CRISIS IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS. ONE IS WITH THE
MIDDLE OF THIS TRANSITION WHICH
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS MEASURE
ARE TRYING EARNESTLY
INAPPROPRIATELY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH STORAGE.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE OUR
RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT'S NOT
RELIABLE AND WE'RE CHANGING THE
SYSTEM AND YOU GOTTA HAVE IT
MAKES TOTAL SENSE I GET IT.
ON BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE
QUESTION IS AT WHAT PRICE.
AT WHAT PRICE.
ARMED WE NOW HAVE IS WAS
EXPRESSED THE COMPRESSION ON ON
RATES WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE IN
WILD FIRES BY.
WE'VE GOT THIS ISSUE WHERE DO
YOU WANT TO SPEND ALL THIS MONEY
TODAY I'M TOLD THE TAKES THREE
PLUS YEARS TO GET THIS PROJECT
BUILDS WHEN A AS THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT STAFF CONCLUDED THAT
THERE'S ENOUGH LEAD TIME BEFORE.
TWENTY THIRTY UNDER THE FORTY
TWO MM T. SCENARIO THAT THE
PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES DO NOT
NEED TO BEGIN IN THIS AYE ARE
PETE -- CYCLE SO ISTHERE A NEED
WE'RE UP AGAINST THIS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM I'M SITTING
HERE AND THEN SO WE'RE DOING TWO
BIG THINGS IN TRMS OF MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS AT THIS TIME.
ONE IS WE ARE IS ICY AT WE NEED
TO REALLY FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH
RATE PRESSURES IN THE YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE THE FIRES AND
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE.
IN TWO WE ARE WHETHER YOU CALL
IT STORAGE OR TRANSMISSION OR
WHATEVER WE ARE OPENING A VERY
BIG BACK DOOR TO THE FORK THAT
WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING.
FOREVER IN LETTING THEM COME IN
AND SET RATES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE FOUR DOES NOT CARE ABOUT.
THE UNDERLYING POLICY ISSUES
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA THE FORK IS A
REGULATED BODY THAT'S JUST ABOUT
RELIABILITY WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT WHAT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT IN HIS
REPORT ON WILDFIRES.
IS HE'S HAS FIVE POINTS ONE IS
THE RELIABILITY AND COST PEACE
BUT ONE ALSO IS PROMOTING OUR
CLEAN ENERGY POLICIES NOW
CLEARLY WHAT THIS PROJECT IS
DOING IS DOING THAT.
THE BALANCE HERE IN TERMS OF
WHERE WE ARE TODAY YOU KNOW I
KNOW EAGLE MOUNTAIN WELL I
MEMBERS PRODUCT BACK TO THE WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE HIGH SCHOOL NO THE
PEOPLE FROM UP THERE AND BEEN
THERE MANY TIMES AND NOTE.
THIS PARTICULAR.
ALTHOUGH I RARELY AGREE WITH MR
WEIDEMANN WHO I SAW SPEAKER
TODAY.
YOU KNOW I A THE ISSUE IS DO DO
YOU I I DO YOU AND I JUST REYES
ONE COUPLE MORE POINTS HERE DO
YOU ACTUALLY NEED.
TO KNOWLEDGE THE ONE THING THAT
I'VE LEARNED BEING AROUND THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY BUSINESS FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
IS JUST THE EXTRAORDINARY RATE
OF CHANGE THE EXTRAORDINARY RATE
OF CHANGE THE REDUCTION IN COSTS
THE RATE OF CHANGE THAT'S
OCCURRING IN THE REAL BILL SPACE.
AND YES THIS CLEARLY 1100% MEETS
OUR GOALS WHAT DO WE HAVE A
WINDOW OR NOT CAN WE TAKE THIS
UP NEXT YEAR AFTER WE HAVE SOME
MORE INTELLIGENCE HOMEWORK.
I DON'T WANNA THROUGH OUT THE
WINDOW BECAUSE IT HAS A LOT OF
VALUE THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
I JUST THINK IT RAISES THE
QUESTION ABOUT.
THE WILDFIRES I THINK IT RAISE
THE QUESTION ABOUT.
FOR YOU KNOW AND SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE BALANCING WE'RE
SAYING OKAY THIS BILL WILL
POLICY SO IMPORTANT WE'VE COME
OUT WITH A PLAN TO SOLVE YOUR
NOBLE POLICY.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING OVER HERE
IS WE'RE SAYING WELL WAIT A
SECOND IT RUNS INTO ALL THE
STUFF WE FELT HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
DOING REGIONALIZATION OF STUFF
AND I JUST CLOSE ON THIS WELL
YOU KNOW I WOULD GOOD DEAR
FRIEND NAMED ONLY GOTTEN US WHO
SERVED IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH
ME HERE.
AND AND THEN WENT ON TO THE CITY
COUNCIL AND OVERSAW THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
A COMMITTEE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND I LEARNED GREAT
LESSONS FROM HIM BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS IS THAT UTILITIES ON
THE ONE HAND WE IN GOVERNMENT
AND IT'S IT'S JUST.
AN HONEST ASSESSMENT.
ARE TRYING TO MEET ALL THESE
POLICIES WITH THE END OF THE DAY
PRICE MATTERS TO PEOPLE IF THE
RATES GET TOO HIGH IF WE TAKE
ACTIONS TO ACHIEVE.
PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE
INTELLIGENT THOUGHTFUL
CONSISTENT VALUES BUT ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE PRICE SPIKES WE ALL
OF A SUDDEN SAY WITH WAY SECOND
WE'RE NOT SO SURE WE WANT TO DO
THAT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED
IMPACTS THEIR LIVES AND SO HERE
YOU HAVE THE YOU'RE GETTING TO
FORK.
THIS ABILITY TO DO THIS ON THE
ONE HAND.
ON IN SO YOU'VE BASICALLY WHAT
WE'RE FACING IS THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE OF
HONORABLE ATTENTION SEARCH THIS
IS NOT A PROJECT WHERE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING -- WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY TRYING. TO TO TO TO
IMPLEMENT EXACTLY WHAT WE SAID
WE WANT TO DO IN GOVERNMENT THEY
ARE EXACTLY FINDING THE WHOLE.
BUT THAT'S RUNNING UP AGAINST
THESE OTHER DYNAMIC SO I JUST
SURE THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
AN HONEST ASSESSMENT OF THIS YOU
KNW WITH IT IN TERMS OF HOW WE
DO THIS NEEDS TO LOOK AT THAT.
IN IN YOU MARRY THAT WITH THE
RATE OF CHANGE DO YOU WANT TO
SPEND.
THAT KIND OF MONEY I LEAVE IT TO
YOU TO DETERMINE WANTED YOU JUST
THANK YOU MISTER INTERFERE
DIRECT GENEROSITY AND WILLING TO
TAKE THE TIME.
TO SHARE THOSE THOUGHTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AGAIN -- OF THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE AUTHOR FOR
BEEN INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE
AND TAKING THIS ISSUE ON IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S AN ISSUE NEEDS TO
BE DISCUSSED THE MATTER THAT
NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT BEFORE THE
PUBLIC AND WE NEED TO DISCUSS
THE MERITS.
AND ALSO THE CHALLENGES FACING
IN OR OUR OUR ENERGY GRID.
I MEAN AS AS WERE AS WERE HERE
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WILDFIRE SEASON
KIND OF APPROACHING QUICKLY.
AND WE'RE ALL WORKING VERY HARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE WE LESSEN THE
FIRES AND WE HARDEN THE GRID ALL
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A COST.
WE UNDERSTAND THATWERE GOING TO
HAVE TO SOMEHOW.
GO BACK TO THE RATE PAYERS AND
AND ASK THEM TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THAT'S A THAT'S GOING
TO BE A VERY HARD THING TO DO
BECAUSE I ALREADY THINK.
THAT OUR OUR RATES ARE VERY HIGH
IN THE HAVE FINANCE THE
TRANSITION IT'S GETTING US TO A
BETTER PLACE.
HELPING TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
HELPING TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THINGS THAT ARE.
I THINK THE CENTRAL TO OUR
SURVIVAL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON BOARD.
WITH THIS WITH THIS -- WITH THIS.
THE STRATEGY AND IT'S HARDER TO
DO.
AS A STANDALONE STATE -- YOU
KNOW -- ONE OF FIFTY STATES --
TAKING AGGRESSIVE ACTION ON THIS
AND EVERYONE ELSE DOES SEEM.
TO SEE THE SAME URGENCY THAT WE
DO -- AND THIS IS OF THIS POLICY
IS KIND OF RESULTING FROM THE
FACT THAT WE NEED A BALANCE
[inaudible]
OUR GRID.
REPAIRS -- IN MY NECK OF THE
WOODS ALREADY SEEN THE FAT FACTS
OF AN IMBALANCE GRID -- RATES GO
UP ARE GOING UP IN THE EVENING
NOW RATES GO DOWN DURING THE DAY.
SO DEPENDING ON WHO YOU ARE YOU
HAVE TO ADJUST YOUR ENTIRE
LIFESTYLE TO KEEP YOUR BILL.
THE SAME.
AND IF THIS FOR SOME PEOPLE IT'S
A IT'S A CULTURE CHANGE IT'S AN
INCONVENIENCE.
IT ALSO IS AFFECTING YOUR
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO IF WE CAN WE CAN CREATE THE
PROJECTS THAT.
THAT HELPS BALANCE THAT.
I THINK PEOPLE.
WHAT WHAT WILL SUPPORT THAT BUT
AGAIN?
NO I I HAVE LOOKED AT I I HAVE
READ THE ANALYSIS AND SEEN --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS I I THINK
THE REASONABLE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE PROPONENTS ARE ARE ARE
ARGUING FOR I MEAN REGIONAL I
SEEN THE COST TO THE STATE MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE?
YOU CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE CHI SO AND THAT'S
THE THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THAT
AND IT MAKES SENSE I'D RATHER.
SHARE THE COST OF CREATING A
BALANCING WITH ALL OF
CALIFORNIAN AND JUST SAYING --
ZANE DIEGANS WERE ONLY GONNA
SHOULDER THE BURDEN OF LOVE ONE
MAJOR PROJECT [inaudible]
SO. FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SAYING NO WE CAN DO BETTER I'D
LIKE TO HEAR SPECIFIC
SUGGESTIONS.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED WE
NEED WE NEED YOUR YOUR
SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF HOW TO
DO THIS BETTER.
I I HOPE I WANT TO COULD SEE
THIS PROJECT CONTINUE FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THAT DEBATE AND I'M
HEARING FROM PEOPLE WE GOT
BETTER IDEAS OF TO DO LET'S WORK
ON THEM.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO FIND.
WE NEED TO FIND THE EFFICIENCY
WE NEED TO FIND THE SAVING BUT
WE NEED IN THE END THE THE
RESULT THIS BILL IS.
IS ACHIEVING TO OBTAIN WHICH THE
BALANCING OF OF THE WAY WE
PROCURE AND DISTRIBUTOR ENERGY.
IT NEEDS IT NEEDS TO WORK AND
RIGHT NOW PEOPLE SAYING THAT
THIS IS AN TIMELY I'M SORRY IF
THIS BILL GOT PASSED TODAY THIS
YEAR.
AND GOT SENT TO SIGN THIS YEAR
WE WOULDN'T SEE THE FIRST
PROJECT. FOR THE VERY LEAST VERY
LEAST FIVE YEARS.
WHERE WE GONNA BE IN FIVE YEARS
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A MUCH?
DIFFERENT PLACE TO BE A GREATER
SENSE OF URGENCY IN FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL IT GETS US OFF ON A
PATH THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
APPROVE ONE PROJECT OR ANOTHER.
SO IF YOU'RE YOU'RE.
IF YOU'RE ARGUING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF ANY
PARTICULAR.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A PROCESS BY
WHICH THESE PROJECTS ARE PROVING
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AND THERE WILL BE A PROCESS TO
APPROVE THAT.
THIS THIS BILL TODAY DOES NOT
APPROVE ANY SPECIFIC ANYONE
PROJECT.
IT IT MAKES IT POSSIBLE FOR SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS TO PRE
APPROVED I UNDERSTAND THAT
[inaudible]
BUT AGAIN.
THEY STILL HAVE TO SHOW THAT
THEY HAVE THEY WILL NOT AFFECT
THE ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE WE WE HAVE A PROCESS FOR
THAT AND AND THIS BILL THIS BILL
DOES NOT WEAKEN THAT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
THAT PROCESS OR WEAKENED IT OR
GIVE.
THESE PROJECTS.
OF ANY DIFFERENT STANDING
ENVIRONMENTALLY THAN THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE SO -- I WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU CENTER BRADFORD IN
TERMS OF ADVANCING THIS BILL AND
WORK WITH -- THE OPPONENTS OF
THIS BILL TO SEE IF THERE ARE.
BETTER WAYS TO DO THIS.
AS YOU SAY THAT THERE ARE.
AND IF YOU SAY WELL THIS IS NOT
THE BEST WAY TO NEVER MIND DON'T
DO AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S NOT
REALLY [inaudible]
OF A IS IN TUNE WITH WHAT THE
SITUATION WE ARE HERE.
IN OUR STATE I MEAN I HEAR OVER
AND OVER THE TOP CHART THE DUCK
CHART THE DUCK CHART.
AND IF YOU'RE IN SOLAR THE DUCK
CHART IS YOUR ENEMY.
AND IF YOU FIND A WAY TO ADDRESS
THE IF YEARS SOLAR POWER IF
YOU'RE IN ANY KIND OF RENEWABLE
POWER THE DUCK CHART IS YOUR
ENEMY.
AND UNLESS YOU USE ALL THE DUCK
CHART THERE WILL BE NO.
NEW PROCUREMENT.
IN THOSE INDUSTRIES.
SO ARE THIS IS A TOUGH ONE AND
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A OF A LOT
OF A CHALLENGES GOODNESS THROUGH
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS A A A CONTROVERSIAL
PROCESS BUT I WANT TO HELP YOU.
AT LEAST ADVANCED ADVANCE THIS
OF AND SEE WHERE WE CAN GET --
TO THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF A
LOT OF BILLS COMING THROUGH THIS
YEAR AND A LOT OF ACTION.
ON ON WALL FIRES AND ON THE ON
ON THE FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
OUR OF OUR OF OUR A LOT
ELECTRICAL COMPANIES.
SO THIS IS GOING TO GET INTO A
REALLY BIG MACS AND AND AT THE
END OF THE YEAR I HOPE.
THAT WE SUCCESSFULLY SORT IT OUT
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA BE A REALLY
TOUGH YEAR.
ON ALL THIS STUFF RELATED TO
ENERGY AND OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR FORESTS.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO.
IT'S IT'S HARD TO DO FROM THIS
DíAS TODAY.
WITHOUT REALLY LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING IN COMBINATION BUT I
THINK.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE IT OUR BEST
SHOT THIS YEAR SENATOR SKINNER
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DODD.
AND SENATOR RUBIO AND THEN
CENTER STUFF START.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND FORCE.
FORCED TO THE AUTHOR -- I
SUPPORT BALK [inaudible]
ENERGY STORAGE [inaudible]
AND MY PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS HOW
THE BILL'S CONCERT [inaudible]
IS THAT.
IT IS NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
AND IF WE IF OUR INTEREST IS
TRYING.
TO CREATE THE PLEXIGLAS IT'S TO
BE ABLE TO DO THE BRIT
INTEGRATION -- THAT WE KNOW WE
NEED.
THEN I THINK -- SOME AMENDMENTS
OR AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD ALLOW.
FOR MORE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY
WHICH DOES NOT ELIMINATE.
I'M PUMPED HYDRO FOR ELIMINATE A
PARTICULAR PROJECT THAT MAYBE
BEING CONTEMPLATED IT DOESN'T
ELIMINATE THOSE BUT IT AT LEAST
IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT SOMETHING
IN THE STATUTE.
ALSO PROVIDES.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES AND I THINK WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO DO -- YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
CRITICISM THAT THE ART PS WAS
NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL ENOUGH
BUT WE WE HAVE AT LEAST TRIED IN
OTHER OF OUR BILLS.
LIKE A TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN THE
ORIGINAL STORAGE BILL. TO MAKE A
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL NOW
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENED IS --
THE P. YOU SEE IN THERE
ADMINISTRATION OF IT EXCLUDED
PUMP HYDRO.
SO THE WITH THIS BILL.
WE COULD MAKE A TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL BUT STILL WE ARE SENDING
A CLEAR SIGNAL THAT WE ARE NOT
EXCLUDING PUMP HYDRO SO I WOULD
BE FAR MORE COMFORTABLE.
IF WE HAD -- LANGUAGE THAT DID
THAT.
AND ADDITIONALLY I THINK THE ARE
REQUIRING IT TO BE THE A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF MEGAWATTS IS PARTLY.
WHAT CONTRIBUTED TO IT NOT BEING
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND I THINK
IN TERMS OF THE COST?
BY LOWERING THE MEGAWATTS BUT
ALLOWING SOME FLEXIBILITY TO GO
HIGHER [inaudible]
IF I'D.
THE R. P. YOUR I. SO SEIZE NEED
FOR IT.
IT BEGAN DOES A LITTLE MORE RATE
PAYER PROTECTION.
AND THEN FINALLY THE CONCERNED
ABOUT FOR I THINK AND I SO IS
VERY LEGITIMATE WHEN I THINK
ABOUT LAST YEAR OUR DEBATE
AROUND -- WHETHER WE WOULD
REGIONAL I START THREADS.
AND IF YOU'RE THAT IF WE WERE TO
DISMANTLE THE CALL HI SO AS AS
IT IT IS CURRENTLY --
CONSTRUCTED THAT WE WOULD BE
INVITING BURKE FURTHER INTO OUR
DIRECTLY INTO OUR FAIRS.
WE KNOWN THAT.
FOR BASICALLY IS THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY OF OUR CAL I SO.
BUT ANYTHING WE EXPAND IN TERMS
OF THAT ROLE CAL SO I SO WE ARE.
IN FACT EMPOWERING FOR THAT MUCH
MORE.
SO -- WHETHER IT WILL HAVE THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THAT SOME
FEAR.
CAN'T DETERMINE BUT CERTAINLY IF
ARE CONCERNED IS THAT -- FIRST
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S INTERESTS NUMBER
ONE IT HARD.
IT IS.
IT IS -- IT CONSTITUENTS TURNING
TO HAVE LANGUAGE THAT SO
DEFINITIVELY -- IT INVITES BURKE
IN THIS WAY SO THOSE WOULD BE MY
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY CONSTRUCTED.
KERRY HAD A BIKE AND SENATOR
SKINNER VERY GOOD POINTS -- IF I
COULD.
I'M SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT IS MISSING
IN A REGULATORY GAP RIGHT NOW
OUR LARGE PROJECTS
INFRASTRUCTURE SCALE PROJECTS.
ARE TWO TWO LARGE FOR ANY LOAD
SERVING ENTITY TO PER CARE -- IF
WE MAKE THE PROCESS THE BILL
SMALLER THERE'S NOTHING IN OUR
CURRENT MARK STRUCTURE THAT
KEEPS PEOPLE FROM BUYING SMALLER
SCALE PROJECTS TODAY.
ON THE P. YOU SEE ANALYSIS THAT
LOOKED AT THE THIRTY MILLION TEN
CARBON CENTER WHICH IS NOT THE
ONE THEY DOCTOR THEY DROPPED A
HIGHER CARBON TARGET SO FOR KIDS
STAYING AT HIGHER CARBON TARGETS
YOU DON'T YOU DON'T NEED THIS
BILL.
BUT IF FOR DRIVING TOWARD OUR
CARBON GOALS THERE IS AN
ANALYSIS OUT OF THE PC AND THE
CDC THAT TALKS ABOUT THE NEED
FOR STORAGE TO SUPPORT FOR
INCREASES IN SOLAR.
THE ECONOMY'S THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF BOOK ENERGY STORAGE WHICH IT
FOUNDED EVERY SCENARIO. FOR
AGGRESSIVE CARBON REDUCTIONS WAS
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE OPTIONS
THAT WAS BASED ON SIZE.
SO WE THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
MARKET KEEPING SMALLER PROJECTS
OUT TODAY IN FACT THIS IS A
SMALL PROJECT MARKET.
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
CAPTURE THE COST EFFICIENCIES OF
LARGE PROJECTS THAT'S WHY YOU
NEED THIS BILL.
SO I WOULD ALSO POINT ON THAT ON
THAT DEFINITION THAT WAS A
NEGOTIATED -- DEFINITION WITH
THE ENERGY STORAGE ASSOCIATION
THAT REALLY WAS CRAFTED TO ALLOW
IT TO MAKE IT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
AND I WOULD POINT OUT THAT WHILE
THERE YOU DO HAVE PUMP STORAGE
PROJECTS SUPPORTING THE BILL.
YOU ALSO HAVE COMPRESSED AIR AND
YOU HAVE -- NEXT TRUCKER WHICH
IS A LONG DURATION FLOW BATTERY.
I DID WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS BILL IS VERY LONG TERM THE
SINISTER GOING TO SEE A PROJECT
ON LINE IS TWENTY THIRTY THE
CYNOSURE GOING TO SEE ANY
PROJECT HAD RATES IS TWENTY
THIRTY THESE ARE TEN YEAR
CONSTRUCTION CYCLES.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE BILL
OR TRIED TO DO TO RECOGNIZE THIS
AS SENATOR HERTZBERG REYES
SOMETHING NEW CAN BE INVENTED.
THE SOME GREAT IDEAS OUT THERE
SO WHAT WE KNOW IS TO GET TO
THAT EVEN A MODERATE CARBON
TARGET AT THIRTEEN MILLION TONS
AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE HEADING
TOWARDS ZERO AFTER SB.
ONE HUNDRED YOU'RE GOING TO NEED
AT LEAST TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
A LONG DURATION STORAGE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND IF YOU GET TO
HIGH ELECTRIC.
SECTOR I'M TRANSMISSION
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR YOU'RE
GONNA NEED UP.
TO FOUR THOUSAND SO WHAT WE DID
IN THE BILL AND IN CANDIDATE
PROBABLY COULD'VE BEEN CRAFTED
BETTER SHE DO TWENTY THOUSAND
TWO THOUSAND BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH IS A NO BRAINER TO GET HER
CARBON TARGETS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE YOU HAVE A
SECOND TWO THOUSAND FOR YOUR
CARBON TARGET AT TWENTY FORTY
FIVE AND IF SOMETHING NEW IS
INVENTED IN THAT PERIOD IF THIS
TURNS OUT TO BE A BAD IDEA OR
SOMETHING.
SOMETHING HAPPENS YOU CAN WE
LOOK AT THAT.
AND THAT THERE WAS A POSSIBILITY.
COMES ALONG SOMETHING'S MORE
COST EFFECTIVE WE DECIDE TO STEP
BACK FROM THESE GOALS WHO KNOWS.
BUT THERE IS A PAUSE BUILT IN
THE BILL BUT WE GET THE TWO
THOUSAND ON BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH WE KNOW WE NEED TO REACH
AT LEAST THE MINIMUM AMOUNT.
OF LONG DURATION STORAGE TO
SUPPORT OUR OUR PS GOALS.
AND THEN WE LOOK AT THE SECOND --
TWO THOUSAND AND MAYBE EVEN THE
DEFINITION IF WE NEED TO BROADEN
NAPA DEFINITION IS NOT
TECHNOLOGY SPECIFIC BY INTENT
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE MULTIPLE
TECHNOLOGIES SUPPORTING THE BILL.
OKAY -- CENTER DOT.
YES -- YOU KNOW WHEN I CAME IN
HERE THIS MORNING I HAD EVERY
INTENTION TO VOTING FOR AND
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL I HEARD A
LOT OF YOUR OMMENTS -- HERE ON
IN OPPOSITION THAT CONCERNED ME.
I ALSO -- ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THAT.
YOUR SENATOR HERTZBERG -- IT
ALSO CENTER SKINNER VERY COGENT
POINTS THEY BRING UP IT LISTEN
TO MISS OUT OF X. -- YOU KNOW.
DESCRIPTION THE FACT THAT THIS
WOULD NOT HIT RATES IN TWENTY
THIRTY AND ALSO.
BECAUSE MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
SPOKE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ALSO SPOKE IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
NINE OH ONE IT WILL PROBABLY
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO WHATEVER
BACKSTOPS WE HAVE FOR UTILITIES
GOING FORWARD -- ON IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE THAT
REALLY AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE
NOT.
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT UTILITIES
ARE ONE COMPANY OVER THE OTHER
BUT THERE TO PROTECT RATE PAYERS.
SO I REALLY BELIEVE THAT I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY TO
LET IT GET OUT. TO ALLOW THE
OPPOSITION TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR -- ON REFINING
THIS BILL -- BUT YOU KNOW.
I I REALLY THINK IT'S IT'S IT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT -- YEAH THE
ASSEMBLY THE GOVERNOR YEAH WILL
BE BACKSTOPS TO THIS IF IT IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT AT THE END
OF THE DAY WITH WHAT WE'VE COME
UP WITH.
FOR UTILITY BACKSTOP THAT IT'S
YOUR CONCERN BUT THE FACT THAT
IT'S COMING UP -- IT WON'T HIT
RATES TOLD -- TWENTY THIRTY I
THINK WE DO HAVE SOME TIME -- TO
YOUR TO WORK WITH THIS BUT I DID
HAVE ONE QUESTION ON THIS BURKE
SITUATION.
THAT -- THE CONCERN ME AND I'M
WONDERING MISTER WEST COULD GIVE
SOME COMMENTS -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
ON THAT'S FINE THAT SITUATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR DIED SCOTT
WHICH TO BE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
I THINK THIS DISCUSSION AROUND --
FOR HAS GOTTEN A LITTLE MURKY.
FURK ONE THOUSAND ALREADY
APPLIES.
TO ALL THINGS TRANSMISSION HAS
BEEN IN PLACE NOW. FOR EIGHT OR
NINE YEARS.
SO IN THE IN THE OLD DAYS IF P.
JEANNIE FOR INSTANCE WAS GOING
TO BUILD A NEW TRANSMISSION LINE
AND IT WAS APPROVED BY CAL I SO.
IT STILL HAD TO BE APPROVED BY.
FOR AND FOR ACTUALLY TAKES OVER
THE BID PROCESS.
AND THERE HAS TO BE A COMPETITOR
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS THAT FOR
CONTROLS -- THIS BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT EVERY TERROR OF THE
IS SET ON THE TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM.
IS APPROVED BY FIRST WE DEAL
WITH FOR WORK ON A DAILY BASIS
THAT IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAN THE DISCUSSION AROUND
REGIONALIZATION WHICH HAD TO DO
WITH COMPLETELY SUBVERTING OUR
GOVERNMENTAL CONTROL OVER.
THE WHOLE DECISION AND PLANNING.
OF MAKING PROCESS THAT CAL IS SO
SO THIS BILL DOESN'T EXPAND AND
GIVE FOR KATIE GREATER REACH
INTO CALIFORNIA IT'S COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE ROLE THAT
FOR PLAYS EACH AND EVERY DAY
INTERACTING WITH CAL I SO. ONE
OTHER POINT I WANTED TO SAY TO
THE EXISTING PROCESS HOLD ON
JUST.
CENTER DOT DOT ARE YOU NOT.
OKAY YEAH -- SO YOU'RE LESS
ALONE.
I THINK YOU AND I APPRECIATED
THE THE QUESTION ABOUT FOR I HAD
THE SAME QUESTION I ALSO ONE IS
THE SE -- THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIRMAN FOR FOR HIS COMMENTS --
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAS BEEN THE
EPICENTER.
FOR REALLY ALL FORMS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AS A CHAIRMAN
KNOWS.
VAST SOLAR BASS GEO THERMAL VAST
WIND.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE A LARGE --
STORAGE PROJECTS AND IN MY
DISTRICT AND I HAVE ENJOYED
WORKING WITH -- THE AUTHOR I'M A
CO AUTHOR WITH THE BILL AND OF
COURSE WITH EVERY BILL WE ALWAYS
FIND IT OR SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND THIS IS WHY.
WE HAVE HEARINGS LIKE THIS TODAY
TO HEAR -- THE OPPOSITION SO I I
KNOW AND I'M CONFIDENT -- THE
SENATOR BRADFORD IS A MAN OF HIS
WORD HE'S GOING.
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND ALSO HE'S AWARE
OF THAT -- WE HAVE SOME TRIBAL
SACRED SITES -- IN ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL PROJECTS AT THIS COULD --
DEFINITELY -- IMPACT AND AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO TO WORK WITH THEM --
BUT IF IT LASER JENNIFER GONNA
MEET OUR CLIMATE -- GOALS AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A A LARGE
CADRE OF OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
FORMS OF ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND
I'M VERY PROUD THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HAS TAKEN A LEAD IN.
ON ALL OF THESE FORMS AND AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR AS WE MOVE THIS FORWARD --
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS SO THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR THINKING
OUT OF THE BOX AND AND AND
YOU'RE IN YOUR VAST ENERGY
BACKGROUND.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- I THINK I'M THEM
WITH WITH YOU.
IN IN IN YOUR AND THE THRUST OF
IT.
IN TERMS OF NEED TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
THE GAP THE DUCK CURVE -- THE
BROADER SORT OF QUESTION ABOUT
HOW TO GET THIS BE ONE HUNDRED
AND SOME -- JUST HOW DO YOU GET
THERE I MEAN REALLY I MEAN THAT
THAT'S YEAH I DON'T THINK WE
SOLVED THAT AND WE SOLVE MAYBE
THEY'LL LIKE 80% OR 65% I STILL
THINK WE SOLVE THE HUNDRED SO.
HI I DON'T I'M I'M A LITTLE.
I HESITATE ABOUT THE NUMBER
THOUGH I THINK IS FOUR THOUSAND
EVEN ENOUGH LIKE I I'M I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT.
WHAT'S DRIVING THAT ANSWER THE
TIMING THAT WAS MY FIRST
QUESTION FOR YOU ALL LIKE WELL
HOW DID HOW DID YOU GUYS COME OF
FOURTH. THOUSAND I MEAN IF IF
THE POPULATION KEEPS INCREASING
LIKE.
THEIR CHANCE WE'RE GONNA NEED
MORE AFTER THAT.
TWENTY THIRTY OR EVEN MORE
BEFORE TWENTY THIRTY IT JUST ONE
FOR SUCH AS NO THE LOGIC OF THAT.
AND CENTER SENT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I AM SO
[inaudible]
THE ANALYSIS IN THE STATE
WHETHER IT'S THE CPUC OR THE CC
DID SOME REALLY GOOD WORK LAST
SUMMER AND THEIR DEEP DEEP
CARBONIZATION STUDY THAT LOOKED
AT CARBON TARGETS ACROSS OUR
ECONOMY -- IN THE FOUR THOUSAND
IS DERIVED FROM THOSE TO THE CCC
THE CPUC STUDY LOOKED AT TWO
THOUSAND TO FOUR THOUSAND BASED
ON A THIRTY MILLION TIME CARBON
TARGET MEMBER WORDS ZERO NOW
AFTER SB.
ONE AND SO THEY FOUND THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BUT WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWO ONE FOUR
THOUSAND IT'S THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRIFICATION WE HAVE IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
PREDOMINANTLY AND HOW MUCH
NATURAL GAS WE KEEP ON THE
SYSTEM.
SO THAT FOUR THOUSAND IS
SOMEWHAT ARTIFICIAL -- IT WAS
ASSUMING REALLY TECH THEY WERE
LOOKING AT PUMP STORAGE NOT THE
BROADER SET OF LONG DURATION
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD
COME FRWARD.
AND THAT WAS JUST BASED ON
GEOGRAPHY PUMP STORAGE IS YOU
KNOW GEOGRAPHIC LOGICALLY DRIVEN
AND SO IT THEY LOOKED AT THE
NUMBER OF MY UNDERSTANDING IS
EAT THREE LOOKED AT THE NUMBER
PROJECTS IN THE FORK LICENSING
AND SAID FOUR THOUSAND IS THE
GEOLOGICAL MAX IN THE STATE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
WON'T NEED MORE LONG DURATION
STORAGE IT DOESN'T MEAN OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES MIGHT NOT COME
FORWARD AND COULD SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
BUT I THINK I THINK YOU'RE YOUR
POINT IS REALLY WELL TAKEN.
HOW WE GONNA GET THERE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT THE SILVER BULLET
RIGHT IF YOU ADOPT THIS BILL?
THAT'S IT'S GONNA ESSENTIALLY A
QUAKE TO ABOUT THREE POINT THREE
MILLION TONS OF CARBON REDUCTION
A YEAR WHAT SEVENTY TWO GOING.
TO ZERO SO THIS IS.
ONE OPTION AMONG MANY YOU'RE
GONNA NEED ENERGY EFFICIENCY
YOUR NEED TO MANNER SPONSORED
ANY BETTER OPTIMIZATION IN OUR
MARKET.
WE'RE GONNA NEED A DIVERSITY OF
OUR RENEWABLE RESOURCES FOR CAN
MEET A LOT OF THINGS INCLUDING
SOME SHORT DURATION STORAGE IN
SOME LOCATIONAL FOR MARCH.
SO THIS IS JUST ONE AMONG
MANAGER.
SO SO THE OTHER TWO ISSUES THAT
BEEN RAISED BY THE MEMBERS I
MEAN I IS THERE A PATH HERE CAN
WE CAN WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT AT
LEAST SOME WAY TO STRUCTURE THIS
WHERE.
WE'RE NOT ARBITRARY CAPPING OURS
ARBITRARILY CAPPING OURSELVES
WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS
PROPORTIONALITY ISSUE WHICH I I
I APPRECIATE WHAT THE THE MUNY
EASIER SAY IN AND SORT OF WE
DON'T WANT THIS SOME SORT OF A
IT'S IT'S GONNA BE UNEVEN WHO
WHO NEEDS WHAT.
AND SO I'M I'M SENSE IT I THINK
ACTUALLY WIND BROUGHT IT UP TO
THAT SORT OF TAILORING IT TO TEN
NEED AND THAT SORT OF
PROPORTIONALITY CONCEPT.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE BLOWS UP
THE BILL.
THE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY SEEMS
LIKE THAT'S GOING TO GIVE YOU
SPACE I DON'T THINK FRANKLY YOU
WANNA SINGLE PROJECT BILL AND I
THINK THAT.
GOT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT.
THAT -- AND I I APPRECIATE YOU
MENTIONED COMPRESSED AIR STORAGE
BUT YOU'RE HERE SO I JUST THINK
FOR THE INTEREST OF FOR JUST HOW
WE MOVE POLICY.
WE SHOULD TRY TO FIGURE THAT ONE
OUT LIKE WHY DAILY CYCLE OF
DISCHARGE LIKE WHY IS THAT THE
THE METRIC -- WHY A FOUR HUNDRED
AND NOT THREE HUNDRED OR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OR TWO HUNDRED OR
I MEAN I I APPRECIATE YOUR
SAYING SMALL CAN GET IN NOW BUT?
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT ONE ALSO
FEEL SORT OF ARBITRARY AND PUMP
STORAGE ORIENTED SO DOES THE
FOUR THOUSAND YOU SAID THE FOUR
THOUSAND DRIVE FROM A FOR PROMPT
STORAGE.
STATE ANALYSIS AND THEN LET'S
JUST LET'S SHADOW THAT LET'S
HAVE THIS RELIABILITY
CONVERSATION MAKE THIS THING IS
SOME WE CAN BE PROUD OF I MEAN I
I WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS THING I
JUST.
I NEED TO GET A SENSE OF WHERE
WERE YOU GUYS WOULD WANT TO GO
HERE AND HOW GRANULAR YOU WANT
TO GET TODAY AND I DON'T WANT TO
CONTRAVENE THE CHAIR EITHER IN
ANY WAY I MEAN I JUST.
I WANT A LITTLE MORE CERTAINTY
BEFORE I VOTE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
LIKE ALL RIGHT.
THUMBS UP AND THEN OFF WE GO SO.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR MAN TO TO
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS TODAY WERE
NOT WE DON'T HAVE THAT BUT IT'S
THE ONGOING DISCUSSION A
COMMITMENT WE MADE AND IT'S
REFLECTED IN.
THE CHAIRMAN'S COMMENTS AS WELL
THAT WE'RE COMMITTING TO WORK.
WITH ALL OF THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL THE
WEEK WEEK WE'VE BEEN PROMISED A
THREAD THE NEEDLE.
AND ADDRESS EVERYTHING TODAY BUT
WE'RE CONTINUING AS WE ALL KNOW
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
ANY PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN
SOMETHING AS COMPLEX AS THIS
THERE ARE SO WE'VE HEARD TOO
CONCERNED VERY CLEAR AND IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT MISTER MAY
THAT.
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO TO MOVE
FORWARD AND THAT'S A COMMITMENT
I CAN MAKE THAT WE WERE.
WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO ADDRESS ALL
THOSE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
I JUST I NEED MORE I CAN'T I
CAN'T GET THERE I CAN'T GET
THERE IN THIS I KNOW.
THAT WE'RE NOT LIKE SOME OF THE
I KNOW THE FINER POINTS ARE HARD
TO DRILL DOWN ON RIGHT HERE FROM
THE DICE BUT LIKE.
I CAN'T I CAN'T BE THERE UNLESS
I KNOW WHERE THESE HAVE A SENSE
EVEN FROM THE SPONSORS OR OR
LABOR WHOMEVER.
WE WANT TO BUILD YES WE WANT TO
DO LONG DURATION BOOKSTORES YES.
BUT TOO MANY TIMES EVEN TODAY
THE WORD PROJECT HAS BEEN SET.
AND THAT'S NOT THAT DOESN'T WORK
LIKE I PEOPLE ARE SLIPPING --
PROJECTS WITH THE KIDS IN
PROJECT THOUGH THOUGH HE FALLING
INTO THAT THAT'S I CAN'T I CAN'T
DO THAT -- SO WHAT WHAT I MEAN
JUST FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THERE SOME SIGNAL YOU CAN GIVE
US IN TERMS OF JUST KINDA
ITERATING WHERE YOU WANT TO HEAD
OR WE JUST GOTTA KINDA.
LAY OFF AND LET THIS THING OF
ALL OF I DON'T KNOW  DON'T LIVE
NEAR THE TWO PROJECTS OF THE
MANSION.
SO SAN DIEGO BUT YEAH WELL ALL --
WHAT WAS THAT THERE SO?
THEY'RE NOT EVEN THERE THEY'RE
NOT EVEN CLOSE I MEAN THEY JUST
GOT STARTED.
I MEAN I APPRECIATE THAT THE
GETTING STARTED BUT I DON'T KNOW
I JUST SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A WAY.
TO IRON OUT AT LEAST A DIRECTION
SO I KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING.
I DON'T MEAN.
TO ALL RIGHT BE A PAIN VERY WELL.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE CLOSING
COMMENTS ARE I WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE.
TO OF FIRST LET ME THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK IN
YOUR STAFF WORK AND ALLOWING US
TO BE HERE THIS MORNING.
AND LET ME STATE.
I DIDN'T RUSSIAN TO TAKE THIS.
A MEASURE BECAUSE OF JUST WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
AND FROM MY PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE
BUT IT'S ALMOST LIKE DEJA VU ALL
OVER AGAIN BECAUSE MANY OF THE
SAME CONVERSATIONS WE WERE
HAVING IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AS WE PASSED
SB.
THREE THREE THIS IS THE MEDIAN
OUR PS BILL AND WE CONSCIOUSLY
MADE ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE BUCKETS
AND HOW CAN STE -- RESTRICTIVE
IT IT WAS AND HOW -- TECHNOLOGY
SPECIFIC IT WAS IN PER SCRIPT IF
IT WAS AND I WAS TRYING TO
BROADEN THAT DISCUSSION AND SAY
LET'S ADD IN RUN OF HYDRO FROM --
BC ALL NO WE CAN'T HAVE THAT
WERE SENT LET'S LOOK AT OUT OF
STATE -- GENERATION NO WE CAN'T
HAVE THAT IT ALL HAS TO BE IN
STATE AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OF SOME THE CONSTRICTIVE
RESTRICTIVE LEGISLATION THAT WE
PASSED IN A FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WHEN WE STARTED THIS WHOLE OUR
P. S..
DISCUSSION.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOW
FIGHTING AMONGST EACH OTHER AT
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WORK FOR
UTILITY I REMEMBER THE SAME
ENVIRONMENTAL.
FRIENDS WHO ASKED FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY TO ASK FOR WIND AND SOLAR
WERE THE SAME ONES WERE OPPOSING
THE TAX SHOULD BE POWER LINES
AND THE SUN RISE POWER LINES ON
A TO AND YOU'RE GOING.
TO HAVE TO BE BUT HOW DO WE GET
THE POWER FROM WHAT WE BUILT THE
SOLAR FARMS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT SO.
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE THAT
DANCE BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW THE NEED E. N. COST AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT TO RATE
HAWK IT IS BEEN ME AND I WAS
VERY.
YOU KNOW ADAMANT ABOUT WHAT WE
WERE DOING ELEVEN YEARS AGO.
WHAT OUR PS WHAT WE DID EIGHT
YEARS AGO WHAT OUR PS WHAT THAT
MEANT TO RATE PAYERS AND NO ONE
SEEMED TO CARE AT THAT TIME BUT
NOW THE SAID?
REPAIRS ARE ALWAYS AT THE FRONT
OF DISCUSSION AS WE TRY TO
EXPAND WHAT WE STARTED.
AND WHAT STARTED OUT AS
SEVENTEEN CENT A KILOWATT HOUR
ON SOLAR IN SOME PLACES WAS
TWENTY FIVE WE ARE NOW DOWN TO
FIVE CENTS A KILOWATT BECAUSE OF
TIME AND GROWTH IN INDUSTRY TO
GROW.
SO AGAIN.
FIRST PROJECT WON'T COME ONLINE
TO TWENTY THIRTY WILL HAVE.
PLENTY TIME TO ADVERTISE THIS
AND AND AND AND AND AND AND COST
IT OUT TO SEE WHAT IT IS WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO IMPACT REPAIR.
LE HAS IMPACTED REPAIRS OF THE
LAST TEN YEARS AS OUR MOVE FROM
COMBINED HEAT AND POWER ARE
MOVED FROM A GAS ARE MOVED FROM.
HYDRO TO WIND AND SOLAR THAT'S
WHAT DROVE UP TO COST.
OUR DESIRE TO BECOME GREEN
CLEAN
AND EFFICIENT.
IT IS A COST FOR THAT.
AND IT'S GONNA BE A COST FOR
THIS AS WELL BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE WANT TO BE MINDFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND ALL THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
FACTORY AND AGAIN I TO RUSH TO
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL COME
BEFORE US AND WE'LL HAVE THAT
SAME DISCUSSION AGAIN.
AS TO HOW DOES IT WORK WHO PAYS
FOR IT YOU KNOW.
WHO BENEFITS WHO SUFFERS BUT ACT
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR TO
TAKE ON THE TOUGH ISSUES I
REMEMBER SENATOR SKINNER WHEN
SHE HAD WON THE LARGEST BATTERY
STORAGE BILLS?
YOU KNOW AND WE'VE TRIED TO MAKE
THAT WORK.
THE WHAT WHAT WE WILL IF WE
STORED YOUR STORED OKAY
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL BUT YES IT
WAS BUT WE WERE WE WERE WORKING
ON THAT THE TWO ONE WEEK WE JUST
COULDN'T THREATEN NEED ON THAT
BUT IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T AND WE'RE HERE TODAY.
DOING MUCH OF WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT. EIGHT YEARS AGO.
SO IT'S ABLUTION OF PROCESS AN
AUNT AND DEVELOPMENT AND I THINK.
WE ALL MUST AGREE IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE AS GREEN AS WE COME --
COMMITTING AN AS CLEAN AS WE ARE
COMMITTING.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
YOU KNOW LARGE STORAGE LIKE THIS
IS GONNA TAKE POP POP HI JOE
IT'S GONNA TAKE YOU GEO THERMAL
PROJECTS AT THIS OUR CHAIRMAN
HAS ADVOCATED FOR IT'S GONNA
TAKE A VARIETY BUT AGAIN WE'RE
FIGHTING EACH OTHER NOW BECAUSE
OF HOW RESTRICTIVE.
AND HOW PRESCRIPTIVE.
OUR OUR PS WAS IN ITS INFANCY
AND HOW IT IS OF OFF SO ON THAT
NOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT
[inaudible]
MOTION.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN SEVEN TO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESO FIVE WEST SO
I MORE LOCK BRADFORD FART
BRADFORD I'D CHIANG.
DODD.
DODD I HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
IF I MAY CHERYL QUICKLY I'M
SORRY HOW TO STEP OUT TO A RALLY
THAT WE WERE HAVING OUTSIDE IS
IT APPROPRIATE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
CALL RUBIO AGAIN.
OR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AGAIN.
AT MORE LACK CHIANG.
HERTZBERG HILL.
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
GET RUBIO AYE AYE SKINNER STERN
WIENER.
WE'LL LEAVE IT THERE THE ROLE OF
THE PROPS MEMBERS I THINK.
I WILL CHECK UP SENATOR NIELSEN
HAS BEEN WAITING VERY PATIENTLY --
AND WHILE WHILE WE DO THAT WE'RE
GONNA CHANGE -- CHAIRMAN OF OF
THE COMMITTEES THIS IS SO I CAN
PRESENT A BILL CENTER DOT.
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN RUNNING
[inaudible]
YEAH SURE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
CENTER NIELSEN I'D ITEM NUMBER
TWO SP.
SEVENTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN FOR
THE INDULGENCE OF WORKING WITH
THIS IS WE PREPARED.
THE BILL.
THE RIDE WITH THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY.
I WOULD REQUEST UNFAVORABLE.
THIS ADDRESSES ISSUES RELATED TO
THE CATASTROPHIC.
WILDFIRES VETERANS.
AND GULPING OUR STATE.
INCREASINGLY.
OF INCREASING SEVERITY.
MANY OF US OF VERY PERSONALLY
DOES LEGISLATORS.
THE HALF OF OUR CONSTITUENTS HAD
TO CONTEND THE DEAL WITH THESE
OVER THE YEARS.
THERE WILL BE MANY.
BILLS PROPOSED TO ADDRESS IT.
THIS ONE ADDRESSES.
A PARTICULAR AREA.
BY REQUIRING THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS.
TECHNICALLY INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. TO REPLACE THE ABOVE
GROUND DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS.
WITH UNDERGROUND RELIANCE
WHEREVER THIS MIGHT BE
PHYSICALLY.
POSSIBLE AND FEASIBLE.
IN AREAS WHERE IT WOULD BE OF
GREATEST HELL.
AND CONSISTENTLY SB. NINE OH ONE
PLANTS THAT THEY'VE HAD PUT INTO
PLACE.
IT ALSO WOULD CREATE A WORKING
GROUP TO ASSIST IN DIRECTING THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF A PLAN. FOR GOING UNDERGROUND.
WHERE WE CAN?
IN OUR CASE A MILLION GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS. FOR THAT
PARTICULAR PURPOSE.
AGAIN I EMPHASIZE THAT. TO CUT
DOWN ON THE DISASTROUS WILDFIRES
MANY THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
HAPPENING.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY WILL ALL FIT TOGETHER
HOPEFULLY [inaudible]
TO LESSON.
THE BURDEN AND THE COST.
WHAT'S YOUR INCREDIBLE.
FIREFIGHTING COSTS OF THIS YEAR
AROUND [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. ELEVEN POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS COST INSURERS TO
THIS POINT.
IN OVER FORTY SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL CLAIMS.
JUST DEALING.
WITH LAST YEAR.
MANY OF THESE FIRES OVER DECADES
HAVE BEEN IGNITED.
BY THE YEAH FOR STRUCTURE
FAILURES.
LINES COMING DOWN FOR EXAMPLE
[inaudible]
PARKING FIRES.
THAT WAS A CONCERN.
AND THE DOOR.
IN THE CAMP FIRE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THEN.
OUR SAFETY TO THE DEGREE THAT WE
CAN [inaudible]
AND THE ASSURANCE OF CONTINUED
SERVICE WHICH IS ALSO BEEN VERY
DISRUPTED THIS YEAR AND VERY
PROBLEMATIC.
WOULD LIKE TO TRY.
TO REDUCE THESE HAZARDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES BY UNDER GROUNDING
WHERE WE CAN'T.
THEY'RE ALWAYS CONCERNS ABOUT
UNDER GROUNDING IN THE COSTS BUT
I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO WEIGH
THESE CONCERNS.
WITH THE OVERALL MACRO COSTS IN
MANY FRONTS [inaudible]
THESE FIRES.
ARE IMPOSING ON US.
AND CONSIDER.
WHAT? TO WHAT DEGREE THE
UNDERGROUND AND WILL ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THAT VULNERABILITY.
IT ALSO WOULD HELP US WITH THE
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWNS THERE
HAVE BEEN SO SEVERE WITH MANY
COMMUNITIES REMAINING ISOLATED
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME FROM
THEIR COMMUNICATION.
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S SO IT'S A WAY OF HARDENING
[inaudible]
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE [inaudible]
THE DID THE TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THAT HAVE.
BEEN SPENT AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS IMPACTING OUR RATE
PAYERS.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AND THAT
IS A MACRO EXPENSE.
THE STEALTH EXPANSE.
BUT A HUGE.
ONE NONE THE LESS.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT GONNA AGAIN BE.
LAYING OUT A PLAN TO UNDERGROUND
EVERYTHING.
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO LAY OUT A
PLAN.
UNDERGROUND WHERE WE CAN
[inaudible]
WORDS FEASIBLE [inaudible]
WORDS ECONOMIC.
WE'VE CONTINUED TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE LARGEST INVESTORS
UTILITIES TO DISCUSS WITH THEM.
THE ISSUES OF IMPLEMENTING IN.
MAKING THIS WORK.
AND RECENT AMENDMENTS WE'VE
TAKEN.
HAVE TIGHTENED THE PRESCRIPTIVE
NATURE OF UNDERGROUND AND THE
LINES AND CREATED SOME.
CARVE OUTS.
FOR THE PHYSICAL FEES VISIBILITY.
AND THEN INCORPORATED THE
PREVENTION PLANNING.
INCORPORATED IN.
SB NINE OH ONE OF LAST YEAR.
I AM INFORMED OF THE WE HAD DONE
WILL HAVE A DOCUMENT YET THAT
THE CAL CHAMBER HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THIS IS.
NOT JUST A COMMONSENSE.
SHORT SMALL STEP.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT STEP.
TOWARDS THE FUTURE.
AND IT IS AN AREA THAT WE HAVE
NEGLECTED NEGLECTED FRANKLY OVER
DECADES IN CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE IT'S A USEFUL AN
IMPORTANT TOOL.
AND I WITHIN THE THAT ASKED THE
BOARD VIA THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
US TO MOVE THIS BILL ALONG.
AND PERCY.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE --
AMENDMENTS WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I THANK YOU
FOR THAT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIS DOES STAFF PERSON OKAY.
ANY WITH ANY -- OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD -- SEALER
I'M IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE UNDER
GROUNDING -- APPEARS TO ME TO BE.
LIKE FOR BUILDING.
PUTTING LIFE BOATS ON THE TANK
PANIC AFTER ITS SALE TO FORD. TO
GET THERE IN TIME.
THERE'S A SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH I MADE A POSITION LETTER.
TO AND YOU WILL SEE A PHOTOGRAPH.
OF WIRE A SERVICE DROP.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SMUD
[inaudible]
AND DATA.
IN THERE I'M POINTING OUT.
THAT TO THAT SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED
THAT WAY HAVE THE HAVE THE
LOWEST COST.
AND FOR THE LONGEST TIME.
THAT SYSTEM WORKS VERY VERY WELL.
AND THEN WE REMOVED AN
INGREDIENT AT DE FACTO METHOD.
A VERY EFFECTIVE DE FACTO METHOD --
AND THAT WAS HAVING SOMEBODY
VISIT EVERY SERVICE CONNECTION
ONCE A MONTH.
WHEN YOU REALLY NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS?
I WAS AT A AT SMUD RATE WORKSHOP.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING IS
THEY'RE GOING TO RAISE RATES FOR
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION.
AND I PRESENTED I SHOULD OR
SHOULD HAVE BROUGHT THE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF THAT.
DATA SERVICE DROPPED.
AND THEY DIDN'T THEY TOLD THEY
TOLD ME THAT THIS IS RELATED TO
THE UNDERGROUND BECAUSE THAT'S
LIKE BUILDING LIFE -- FOR YOU
ARE YOU ARE YOU.
WHAT WHAT ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE
WHO WHO -- IT HASN'T HAD A FIRE
YET OR WHATEVER ELSE YOU NEED TO
FOCUS ON YOUTH CHANGE THE DESIGN
OF THE SYSTEM.
AND INADVERTENTLY REMOVE
SOMETHING THIS IS WHAT THE KIND
OF THINGS ACOSTA APOLLO.
THIRTEEN IT'S A KIND OF THE IT'S
THE KIND OF THINGS WHERE
SOMEBODY GETS C
CONSEQUENCE.
BECAUSE THEY THINK -- WE CAN DO
ALL THIS TO LIMIT TREE IN
WHATEVER.
YOU REMOVE THE FEATURE THAT WAS
DE FACTO THEY COULDN'T BILL THE
CUSTOMER YOU DON'T NEED ANY LAWS
THEN.
SOMEBODY WOULD GO TO EVERY EVERY
SERVICE DROP ONCE A MONTH TWELVE
TIMES A YEAR.
AND ANY LEASE CATCH THAT PART
AND IF THE END THIS IS AN ENTRY
LEVEL JOB.
SO YOU'VE GOT SOMEBODY WAP UP
PLEASE OKAY I WANT EXPLAIN WHY
THIS IS IS IS OKAY WE NEED A
LONG EXPLANATION OKAY MAYWEATHER
STAND.
I AM DOING THIS ROUND ROUTE IS
IS NOT GIVING SOMEBODY A LIFE.
YOU'RE NOT CAPABLE IT'S TOO
COSTLY YOU ALREADY HAVE
UNDERGONE GAS.
IF THAT IS NOT THE PROBLEM.
THE CLIMATE IS NOT THE PROBLEM
YOU'VE YOU'VE.
CREATED AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THINKING THAT YOU'RE
MAKING SOMETHING BETTER THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS LEE S.
OVER THERE WITH THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE WERE INITIALLY IN
OPPOSITION -- PRIMARILY DUE TO
THE COSTS AND CONCERNS ABOUT
DUPLICATION WITH THE NINE ONE
PROCESS WINTERS IN THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE REALIZED
THAT THAT WAS ACTUALLY A
REDUNDANT TO PROVISION ANYWAY
AND SO.
I WAS.
REMOVED.
IT ANY -- OPPOSITION OTHER
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE BUT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR STONE --
TURN IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HEARING NO COMMENTS WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE SENATOR I WOULD SIMPLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
SB SEVENTY TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESO MORLOCK
BRADFORD CHIANG DODD AYE DODD
AYE HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
HI RUBIO ICE SKINNER STERN STONE
STONE AYE WIENER.
NEEDS FOR THE WRESTLING OKAY
WITHOUT WHEELS ON CALL THANK
SENATOR.
THE FIRST CENTER JACKSON WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
FORTY SIX GOOD MORNING.
THIS MORNING [inaudible]
STILL [inaudible]
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING UP MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS IS A SUBJECT ABOUT WHICH I
DON'T THINK I HAVE TO DO TOO
MUCH -- PERSUADING FOR SENATOR
DODD -- BUT THIS IS A BILL SB
FORTY SIX THAT EXPANDS MY ALERT
AND WARNING BILL FROM LAST YEAR.
WHICH WAS BROUGHT ON BY.
RESEARCH AND INFORMATION
PERTAINED.
PERTAINING TO THE FIRES UP IN.
THE CENTER DODGE DISTRICT AND
THEN SUBSEQUENTLY.
IN MY DISTRICT AND THEN OF
COURSE IN THE PAST YEAR AND JUST
ABOUT.
MANY OTHER DISTRICT HERE IN THE
STATE.
THIS BILL EXPANDS THAT A WAR --
ALERT AND WARNING SYSTEM BY
ALLOWING CITIES.
AND UNIVERSITIES TO
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL STUDENTS
RESIDENTS AND EMPLOYEES IN
LOCALLY OP.
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEMS WHILE
PRESERVING THEIR ABILITY TO OPT
OUT.
AND I AM TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE REFERENCED
IN THE ANALYSIS TO ASSURE.
THE COULD TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES THAT THEY ARE ONLY.
CALLED UPON TO PRODUCE
INFORMATION THAT IS IN THEIR
POSSESSION.
THAT ANY INFORMATION THAT MAY BE
MADE PUBLIC IS AGGREGATED
INFORMATION THAT DOES NOT
IDENTIFY AN INDIVIDUAL OR POSE A
SECURITY THREAT TO THE PUBLIC.
AND THAT NO PROPRIETARY BUSINESS
INFORMATION WILL BE DISCLOSED.
THESE AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE ALSO
MEET CERTAIN.
CONCERNS REGARDING THE USE OF
THAT INFORMATION.
KNOW WHAT IS IT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET WITH THE USE OF THAT
INFORMATION.
WE WANT TO FIND OUT WHETHER
THESE EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEMS
ARE WORKING.
ARE PEOPLE ACTUALLY RECEIVING
THE NOTICES THAT ARE GOING OUT.
TO WARN THEM OF DANGER TO LIFE
AND PROPERTY.
SO THIS MEASURE CLARIFIES THAT
ALERTING AUTHORITIES MAY USE
WIRELESS TELEPHONE SUBSCRIBER
DATA. FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS.
AND IT ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO IDENTIFY RESIDENTS WITH
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS IN
ORDER TO SEND THEM SPECIALIZED
EMERGENCY ALERTS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OPERATORS TO
ANNUALLY PRODUCE DATA.
CONCERNING THE PERFORMANCE OF
WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE USED TO
SEND THESE EMERGENCY ALERTS THE
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS.
MEMBERS WE KNOW OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS
HAVE BEEN AFFLICTED BY THESE
HORRIFIC WILDFIRES. TO THE COST
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
COST OF FAR TOO MUCH IN HUMAN
LIFE.
A COMBINATION OF YEARS OF
DROUGHT FUELS ACCUMULATION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DO SEVERE
WEATHER.
HAVE RESULTED IN WILDFIRES OF
ABSOLUTELY UNPRECEDENTED SIZE
AND INTENSITY.
THAT HAVE KILLED OVER A HUNDRED
PLUS CALIFORNIANS DESTROYED
THOUSANDS OF HOMES.
AND BURNED WELL OVER MILLION
ACRES.
THESE FREQUENT EVER FREQUENT.
LARGE SCALE WILDFIRES HAVE
FOCUSED ATTENTION ON HOW
CALIFORNIA WARNS THE PUBLIC
DURING AN EMERGENCY.
OUR WARNING SYSTEMS COME IN A
VARIETY OF FORMS AND EACH HAS
SPECIFIC CAPABILITIES AND
DRAWBACKS.
SYSTEMS RANGE FROM RELATIVELY
LOW TECH OPTIONS LIKE MAKING
DOOR TO DOOR ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ON FOOT FREQUENTLY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
KNOCKING ON YOUR FRONT OR BACK
DOOR.
WHICH I'VE HAD HAPPENED IN MY
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. TO
OUTDOOR WARNING SIRENS TO AUTO
DIALING TELEPHONE SECURE RELAY
DETAILED IN FROM EMERGENCY
INFORMATION TO HOUSES AND A
BLOCK BY BLOCK LEVEL. ONE OF THE
MORE MODERN ALERT SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE WEST
IS THE WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT
SYSTEM CALL WE ARE.
THIS IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION COMMISSION AND ALLOWS
MOBILE PHONE SUBSCRIBERS TO
RECEIVE GEOGRAPHICALLY TARGETED
TAX LIKE MESSAGES ALERTING THEM
OF IMMINENT THREATS TO THEIR
SAFETY.
IN THEIR AREA NOW WE A IS A VERY
GOOD SYSTEM AND IS BEING.
APPROVED BUT ACCORDING TO
EXPERTS IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
NOTIFICATIONS BE MADE IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT MODES IN
ORDER TO GROUP TO REACH THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF RESIDENTS.
SO WE CALL REDUNDANCY A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO NOTIFY
PEOPLE SOME WHO DON'T HAVE
WIRELESS SOME WHO DON'T HAVE A
LAND LINES.
IN THE OLD DAYS WE USED TO USE
THE CHURCH BELLS WELL OBVIOUSLY
WE LIVE IN A LITTLE FARTHER --
COMMUNICATIONS DURING THE THE
HEIGHT OF THE RED SCARE THE
RUSSIANS CARE WHICH I GUESS IS
NO LONGER RISKIER.
OUT WE HAD THE CONRAD SYSTEM
READ HIS HIGH PITCHED EMERGENCY
SOUND THAT WARNS YOU THAT THERE
WAS DANGER COMING AT SYSTEM
DOESN'T EXIST ANYMORE BUT IT HAS
BEEN SUPPLANTED IN SOME MEASURE
BY SYSTEMS LIKE THE WE ASSIST
THEM.
WE JUST NEED TO KNOW IS THIS
WORKING.
SO.
MANY JURISDICTIONS SUPPOSE
SUPPLEMENT THE WE IS SYSTEM WITH
THEIR OWN LOCALLY OPERATED
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS
IN ORDER TO CREATE THAT
REDUNDANCY AND TO ASSURE.
MORE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION
WITH RESIDENTS DURING EMERGENCY
THESE SYSTEMS SUCH AS NICK SOLAR
CODE RED.
IT CAN SEND PRE RECORDED
MESSAGES TO LAND LINE TELEPHONES
LOCATED WITHIN A DEFINED TARGET
AREA AS WELL AS TEXT AND VOICE
ALERTS TO MOBILE TELEPHONES.
GIVEN THE UNIQUE ABILITY TO
TARGET ALERTS USING PHYSICAL
ADDRESSES LOCALLY OPERATED
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS ARE AMONG
THE MOST PRECISE.
AND SAFEST WAYS TO GIVE PEOPLE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SO THE
PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THE PROBLEM IS
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND TO AVOID THE KIND
OF FEAR.
OF A MASSIVE ONSLAUGHT OF PEOPLE
HITTING THE ROADS WHICH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO OCCUR OF
PEOPLE ARE PRECISE IN THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
SO -- AGAIN THIS SUDDEN WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE REGISTRATION FOR
EXAMPLE OF MOBILE PHONES.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL RECENTLY AN
AUTOMATIC PROCESS.
MANY JURISDICTIONS STRUGGLE TO
GET RESIDENTS TO SIGN UP TO
RECEIVE AERTS THEY WERE OP THE
IN YOU HAD TO MAKE THE EFFORT
WHAT WE'VE DONE BY OUR PRIOR
LEGISLATION THAT I WANT TO
EXPAND ITS NOW AND OPT OUT
SYSTEM.
YOU WILL BE INCLUDED UNLESS YOU
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT
TO KNOW IF THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
IN MY AREA.
SO -- WHEN THE THOMAS FIRE BROKE
OUT IN MY DISTRICT LITERALLY
AFTER WE JUST CONCLUDED A
HEARING?
ON EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEMS IT
WAS THEN THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
THE HISTORY THE STATE THAT
STARTED IN DECEMBER ON HEARD OFF.
FEWER THAN 30% OF THE RESIDENTS
OF THE AFFECTED AREA HAD EVEN
SIGNED UP TO RECEIVE COUNTY
GENERATED CELLPHONE AN EAIL
ALERTS.
SO WE PASSED SB A TWENTY ONE
LAST YEAR -- THAT INSURED
RESIDENTS WHO DO NOT WISH TO
RECEIVE THESE ALERTS CAN OPT OUT.
OF THE MEASURE WAS A NECESSARY
BUT A FIRST STEP TOWARD
INCREASING THE PERCENTAGE OF
RESIDENTS WHO RECEIVE EMERGENCY
ALERTS FROM COUNTY OFFICIALS.
BUT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS WILL A BILL IS
DESIGNED TO DO -- I WON'T GO
INTO ANY GREATER DETAIL LIKE I
KNOW THAT THE THAT YOU ARE
PROBABLY ALL FAIRLY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS PROCESS BUT I DO HAVE
WITH ME TODAY RAYMOND REARED IN
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
FANTASTIC SIR.
THANK YOU ARNOLD COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PANELISTS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ARE HERE TODAY.
AND THANK YOU TO CENTER JACKSON
FOR OF PROPOSING THIS
LEGISLATION AND MOVING FORWARD.
ON BEFORE I STARTED SAN JOSE OF
AN EMERGENCY MANAGER AT SEVERAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVELS THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL SOME VERY FAMILIAR
WITH EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROTOCOLS AND ALERT AND WARNING.
IN MY THIRTY THREE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN A EMERGENCY MANAGER --
I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT -- AS
THE LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGER THE
CONCEPT OF WHAT THIS BILL.
PRESENTS AND PROVIDES FOR US --
ITS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS USING --
TELEPHONE DATA TO ACCESS AND
SEND INFORMATION OUT TO THE
PUBLIC TO WARN THEM OF THE
EMERGENCIES.
WE DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO SEE
THE FUTURE EVENTS CAUSED BY
PEOPLE NOT BEING NOTIFIED.
AND THE ASSISTANCE OF GETTING
THIS DATA WILL ASSIST US IN
GETTING THE RIGHT INFORMATION
OUT TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE THE
RIGHT TIME.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL THESE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS UNDERSTAND.
THEIR VULNERABILITIES AND
PROVIDE THE RIGHT ALERTING
WARNING SO THAT WILL PROVIDE
THEM A SENSE OF SECURITY.
THAT'S INTO MINE THANK YOU.
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR KLUCZBORK
HERE WE HAVE A SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WAS
DEVASTATED BY THE THOMAS FIRES.
AND I WANT TO MENTION THE RESULT
IN MUD SLIDES WITH FOLKS IN
ESSENCE WAKING UP AT THREE OR
FOUR IN THE MORNING -- WITH LIFE
THREATENING MUD SLIDES COMING
DOWN THE CANYONS WE THINK THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ENSURING EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM AN URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR I MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUBBER TO GO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES --
ONE I THINK THE THE CENTER
JACKSON'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
WE THINK THIS BILL HAS POTENTIAL
TO SAVE LIVES AND FOR THEIR FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ABERDEEN
ROSCOE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION --
CCT A IS OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE.
WHAT IT WOULD DO IS REQUIRE A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING?
USE USE YES SIR COULD YOU MAKE
ROOM FOR THE WITNESS BEHIND YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
UP WELL THIS -- MEASURE WOULD
REQUIRE COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
ON A THIRD PARTY PRIVATE VENDOR
OPERATE WROBEL CALLING MACHINE --
RIGHT NOW I THINK CENTER JACKSON
DID A VERY GOOD JOB EXPLAINING
THE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EMERGENCY ALERTS SO THE NATIONAL
LEVEL WE HAVE -- THE A. S. AND
THE EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM WHICH
IS BROADCAST ON RADIO AND
TELEVISION ON VIDEO AND THAT
GOES TO EVERYONE YOU DON'T NEED
A DATABASE YOU TAKE GOES OUT YOU
RECEIVED THAT NOTICE SAME THING
WITH WE A NOW THE WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERT ALSO
AUTOMATICALLY GOES OUT AND HIT.
CELL TOWERS YOU DON'T NEED A
DATABASE THAT GOES OUT AND
EVERYONE WAS SEND THE RANGE OF
THAT CELL TOWER WE'LL GET THAT
EMERGENCY ALERT.
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES IS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THERE ARE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED I'M HAVE WANT TO GO OUT
AND HIRE A THIRD PARTY VENDOR --
THAT WILL USE A DATABASE OF
WROBEL CALLING MACHINE.
THAT WILL INITIATE PHONE CALLS
FOR COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT RUBBLE CALLING
MACHINE IS JUST ANOTHER PHONE
CALL GOING THROUGH THERE'S NO
MEASUREMENT OF WHAT WE DO WE WE
WILL MONITOR TRAFFIC FLOW
GENERALLY AT OUR OPERATING
CENTERS.
BUT THIS IS THIS IS REALLY NO
OTHER TYPE OF NO DIFFERENT THAN
ANY OTHER PHONE CALL THIS GOING
OVER THE NETWORK.
SO WE ARE REQUIRED TO DO A
CONFERENCE REPORTING ON THE
METRICS OF THROUGH PUT AN ERROR
RATES THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
DEFINED IN THE BILL I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT YOU'RE ASKING ME TO DO.
IT IN THAT REPORT AGAIN THIS
THESE THESE ARE JUST NORMAL CALL
TO GO THROUGH THE NETWORK.
WE'RE LOOKING AT ERROR RATES
WHATEVER THAT IS LOOKING FOR
THROUGH PUT WHATEVER THAT IS.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION YOU SEE.
NOW THE PC DOES NOT HAVE A ROLE
IN EMERGENCY ALERTS THAT IS A
ROLE THAT IS GIVEN TO THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES SO THE
ANNOUNCES THAT A VERY GOOD JOB.
OF EXPLAINING WHAT -- YES DOES
THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY LAST YEAR
UNANIMOUSLY PASS SB EIGHT THREE
THREE AND THAT WAS NOTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS.
THAT SAYS -- YES YOU NEED TO GO
BACK TO WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE WE'RE
DISCOVERING ISSUES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOT KNOWING.
WHEN TO SEND OUT ALERTS HOW TO
SEND OUT ALERTS AND HOW THE HOW
WE SHOULD BE COORDINATING WITH
COMMUNICATION SERVICE PROVIDERS?
SO -- YES IS NOW ADOPTED SOME
GUIDELINES THAT ARE IN DRAFT
FORM THAT JUST CAME OUT COUPLE
WEEKS.
CC T. A. N. S. MEMBERS WILL BE
MEETING WITH -- YES NEXT WEEK TO
GO OVER THOSE GUIDELINES TO LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF COORDINATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN THE WORDS
ARE ISSUE.
WE WOULD SAY THAT THIS MEASURE
IS PREMATURE AT THIS TIME.
THE REPORT THAT WE GO TO THE P.
YOU SEE I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
WOULD DO WHAT WHAT THE QC DO
WITH THAT INFORMATION.
ITSELF SUCH INFORMATION REVIEW
PROVIDED IT SHOULD BE PROVIDED --
TO YES AS THE APPROPRIATE AGENCY.
BUT FOR THESE REASONS CCK IS
OPPOSE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SAYS THE
CARLSON AT CTIA THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK GOD MISTER ROSS GO HIT ON
A LOT OF THE POINTS THAT THE
THAT I WAS GOING TO MAKE I I DID
WANT TO COMMEND THE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH WAS
WHICH WAS QUITE COMPLETE -- I I
DO WANT TO KIND OF FOCUS ON THE
FACT THAT WITH SB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE IS SORT OF A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO LOOKING AT LOCAL
STATE FEDERAL.
WARNING WARNING ISSUES WE
BELIEVE -- THIS BILL IS -- IS
DUPLICATIVE OF THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT CAN'T BE DONE
THROUGH THE EIGHT THIRTY THREE
PROCESS -- AND THAT EIGHT THIRTY
THREE PROCESS IS RUN BY A BY --
YES I'M AND CAL FIRE.
WE HAVE REMAINING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE THE PRESUMPTION OF
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT IS REVERSED
I'M IN THE BILL -- AND AND THAT
THAT THAT'S REMAINING CONCERN.
WE BELIEVE THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE THESE ISSUES IS FOR THE
RIGHT FOLKS TO SIT AROUND A
TABLE AND WORK THROUGH ON EVEN
TODAY WIRELESS CARRIERS ARE
WORKING TO FINALIZE A MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING WITH -- YES AND
WORKING PROPERLY WITH CAL FIRE.
TO ENSURE THAT INFORMATION FLOWS
LIKE THESE SORTS OF ISSUES ARE
PROBABLY TAILORED -- TO THESE
AGENCIES NEED A WE LOOK FORWARD
TO LOOKING AT THE AT LANGUAGE ON
THE AMENDMENTS AS THEY BUT RIGHT
NOW WHICH WE CONTINUE -- TO TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL DIVINE
AND I REPRESENT AT AND T. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE.
I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF FIRST LET ME COMMEND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL BECAUSE
CLEARLY THE OBJECTIVE HERE IS
ONE THAT WE WOULD ALL SUPPORT.
IN FACT SECTIONS ONE TWO AND
THREE WE OF THIS BILL WE THINK
ARE ARE IMPORTANT AND USEFUL FOR
CONTINUED EXPANSION OF EMERGENCY
ALERTS TO CITIZENS.
ARE OBJECTIONS ARE IN SECTION
FOUR AND IN SECTION.
FIVE PREFERRED TO THE ISSUE OF
FLIPPING THE PRESUMPTION.
THE SENATOR COMMENTED ON THE
NEED FOR PROTECTING PROPRIETARY
NETWORK INFORMATION THE P. YOU
SEE RECENTLY WITHIN THE LAST TWO
YEARS ADOPTED NEW RULES NEW
PROCEDURES -- SIXTY SIX D. THAT
OUTLINES DUE PROCESS FOR THE
PROTECTION OF INFORMATION.
IT IS WORKING EVERYONE
PARTICIPATED AND SO BOTH THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS REGULATED
ENTITIES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK THROUGH CHALLENGES SO WE
BELIEVE PRESERVING THAT SYSTEM.
A WORKING SYSTEM PROTECTS THE
CONFIDENTIALITY AND LIMITS
CONFLICT CLOSER TO BE YOU SEE
BUT THE OTHER ISSUE IS BECAUSE
THAT SYSTEM IS SO WELL DESIGNED.
THE P. YOU SEE IS GETTING ALL OF
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
REQUEST PERIOD WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
HAVING THE PRESUMPTION FLIP TO
EVERYTHING'S PUBLIC.
NOW PUT ALL YOUR INFORMATION AT
RISK BECAUSE YOU ARE NEVER SHORT
TO BE YOU SEE WILL EVER REVIEW
IT.
AND BLOCK EXPOSING.
IMPORTANT PROPRIETARY FOR
NETWORK INFORMATION SO THAT YOU
WANT.
THE SECOND PART OF SECTION FOUR
THAT WE OBJECT TO IS THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL FALSE PREMISE IN THE
BILL.
AND THAT IS THAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY.
HAS CONTROL OVER ALL EMERGENCY
ALERT ECOSYSTEM.
WE DO NOT AS THE SENATOR AS
HIGHLIGHTED WE HAVE THE WE A
SYSTEM WHICH IS A BROADCAST
SYSTEM.
THAT SOFTWARE ITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONTROL ITS
ENGAGEMENT WITH FEMA AND WHEN
THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
BROADCAST A BROADCAST OVER THE
WIRELESS NETWORK BUT IT'S NOT A
PHONE CALL.
IT IS A BROADCAST EVERYONE IN A
CELL SECTOR IDENTIFIED BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ACTUALLY WILL GT THE ALERT AND
THE WAY YOU TEST WHETHER THE
ALERTS HAVE ARRIVED IS THE U.
SURVEY MECHANISM AT FEMA AND
SOME OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE DONE SO AS WELL.
THEY FINE THAT WE END UP HITTING
UPWARDS OF 80%.
OF ALL THE CITIZENS WITH A
WIRELESS DEVICE IN THAT AREA YOU
MIGHT ASK WHAT ABOUT THE LAST
20% WILL USUALLY THAT'S BECAUSE
A PERSON HAS TURNED OFF THEIR
PHONE WHERE THEY DISABLED THE
EMERGENCY ALERT OR THEY MAY
ACTUALLY.
NOT HAVE THE PHONE WITH THEM OR
MAY NOT EVEN RECALL THE GOT THE
ALERT BECAUSE THEY'RE ESCAPING A
DANGEROUS SITUATION -- SO THE
WE'LL ALERT IS THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE AND ITS OPT OUT
AUTOMATICALLY ON YOUR PHONE
RIGHT NOW.
SO YOU HAVE TO OPT OUT OF THAT
SYSTEM SO IT IS THE SUPERIOR
SYSTEM.
AND IT ACTUALLY WORKS INCREDIBLY
WELL BUT THE KEY HERE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY HAS TO ISSUE
THE ALERT.
AND THAT HAS BEEN AN ISSUE IN
THE PAST -- QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
WERE RECENTLY ANSWERED IN A CAL
ONLY A STUDY FROM LAST YEAR.
AND IT AND I'LL QUOTE THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS FOR ALERT AND
WARNING DISSEMINATION APPEAR TO
A FUNCTION ADEQUATELY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CINEMA IN THIS
INSTANCE.
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
SEVERE IMPACTS OF THE EVENT ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS CELLULAR
RADIO.
REPEATER SITES AND
INTERCONNECTING FIBER CABLES THE
POINT IS THE SYSTEMS WORKS AND
IT'S BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY -- YES
SO WE'D LIKE TO TRY TO FIX
SECTION FOUR REMOVE SECTION FOR
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THE BILL.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THESE ARE IMPORTANT
ISSUES WERE AT THE TABLE WORKING
WITH EVERYONE.
BUT THE WAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY
CRAFTED WE HAVE TO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMEND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION OFF THEIR
NOT OPPOSITION I KNOW POSITION
ACTUALLY WHICH WON THE THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE THEY'LL BE A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT -- INCLUDED AND THEN
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY PATRICK
WHAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SENSATION
PATCHWORK OF THE AUTHOR AND HER
WONDERFUL STAFF -- TOBY WHO AND
FORTY IS NO LONGER -- WITH US IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN HE WILL BE
MISSED AT BUT IT THIS TECHNICAL
ISSUE BEING RESOLVED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MEMBERS ARE [inaudible]
DID YOU.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS [inaudible]
OR CENTER REFERENCE.
YEAH I'M I'M JUST LOOK.
TURNER HAVE A QUESTION AS IT
RELATES TO YOU.
AGAIN THE TELEPHONY COMPANIES TO
TELECOMS AND CABLE COMPANIES.
HALL THEY WILL GATHER THAT DATA
BECAUSE THEY'RE NO MORE THAN THE
HIGHWAY I MEAN THEY'RE JUST THE
YOU KNOW THE PIPE FOR THE ROLE
THAT THE PHONE CALL IS
ORIGINATED ON BUT IT'S
ORIGINATOR OF THE PHONE CALL WHO
HAS THAT DATA IS JUST NO MORE
LIKE YOU SAY THAN.
A ROLL CALL THAT WE MIGHT DO AND
WE GET BACK A PRINT OUT OF SAND
NUMBER OF CALLS ANSWERED THE
NUMBER OF CALLS FAILED BUT THE
TELECONFERENCE.
THE CABLE COMPANY DOESN'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION WELL ACTUALLY
THEY CAN GET THAT INFORMATION SO
FOR EXAMPLE -- UNFORTUNATELY.
THE WE IS SYSTEM.
KINDA WORKS BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE JUST ANECDOTALLY
NEVER GOT THE OUIJA --
NOTIFICATIONS.
ARE AT SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TIGHTEN THAT UP FIGURE OUT
WHY.
I'M AND WHAT EXTENT TO WHAT
EXTENT SO THIS BILL BASICALLY
AND WE'VE TAKEN ALL THE
AMENDMENTS REQUESTED ABOUT --
TRADE SECRETS AND THINGS THAT
REALLY HOT BUT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO DO.
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO CREATE
A SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
GET NOTIFICATIONS.
AND THERE ARE THERE ARE.
WAYS TO DO THIS THERE ARE --
THING SO WE DO ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO YOU GET A NICK SOUL.
NOTIFICATION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY EVENT ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
THEY SIMPLY ASK YOU TO CONFIRM
RECEIPT.
SO YOU HIT YES.
AND THAT'S REALLY BASICALLY ALL
WE'RE ASKING OF THE INDUSTRY IS
TO IDENTIFY.
WHETHER OR NOT -- PEOPLE ARE --
GETTING THESE WE ALERTS SO
ESSENTIALLY IT'S SAYING COME ON
FOLKS -- IT GETS YOU KNOW.
ARE THESE ALERTS BEING RECEIVED
BY THE WELL THAT WE INTEND TO
RECEIVE THEM BECAUSE THIS IS A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH. TO BE
ABLE TO LEAVE THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE TO GET OUT OF HARM'S WAY TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM.
AND I I WOULD HOPE THAT THE THE
THE FELLOW FROM.
THE CITY.
WHO IS HERE WITH THE STATE?
ALL RIGHT WELL -- OKAY SO OF OF
MY APOLOGIES BUT HE'S ACTUALLY
BEEN DOING THIS KIND OF THING HE
THERE ARE SOME CITIES AND SOME.
AREAS AND ARE DOING THIS BETTER
THAN OTHERS AND ONE OF THE HOLES
IN ALL OF THIS THAT WE FOUND.
HAS BEEN WITH THE WIRELESS
COMMUNICATIONS MOST PEOPLE NOW
DON'T OPERATE USING LAND LINES
SO THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW WE
GONNA NOTIFY THEM AND ARE THESE
NOTIFICATIONS AFFECTED.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO.
I FIND IT KIND OF INTERESTING
THAT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WITH -- YES -- AND
OTHERS BUT NOT HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WITH.
WITH THE AUTHOR THIS BILL I
THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ARE I KNOW
THE TERM.
OF MY FRIEND FROM EIGHTEEN TEASE
ROLLING HIS EYES -- I NOTED THAT --
BUT WE GAVE THEM ALL THE YOU
KNOW THE FIRST SET OF REQUESTS
HAD TO DO WITH ALL OUR TRADE
SECRETS AND ALWAYS HAD FUNDING
WILL TAKE THOSE MOMENTS WE'VE
TAKEN THEM.
OF THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRY TO
SAVE LIFE AND IT'S MY HOPE AND
EXPECTATION THAT IN SPITE OF
THESE CONCERNS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE PC CAN'T SAY
I BLAME THE WILL WORK WILL FIND
ANOTHER WAY TO DO THIS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATIONS.
AND IF LOOKS COULD KILL I KNOW
RIGHT NOW BE DEAD ABOUT.
TEN BUT THE IMPORTANT THING HERE
IS THAT THIS IS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS IS A MATTER SAFETY WHEN
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH WHAT WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH IN MY DISTRICT WHAT
YOU HAD HAPPEN IN SAN DIEGO
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WITH CENTER
DAUGHTERS HAD WHAT MANY OF US
ARE HAD.
WE NEED TO MAXIMIZE THE VARIOUS
A REDUNDANCIES IF YOU WILL TO
GIVE PEOPLE THE WARNING THAT
THEY NEED SO I WILL PLEDGE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH.
MY GOOD FRIENDS FROM EIGHTEEN T.
ON THIS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COME UP WITH SOMETHING.
THAT MEETS THE EXPECTATIONS WE
DON'T WANT TO CAUSE THEM. TO
HAVE TO REVEAL INFORMATION WE
WANT THEM TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION HERE.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL.
HAS COME FORWARD WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THE STATE AND
I BELIEVE.
THAT -- THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
THE CABLE INDUSTRY ALL OF PART
OF THE SOLUTION I'M HAPPY TO
CAN'T CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THANK YOU DID YOU HAVE ANY ELSE
SENATOR WILL IS OKAY FOR EXCEPT
THOSE OF HIS YOUR QUICK CLOSING
COMMENT THAT IS CORRECT
SOMETHING LIKE CLOSING COMMENTS
TO ME.
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FORTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROACH.
HUESO I WAS SO I A MORE LOT
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHIANG DODD
HERTZBERG.
HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE.
WIENER.
UP AHEAD FOR THE BETTER FOR THE
PUBLIC ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB --
ONE NINETY NINE BY SENATOR HILL.
IS BEEN MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SO WE WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB.
FIVE FOUR NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR WE WHILE WE'RE AT IT JUST TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION THIS CALL THE
ROLL.
SB ONE NIGHT.
SB.
ONE NINE NINE DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WESSEL.
I WAS SO I MORE LACK BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE KING DODD HERTZBERG
KILL.
HI.
I MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER STERN
STONE WIENER.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO S. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB.
SB FIVE FOUR NINE WELCOME.
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK AT THE
END OF THE DISTINGUISHED GUESTS
TODAY.
FUTURE THANK YOU WHEN THAT WHEN
P. JEANNIE ANNOUNCED ITS PLAN
<c.green>ANKRUPTCY IN JANUARY MANY OF US</c>
MYSELF INCLUDED.
STATED NOT ONLY OUR CONCERNS BUT
OUR HOPE.
IT'S CERTAIN PRINCIPLES ARE UP
HELD DURING THE PROCESS.
WILL SUCH AS ENSURING FIRE
VICTIMS ARE COMPENSATED.
REPAIRS ARE PROTECTED AND THE
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY OF OUR
ELECTRIC AND GAS SERVICE.
IS IMPROVE.
WE ALSO NOTED ARE CLIMATE CHANGE
EFFORTS IN THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THE UTILITIES PLAY IN OUR
EFFORTS TO GREEN THE GRID.
I HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
SOLUTIONS AND WE WANT TO HAVE A
VOICE IN THIS BANKRUPTCY.
SB FIVE FORTY NINE IS THE WAY WE
CAN DO THAT.
SB FIVE FOURTEEN I REQUIRES THE
CPUC TO SEEK AUTHORIZATION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE.
PRIOR TO APPROVAL OF RATE
CHANGES FOR P. JEANNIE THIS WAS
CAUSED CONCERN FOR SOME OF YOU
REGARDING THE APPROPRIATENESS OF
THE LEGISLATURE REGULATING RATES.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE REMEMBER THAT
THE LEGISLATURE UP.
CREWS OF UTILITY RATES ALL THE
TIME.
WE PASS LAWS FOR SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS ARE GOALS WITH THE CPUC
MUST ADJUST RATES TO IMPLEMENT.
SOMETIMES WE OUT RIGHT REQUEST
THE CPUC TO RAISE OR LOWER RATES
OR EVEN OVERTURN A SEE IF YOU
SEE RATE DECISION.
WHAT IS CONTEMPLATED IN THIS
BILL IS NO DIFFERENT?
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PLENARY
POWER AFFORDED TO IT BY THE
CONSTITUTION OVER THE CPUC.
AND SPECIFIES THAT QUOTE PUBLIC
UTILITIES ARE SUBJECT TO THE
CONTROL BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SB FIVE FORTY NINE IS NOT MEANT
TO BE PUNITIVE AGAINST THE CPUC
ORDERS PROCESSES BUT IT ISN'T
MEANT TO IT'S MEANT TO BE A
CHECK.
ON THE CD USUALLY ENDED TWO IS A
SERVE OUR OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
GRANTED BY THE CONSTITUTION
AFTER THE ELECTRICITY CRISIS IN
P. GENIES TWO THOUSAND AND ONE
BANKRUPT.
THE CQC TOOK MEASURES TO IMPROVE
THE CREDIT RATING OF OF PGD.
THIS IF YOU SEE AUTHORIZED A
RATE OF RETURN ON EQUITY OF NO
LESS THAN ELEVEN POINT 22%.
UNTIL P. GENIES CREDIT RATING
IMPROVE.
YET EVEN ONCE P. GENIES CREDIT
RATING IMPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN THREE DO YOU SEE
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS.
BEFORE THEY ADJUSTED THE RATE OF
RETURN BACK DOWN TO WHAT IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY.
NOW I'M I HAVE MORE CONFIDENCE
IN THE CPUC TODAY.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME OF THE
BEST COMMISSIONERS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE CPUC PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO ARE THOUGHTFUL AND
CARING AND BALANCE SAFETY AND
AFFORDABILITY AND RELIABILITY.
OF ENERGY SERVICE.
BUT WE AS LEGISLATORS HAVE
OVERSIGHT.
BUT EVERY DAY WHEN EVERYONE'S
GOALS ARE IN HARMONY THIS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION IS
UNDERSTANDABLY MINIMAL.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT SEE THE R.
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY.
NOW IN THE HOPE THAT THIS
HARMONY REMAINS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CONSEQUENCES SEE MORE
HEIGHTENED BECAUSE P. GENIE IS
IN THE MIDST OF BANKRUPTCY.
COLLEAGUES THAT IS THE VERY
REASON WE SHOULD BE INVOLVED.
NONE OF US WANT PEACE YOU NEED
TO EMERGE FROM THIS BANKRUPTCY
ON CHANGE WE WANT A SAFER MORE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE UTILITY.
IT IS RESPONSIVE TO CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDS THAT IS WHY ARE FULLY
VOICE.
THAT'S WHY OUR VOICES SO
CRITICAL IN THIS PROCESS
ULTIMATELY OUR INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS BANKRUPTCY.
IS COMING TOWARD US NO MATTER
WHAT.
IS THE GOVERNOR STRIKE FORCE
PLAN HIGHLIGHTED WE ALREADY HAVE
MANY QUESTIONS BEFORE.
BEFORE US THE TOUCH ON RIGHT
GREAT MAKING AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE CPUC SO WE CAN
EITHER BE BACKED INTO A CORNER.
AND FORCED TO SIGN ON TO A DEAL
COMING FROM A GROUP OF PREDATORS
OR WE CAN TAKE A FIRM HAND IN
THIS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS DESERVE OUR
LEADERSHIP SB FIVE FORTY NINE IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY TO DEMAND BETTER.
IT DOES NOT PRESUPPOSE THE
FUTURE OUTCOME OF THE BANKRUPTCY
OR OTHER RATE MAKING OCCURRING
AT THE CPUC.
THE LARGEST TO HAVE A ROLE.
IN WE SHOULD HAVE A YOU HAVE A
WITNESS I DO THANK YOU.
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I AM
JERIT ALLIANCE I'M A PROFESSOR
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAWN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS -- SB FIVE FORTY NINE SO
TO JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
MY NVOLVEMENT WITH THE BILL --
MY INVOLVEMENT WITH THIS -- BILL
IN THIS IDEA CAME WHEN I
RECEIVED A CALL FROM SENATOR
HILLS OFFICE PRIOR TO P. JEANNIE
I'M FINE FOR BANKRUPTCY I'M JUST
LOOKING FOR SOME INFORMATION ON
HOW BANKRUPTCY WORKED -- AND WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN IN THIS BANKRUPTCY
CASE AND THEN -- HOW PARTY SORT
OF EXERT INFLUENCE IN BANKRUPTCY
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS THAT LED TO
THIS BILL AND IN THE DISCUSSIONS
I HAD WITH SENATOR HELENA STAFF
I RELIED ON MY RESEARCH INTO
BANKRUPTCY BARGAINING?
MY KNOWLEDGE OF LARGE BANKRUPTCY
CASES FROM WORKING AS A
PRACTICING BANKRUPTCY LAWYER I'M
PRIOR TO MY TRANSITION INTO
ACADEMIA AND SPECIFIC PRECEDENCE
OF HOW FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT HAVE EXERTED
INFLUENCE OVER THE BARGAINING
PROCESS.
THAT EMERGES FROM CHAPTER ELEVEN
SO I FIRST THOUGHT ABOUT HELP
HOW PRIVATE PARTIES OF TEEN
INFLUENCE OVER BANKRUPTCY CASES
MORE GENERALLY ON BANKS
TYPICALLY ACQUIRE ENORMOUS POWER
OVER THE CHOICES THAT A DEBTOR
MAKES IN CHAPTER.
ELEVEN BY MAKING ATTACHING
CONDITIONS TO THE EXTENSION OF
FINANCING TO ALLOW THE COMPANY
GO TO GO THROUGH BANKRUPTCY ON
THESE LOANS OFTEN COME WITH
CONDITIONS THAT SAY FOR EXAMPLE --
IF YOU WANT TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY WILL GIVE YOU SOME
MONEY BUT YOU HAVE TO SELL OF
YOUR ASSETS WITHIN NINETY DAYS
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I'M BY ACQUIRING THAT CONTROL
THE THAN SHAPE THE BANKRUPTCY
OUTCOME THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING BUT THE
FACT THAT THE BANK HAS ACQUIRED
THAT RIGHT ON THEN SHAPES THE
BARGAIN THAT DOESN'T MERGING THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE.
IN THEIR TWO PROMINENT EXAMPLES --
RECENTLY OF HOW GOVERNMENT'S
RESHAPED BANKRUPTCY OUTCOMES --
ONE IT CAME FROM THE GENERAL
MOTORS CASE -- WHICH FAMOUSLY
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY FOLLOWED THE BANK
PLAYBOOK AND I'M CONDITIONS THE
EXTENSION OF FINANCING TO
ALLOWED HIM TO GET THROUGH
BANKRUPTCY -- ON GM FOLLOWING A
PRESCRIBED COURSE OF EVENTS THAT
MATCH CERTAIN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
POLICY GOALS THINGS THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO
HAPPEN IN THOSE WHEN TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES --
KEEPING AMERICAN WORKERS WORKING
KEEPING AMERICAN PLANTS --
ROLLING ON GM WAS GIVEN AS A
CONDITION OF THIS FINANCING
THREE DAYS AFTER THE BANKRUPTCY
FILING TO INITIATE AN AUCTION
PROCESS -- FIVE DAYS AFTER THAT
TO GET AN ORDER FROM THE JUDGE
APPROVING IT AND ANOTHER THIRTY
FIVE OR SO DAYS TO HAVE THE SALE
APPROVED -- GM MEMBERS FROM
BANKRUPTCY SHORTLY THEREAFTER --
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
ABLE TO PROTECT UNIONIZED
WORKERS AND PENSIONERS IN THE
UNION CONTRACT I'M IS ALL THE
SUPPLY CHAIN AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS O AMERICAN JOBS.
ON THE CITY OF DETROIT FILE FOR
ITS OWN BANKRUPTCY IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AT THE TIME THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN'S LEGISLATURE TOOK
THE POSITION THAT WE'RE NOT
GIVING A BAIL OUTS TO THIS SORT
OF FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE CITY --
BUT THEN THE REPUBLICAN
LEGISLATURE BEGAN TO SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACQUIRE -- POLICY
ACHIEVEMENTS THROUGH MAKING
CONTRIBUTION TO THE BANKRUPTCY
CASE AND SO THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN ENDED UP CONTRIBUTING
THREE ENGINE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THAT BANKRUPT HE'S
CASE TO FACILITATE.
A GRAND BARGAIN THAT AMONG OTHER
THINGS PROTECTED TRAITS PRICED
OUR COLLECTION -- BUT ATTACHED
TO THAT CONTRIBUTION -- WAS A
REQUIREMENTS THAT UNIONIZED
WORKERS AND PUBLIC SECTOR UNIONS
GIVE UP MORE THAN THEY WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO SUE SOME OF THE
CONCESSIONS THEY'RE BEING ABLE
FORCED TO MAKE.
IN COURT SO BY ACQUIRING
INFLUENCE IN THE BANKRUPTCY CASE
ON THE REPUBLICAN DOMINATED
LEGISLATURE IN MICHIGAN WAS ABLE
TO ADVANCE POLICY GOALS THAT
THEY HAVE LONG HELD SUCH AS
WEAKENING PUBLIC SECTOR UNIONS --
HOW IS THIS BILL DIFFERENCE FROM
THESE PRIOR GOVERNMENTAL
INTERVENTIONS THE FIRST IS
UNLIKE GM OR OTHER PROMINENT
BANKRUPTCY CASES THIS ISN'T
DISCUSSING ACQUIRING INFLUENCE
OVER THE BEGINNING OF THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE THE PROVISION OF
FINANCING?
P. JEANNIE WAS ABLE TO GET MONEY
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND THEY
DON'T NEED MONEY FROM YOU TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE IN BANKRUPTCY
ON THEY WILL HOWEVER MOST LIKELY
NEED TAX PAYER RATE PAYER MONEY
LATER.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT'S CASH INFUSION WILL
COME LATER IN TIME LEADER IN
TIME SOMETIMES MEANS THAT YOUR
BARGAINING POWER ENDS UP BEING
MORE LIMITED THAN IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN HAD YOU SORT OF SHAPE THE
COURSE OF CONDUCT FROM THE
BEGINNING -- IT SO HERE WE ARE
TRYING TO USE THE BACK END OF
THE CASE IN STATING RIGHT NOW
HOW THE TO THE EXTENT YOU WANTS
TO RAISE RATES -- OR GET A
CAPITAL STRUCTURE JUST MEANT I'M
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED TO THE
CONSENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE -- IN SACRAMENTO BY
STANDING BETWEEN P. JEANNIE AND
THE EXIT FROM BANKRUPTCY YOU CAN
TELL TO THE PLAYING FIELD IN
FAVOR OF THE INTEREST YOU CARE
ABOUT WHETHER IS PUBLIC SAFETY A
REPAIRS OR ANYTHING ELSE.
TAXPAYERS AND RATEPAYERS ARE NOT
REPRESENTED AT THE BANKRUPTCY
BARGAINING TABLE DIRECTLY --
THIS BILL WILL CAST A SHADOW
OVER THE P. JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY
THAT WILL CHANGE THE RELATIVE
BARGAINING POWER OF DIFFERENT
PARTIES AND RESHAPE THE
BANKRUPTCY BARGAINING TERRAIN --
IMPORTANTLY I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL START TO CAST THAT
HADOWS TODAY HOPEFULLY WHEN
THIS BILLS PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND THE PARTIES WERE
NEGOTIATING REALIZED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE
OUT THERE IN THE FUTURE THAT
THEY NEED TO TAKE ACCOUNT OF AND
COMING TO AGREEMENT ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN IN THE BANKRUPTCY
CASE AND WHO IS GOING TO MAKE
WHAT SACRIFICES.
I'M CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES AND
USING STATE LAW IN A WAY THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
BANKRUPTCY LAW. TO RESHAPE
BANKRUPTCY OUTCOMES USING
EXPECTED BACK AND CONTRIBUTION
IT'S JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA INNOVATING AND
CREATING A PRECEDENT THAT OTHER
STATES CAN FOLLOW WHEN THEIR OWN
UTILITIES GRAPPLE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE -- I WORRY ABOUT TWO
SITUATIONS IN PARTICULAR -- THE
THE BARGAINING TABLE DIRECTLY SO
IT'LL BE VERY EASY FOR ALL THE
PARTIES WERE AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE TO COME UP WITH A PLAN OF
ORGANIZATION THE CONTEMPLATES A
LARGE CONTRIBUTION EITHER IN THE
FORM OF LIABILITY RELIEF -- A
CHANGE LIABILITY ENVIRONMENT FOR
A RATE INCREASE -- AND THAT MAY
COME TO BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE A
YEAR FROM NOW WHEN P. GENIE HAS
ALREADY ABSORBED MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED OR SO MILLION DOLLARS ON
LITIGATION EXPENSES WHEN WILD
FIRE VICTIMS WERE ALREADY
WAITING TO GET PAID -- ARE EAGER
TO GET SOMETHING -- INTO NEW MAY
FACE A SITUATION WHERE THE
BANKRUPTCY JUDGE SUPPORTS THE
DEAL -- IN THE THE PARTIES
INCLUDING P. GENIE IN THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE MAY TRY TO USE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEDURE TO MAKE IT
HARDER FOR YOU TO ASK FOR A
DIFFERENT DEAL OR TO ASK TO
RENEGOTIATE.
WHAT IS GOING ON SO THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THIS BILL IS
THAT BY PASSING THIS BILL YOU'LL
SIT IN THE BACKGROUND OF THE
MEETINGS THAT ARE ALREADY GOING
ON AND PARTY'S WILL UNDERSTAND
THAT I. P. GENIES I COULD
THROUGH BANKRUPTCY?
RUNS THROUGH THIS BUILDING --
AND THE SECOND REASON WHAT THE
SECOND THING THAT I WORRY ABOUT
IS THAT THE CQC IS ALREADY
ACCORDING TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE MOVING FORWARD ON A
RATE INCREASE THAT WE CALL
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH. FOR
EVERY HOUSE IN THE P. JEANNIE
SERVICE AREA FOR JUST THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES PURSUANT TO
ASKING I'M NINE A ONE ONE COULD
EASILY IMAGINE A BANKRUPTCY PLAN
THAT WOULD SATISFY BANKRUPTCY
LAW.
THAT'LL PAY WHILE FOR VICTIMS
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR I'M ON THE
GROUNDS THAT P. GENIES NEEDS USE
ALL OF ITS EXISTING ASSET BASE
I'M TO SELF INSURE AGAINST
FUTURE WILDFIRES.
PLAN WOULD BE LEGAL -- IN
APPROVAL BY THE BANKRUPTCY JUDGE
IN THE C. P. U. C. WITHOUT YOUR
INPUT AND PERHAPS EVEN WITHOUT
TO THE C. P. HOW I GUESS THEY
PROBABLY STILL WITH ME THE CPC.
ON THE THREAT OF THIS PLAN CAN
MAKE IT CHALLENGING NOT TO GET
P. JEANNIE LIABILITY REFORM OR
OTHER LEGISLATIVE RELIEF ON THE
TERMS THAT THEY WANT TO A PART
IN THE GOALS THAT YOU HAVE.
ON THIS IS A POWER THAT ONLY YOU
IS THE LEGISLATURE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO ON THECBS POWER
YOU KNOW COMES FROM THIS BODY
IT'S DELEGATED TO THEM THE
GOVERNOR.
STONE IT REALLY RESTS WITH THIS
BODY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
WE HAVEN'T ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
JUST GENERALLY MY COMMENTS -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE THE ANECDOTES.
IN MICHIGAN AND WITH FORD
[inaudible]
OF THE CITIES HAVE CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS OVER STATES AND AND
ANY OPPORTUNITY PENETRATE THAT
I'M SURE SOME STATES WOULD TAKE
THAT OPPORTUNITY IN THE DETROIT
EXAMPLE.
THANK CALIFORNIA CHARTER CITIES
ARE THERE CERTAIN AREAS WERE NOT
EVEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COULD EXERT.
INFLUENCE OVER CHARTER CITIES.
IN CERTAIN AREAS.
BUT WE HAVE INFLUENCE AND OTHERS.
OVER A PRIVATE CORPORATION LIKE
LIKE -- GENERAL MOTORS OR FORD
OR ANY ANYTHING LIKE THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU GET INVOLVED IN
THE PROMOTE PER PER NIGHT.
PROVIDE THE FINANCING YET GIVE
YOU OUT THE OPPORTUNITY COME IN.
AND AFFECT.
INTERNAL OPERATIONS.
BUT IN THE CASE FOR UTILITIES A
P. YOU SEE AS OUR DIRECT --
REGULATOR.
AND IN A BANKRUPTCY THY'RE
INVOLVED.
IN THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS AS YOU
CLEARLY STATED IN YOUR
PRESENTATION OF BANKRUPTCY AND
THAT IS THE WAY.
THE STATE [inaudible]
SPECIALIZES REGULATORY REVIEW.
WITH ONE ORGANIZATION AND AND IF.
YOU HAVE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
ALREADY PROVIDING [inaudible]
THE EXPERTISE.
AT A SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE
RATE PAYERS.
AND TO THE UTILITIES EVERYBODY
IS PAYING FOR THIS PROCESS WE'RE
GETTING SOMETHING FOR OUR MONEY.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WE'RE GOING
TO ADD ANOTHER REGULATORY.
REVIEW.
YEAH I THINK THAT IT'S IT'S A
RISK REDUNDANCY.
THAT IS NOT NECESSARY BECAUSE
IT'S ALREADY BUILT INTO THE
PROCESS -- NONE THE LESS --
AGAIN THIS IS A VERY SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE I THINK IT DESERVES.
A CONVERT TO A YOU KNOW A
CONVERSATION IT DESERVES -- A
DEBATE A DIP.
AND NEW AND INTERESTING AND
IDEAS NEED TO BE.
AARON REVIEWED THIS ISN'T A NEW
AN INTERESTING IDEA -- TO OUR
DELIGHT OF THE LEGISLATURE DEALS
WITH EVERYTHING.
WITH EVERY ISSUE.
AND WE'RE BOMBARDED WITH EVERY
ISSUE AND AND IT'S HARD TO
BECOME A TECHNICAL EXPERT ON
EVERY ISSUE IS JUST IMPOSSIBLE.
AND I AND THEN WHEN YOU AND
CALIFORNIANS REPEATEDLY HAVE
VOTED.
FOR CITIZENS LEGISLATURE ANYTIME.
CALIFORNIANS CONVERT FOR TERM
LIMITS THERE FOR THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT CAREER
POLITICIANS THEY WANT.
THEY WANT THE AVERAGE CITIZEN
RATE OF COMMAND.
AND AND TO MAKE DECISIONS.
AND WHAT IS BAD BEST FOR THEIR
BEHALF SO.
IT'S HARD TO GET.
IT IS HARD TO GET OF EXPERTS IN
ANY ONE ISSUE AND IF WE DID
THEY'D BE AN EXPERT IN ONE ISSUE
AND NOT AN EXPERT IN.
AND LOTS OF ISSUES AND THAT'S
WHY THE THE FOR ME THIS BILL.
IT IS REALLY HARD HARD THING FOR
ME TO CONTEMPLATE.
AS AS THE RIGHT COURSE OF ACTION
BUT BUT AGAIN OF THE CENTER HILL
YOU ARE AT THIS POINT OF THE ERA
THE THE POINT OF THE SPEAR ON
THIS.
ON THIS ISSUE IN THIS IS
AFFECTING YOUR CONSTITUENTS MORE
THAN SUFFICE EVEN IF IT'S
AFFECTED MINE IT'S NOT AFFECTING
MINDS.
MUCH IS AFFECTING YOURS AND AND
THIS BANKRUPTCY IS AS A MAJOR
MATTER.
AND AND I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT YOUR WE WORK ON THIS.
AND AND CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
DEBATE ABOUT -- THE
LEGISLATURE'S WRONG BANKRUPTCY --
I BELIEVE.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD HAVE A
ROLE IN THIS BANKRUPTCY AND I
BUT I I HOPE THAT THE P. YOU SEE
IS IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
ADVOCATING FOR OUR INTERESTS AND
WE'RE GONNA BE.
WATCHING DIED AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE SOLUTION IS BUT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THE CENTER HILL.
IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND I I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU AND
AND MEN'S -- OR I THINK SO.
SPOT ON ESPECIALLY WITH THE FACT
THAT.
IF WE LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR HAS A
STRONG ROLE HAS THE BULLY PULPIT.
CAN USE THAT MINISTER IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY.
BEING ABLE TO AFFECTED THE
BANKRUPTCY IT'S DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING.
THE P. YOU SEE -- HIS AND HE
HASN'T MADE THOSE APPOINTMENTS --
YET SO IT'S IT REALLY IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO BELIEVE
THAT TO AT LEAST HAVE A ROLE TO
BE ABLE TO BE HEARD AND TO BE
ABLE -- TO BECAUSE WE DO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU I WILL
TAKE THAT THAT YOU COULD ME USE
THAT AS A CLOSE BUT I THINK YOU
MAY HAVE.
I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH
THANK YOU -- THIS ARE YOU
INTERESTED IN MOVING THIS BILL.
NO I DON'T WISH TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR THE AND THAT EVEN
AS A CHRISTIAN -- I I JUST TO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS SENATOR HILL
OKAY FIND SHARE FOR OPENING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO SPEAK --
THANK YOUR HEAD YES -- I'M MORE
OF A NO BETTER NO WORSE KIND OF
PERSON SO I'M WONDERING WHY JUST
P. WE'RE DOING A FOR PEACH YOU
NEED TO SET THE SCENE IS THE
ONLY UTILITY.
CURRENTLY IN BANKRUPTCY.
AND THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AUTHORITY OVER THAT BANKRUPTCY
IS ONLY LIMITED TO RATES AND
CAPITAL EXPENDITURES AND RATE
SETTING IS GOES FORWARD.
THOSE THE BANKRUPTCY WILL BE
REFLECTED IN THOSE RATE
INCREASES IN CHANGES AS IT MOVES
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY THIS GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE THE OPPORTUNITY IN
THAT.
PARTICULAR CASE. TWO OF TO HAVE
A VOICE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
COMMENTS AND IN EITHER VOTE UP
OR DOWN AND SUPPORTING UP ORDER
OF THAT.
WHAT THE PROFESSOR COMMENTED ON
WHICH I THINK WAS A VALID IS?
BY US BEING.
IN THE PROCESS OF THIS BILL
MOVING.
FORWARD IT DOES IT ALLOWS.
FOR THE WHICH WE WILL HAVE A
PRESENCE IN THE BANKRUPTCY
CONVERSATION BECAUSE OF THAT.
KNOWING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE SOME SAY.
IN THAT I THINK IS CRITICAL.
IF THEY LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS A
WE'VE REYES.
SINCE THE BANKRUPTCY FILING WITH
THE PROTECTION OF REPAIRS
PROTECTION OF THE FIRE VICTIMS.
OF PROTECTIONS OF THE THE THE
WORKERS AT THE F. P. JEANNIE.
AND OUR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION AND NO ONE IS
MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT
AREN'T REALLY I BELIEVE IN
REALITY KNOWS MORE ABOUT THAT
THAN MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
AND AND WHAT DID.
AND I APOLOGIZE I'M JUST JUMPING
IN HERE. ONE DAY YOU'RE HAVING.
WHO WOULD THAT THE BILL PREVENT
P. JEANNIE FOR MAKING POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO LEGISLATORS
DURING THIS THIS?
THANK YOU.
THE THE BILL DOES NOT HAVE THAT
PROVISION IN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU [inaudible]
I'M WILL.
THIS IS OUR MOTION ON THIS
CENTER HERTZBERG.
OKAY CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE FOUR NINE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL FIVE WAS
SO I MORE LAST NO MORE LIKE NO
BRADFORD CHIANG.
DIED HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO
SKINNER STERN STONE WIENER.
ITEM NINE SB.
FIVE FIFTY CENTERVILLE.
SB FIVE FIFTY PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA FOR THE CQC
CONSIDER AND WE'RE DOING A
PROPOSED CORPORATE RESTRUCTURING
TO ENSURE SAFE SERVICE.
OF THE SUCCESSOR ENTITY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE ALREADY
LIST RIGHT THE COMMISSION MUST
CONSIDER PRIOR TO AUTHORIZE ANY
CORPORATE RESTRUCTURED.
THESE CRITERIA INCLUDE IMPROVING
THE QUALITY OF SERVICE PROVIDED
ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO RATE PAYERS.
IRVINE THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CHIEF USUALLY AND MOST RECENTLY
ADDED UNDER SB NINE OH ONE LAST
YEAR IT'S FAIR AND REASONABLE.
TO AFFECTED PUBLIC UTILITY
EMPLOYEES DESPITE THESE FOR IF
YOU'RE IN NO FORMAL REQUIREMENT
THERE'S NO FORMAL REQUIREMENT.
THAT UTILITY RESTRUCTURING
PRESERVED AND IMPROVED SAFETY.
THIS TODAY DURING THE LEGAL
OWNERSHIP CHANGE IN FEBRUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AT THE
GIL BRANDT STORAGE FACILITY
LOCATED FRESNO AND MADERA
COUNTIES THE NOTION OF SAFETY
CULTURE.
AS LIKE AS A CRITERIA FOR
APPROVAL EMERGE.
I HOLDING COMPANY FILED AN
APPLICATION TO ASSUME LEGAL
OWNERSHIP OF THE FACILITY.
THE OFFICE OF SAFETY ADVOCATE
PROTESTED THE APPLICATION OVER
CONCERNS IT'S SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WERE NOT BEING
ADDRESSED.
THE HOLDING COMPANY ULTIMATELY
REACHED A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
WITH -- AS A THAT INCLUDED THEIR
DESIGNATING THE CHIEF SAFETY
OFFICER CREATING A PIPE RIGHT
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM -- IN
ALL OF THAT WAS DONE IN CHANGE
THE CONDUCT CAUGHT SAFETY
CULTURE ASSESSMENTS FOR THE
COMPANY.
AS A RESULT OF THE SETTLEMENT
THE CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP WAS
APPROVED BUT IT HAD TO HAVE THAT
SAFETY COMPONENT.
THIS JUST EXPANDS THAT OUTLINED
AND TO THAT THE CPUC WILL HAVE
THAT SAFETY COMPONENT A DURING
THE BANKRUPTCY.
THANK YOU CENTER HILLS -- ANYONE
HERE IN PUBLIC.
I'D SUPPORT WERE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANYTHING MEMBERS.
LEISURE THE MEMBERS TO HAVE
MOTIONS BILL FOR MOVE.
MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
YOU WANT TO CLOSE OF THANK YOU.
PERFECT SB FIVE FIFTY DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL.
I WAS SO I MORE LOT.
I LIKE NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE EIGHT CHIANG DIED.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE MCGUIRE
RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE WIENER.
VERY GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN SB SIX TWO FIVE THANK YOU
CHAIR A LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW
MAKES IT LEGAL FOR PASSENGERS TO
SMOKING CANNABIS IN A PARTY BUS
A LIMO TAXI OR TNC.
AS A RESULT SOME PARTY BUSES AND
LIMO OPERATORS ARE OFFERING
CANNABIS DISPENSARY TOWARDS
SIMILAR TO EXISTING TOURS. FOR
WINERIES OR BROUGH RICH MODELED
AFTER STATUTES FOR ALCOHOL BUSES
IN LIMOS.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WILL PROHIBIT
CANNABIS USE IN THESE VEHICLES
AND THE SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
FOLLOWED. FOR A PASSENGER ANY
PARTY BUS OR LIMóN. TO SMOKE OR
VAPOR CANNABIS UNLESS THE
DRIVER'S COMPARTMENT IS SEALED
OFF IN SEPARATELY VENTILATED.
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE RIVER IS NOT
IMPAIRED IF CANNABIS SMOKE.
IS CONSUMED IN ONE OF THESE FOR
HIGHER VEHICLES THE BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS ANYONE. TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE FROM BEING ON
BOARD IF CANNABIS SMOKERS
PRESENT.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WILL
ESTABLISH SAFETY RULES TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND ELIMINATE
BAD ACTORS OF THE DISEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
SEE SEE I A IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE SPELL WHICH
PROHIBITS THE INGESTION OF
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
IN CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS
LIMOUSINES ARE TAXICABS -- WE
BELIEVE THAT -- YEAH THIS IS
THIS IS A OF IMPORTANT SAFETY
PROTOCOLS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS TOURISM ASSOCIATION IN
MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA SIDE TWO HUNDRED AND
99% INCREASE.
IN CANNABIS RELATED TOURISM
SEARCHES IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FORBES MAGAZINE
REFERRED TO CANNABIS TOURISM AS
QUOTE FOR THE NEXT BIG THING.
IN FACT IN COLORADO CANNABIS
TOURISM HAS GROWN 51% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ACCORDING
TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
REVENUE AND IS ATTRACTED SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION NEW TOURISTS --
BEGINNING IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
THAT NUMBER IS GROWING.
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TOURISTS VISITING
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR WE CAN
ASSUME MANY OF THESE TOURISTS
ARE OR WILL BE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF CALIFORNIA'S NEWLY COMPLIANT
CANNABIS MARKET PLACE.
CCAP SUPPORTS THE SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
AND BELIEVES PROVISIONS IN SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE OR IN
FURTHERANCE OF THIS POLICY.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS BILL
ESTABLISH APPROPRIATE SAFETY
MEASURES THAT ENSURE CANNABIS IS
CONSUMED RESPONSIBLY AND BY
PERSONS TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER.
IT ESTABLISHES APPROPRIATE
INDUSTRY STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS
TOURISM WHILE IMPROVING THE
SAFETY OF BOTH PASSENGERS AND
DRIVERS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE BILL -- AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
JUST A QUESTION OF WHEN YOU SAY
THE APPROPRIATE ENTRY INDUSTRY
STANDARDS WHAT ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT.
THERE ARE BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE ALREADY BEING UTILIZED BY --
A LOT OF PARTY CARRIERS -- SO
THIS WOULD IN FACT MANDATE THOSE
TYPES OF STANDARDS BY ENSURING
THAT ALL APPROPRIATE UNDER --
THEY THEY ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED REALLY
BEGINNING IN COLORADO THERE ARE
A COUPLE OF CHARTER PARTY
CARRIERS THAT DID THIS -- IT WAS
NOT LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED BUT
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THEIR
DRIVERS -- WE DO KNOW TOO THAT
THERE IS ALSO EXISTING --
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED PURSUANT TO
LEGISLATION ENACTED BY SENATOR
HILL AND OTHERS -- RELATED TO
ALCOHOL AND AND SAFETY IF THERE
IS IN FACT AN ACCIDENT SO THIS
WOULD JUST INCORPORATE THE SAME
TYPES OF STANDARDS ON THAT THAT
ARE ALREADY UTILIZED BY A LOT OF
THE INDUSTRY BUT WOULD MANDATE
THOSE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
PASSENGERS AND THE DRIVERS WHEN
CANNABIS IS.
CONSUMED -- DO YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR ON THAT DAY WE HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE WAS BECAUSE FAVOR.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY WANT TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ON OKAY BEFORE YOU MOVE ANY ANY
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
JUST GENERALLY I JUST WANT TO
REMIND.
EVERYONE THE THE YOU KNOW THAT
THIS -- YOU MENTIONED THERE WAS
A LOOPHOLE IN THE BILL AND THAT
WAS YOUR BILL MAHER REMIND.
LAST YEAR [inaudible]
OR PUBLISHED BEFORE.
EITHER AND THERE WAS A BILL THAT
YOU RAN.
THAT -- IMPLEMENTED PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS --
NOT LONG AGO.
AND THE ARE THE PARTICULAR CODE
SECTION THAT DEALS WITH THE
VEHICLES.
MADE IT SO THAT YOU HAVE --
PARTY BUSES NOW -- IN A IN A
SITUATION WHERE -- THE DRIVERS
ARE ARE NOT ARE BEING EXPOSED TO
SECONDHAND SMOKE [inaudible]
AND SO.
IT POSES.
A IN YOUR BILL IT IS GONNA
[inaudible]
OF CREATE A TRY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
AND AND FRANKLY -- IT'S A VERY
CALM COMPLICATED PROBLEMS SOLVED.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE OF THESE
VEHICLES WERE NOT DESIGNED TO BE
HAVE THE SHOW FOR SEPARATE IT
FROM.
FROM THE PASSENGERS WHICH
CREATES.
A NEW SAFETY RISK FOR NOT ONLY
THE PASSENGERS.
AND THE DRIVER.
BUT YOU HAVE A CONDITION IN
WHICH PASSENGERS ARE AN ALTAR
STATE OF MIND -- WHILE THEY ARE
SEPARATED FROM THE DRIVER.
WHO HAS -- A LIMITED ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
[inaudible]
SO -- THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT
I DO I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO WORK
ON CENTER HILL -- AND THEY THEY
AT THE DEAL WILL DEVELOP A IN --
OF OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW WE
DO THIS IS A LEGISLATURE BUT
THERE ARE CERTAIN FEDERAL
SANDERS HAVING TO DEAL WITH --
VEHICLE DESIGN.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY'RE NOT THE
WE DON'T HAVE STANDARDS AROUND --
USING OF USING A VEHICLES FOR
MARIJUANA USE.
AND IF PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE --
SMOKING MARIJUANA IN THE BACK OF
A OF A CABIN.
WHAT WHAT ARE WORTH WHAT ARE THE
DANGERS ASSOCIATED THAT WITH
THAT -- ARE THEY GONNA BE USING
IN -- LIGHTERS A YOU KNOW UC A
COMBUSTIBLE NORMALLY IN VEHICLES
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED.
THEY HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC
LIGHTER VEHICLES.
THAT DOES NOT PRODUCE A SPARK OR
FIRE.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A VERY
CROWDED BUS IN THE BACK WHERE
PEOPLE MAY BE USING.
UP LIGHTERS OR SOME KIND OF
COMBUSTIBLE.
SO YOU KNOW I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT -- INTRODUCE SEEN
COMBUSTIBLES INTO.
A CABIN OF A OF A OF A VEHICLE
THAT IS POWERED BY A COMBUSTIBLE
FUEL.
YEAH IN IN AN AREA WHERE PEOPLE
MAY BE IN A CONDITION IT IN A
CONDITION WHERE THERE MAY BE
LESS RESPONSIVE.
AN EMERGENCY.
HI SO THAT'S THE FIRST ISSUE THE
SECOND ISSUES HAVING TO DEAL
WITH -- HOW YOU SEPARATE THE
DRIVER?
AND WE NEED TO COME UP WITH AN
ENCLOSURE.
THAT IS IS IS SAFE FOR THE
DRIVER.
AND ALSO -- AND I'M I'M LOOKING
AT THAT -- CREATES A DRIVER
COMPARTMENT WHERE THE DRIVERS
COMPLETELY SEALED OFF.
WHO IS THE ONLY -- NORMALLY
DRIVERS ARE ARE.
NOT ONLY THE DRIVERS OF THE
VEHICLE BUT THEY'RE ALSO THE
SUPERVISORS OF THE ACTIVITY
BEHIND THE VEHICLE.
IN IF I COULD POINT OUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT THE VEHICLE THE
DOOR IS IS -- COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT AND IT IS A DOOR.
SO JUST CLOSE THAT IF THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY THE EASIEST WAY TO GET
BACK IN.
I WAS UNDER THE REAR OF THE
THING I KNOW IT'S HARD TO SEE BY.
I SEE THAT BUT I ALSO SEE.
THAT -- IN THIS PHOTO HERE.
IN THIS PHOTO HERE THE VIEW.
OF OF THE THE THE THE BACKSIDE
OF THE DRIVER IS COMPLETELY
BLACK BOX OFFICE HIS VIEW IS
SIDE WAYS.
WHERE WHERE IS THE VIEW INTO THE
CABIN?
I DON'T KNOW I'M SURE HE LOOKS
AROUND THE ACHING DID WHATEVER
THAT DOOR IS THAT SEPARATES THE
TWO OF AND WE CAN GET YOU MORE
THERE'S A LOT OF OBSTRUCTION AND
I'VE I'VE BEEN IN THE BUSES
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF
OBSTRUCTION.
WITHOUT HAVING IT WASN'T A
MARIJUANA TOWARD BY THE WAY --
BUT THERE BEEN I'M GLAD YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD THAT THEIR SOMETIMES
YOU CAN'T TO SEE BUT BUT I THINK
THAT YOU'RE MAKING A VERY VALID
I'VE NEVER BEEN ON A BUS THAT
HAS AN OBSTRUCTION.
IF THE BEHIND THE DRIVER'S SEAT
I'VE SEEN THAT ALL THE WAY TO
THE TOP.
OF I'VE SEEN THAT AND SO IT IT'S
IT'S VERY BUT I I THINK YOU MAKE
A GOOD A POINTS.
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S EASY ACCESS.
WHITE AND YOUR YOUR STAFF BOARD.
WORK CLOSELY WITH US AND I DID
AND I DID WANT TO CUT YOU OFF ON
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE NO NO
THAT'S FINE AND IT'S OKAY IF WE
HAVE AN EXCHANGE HERE BECAUSE I
I HONESTLY I WE HAVE HAD LATELY
DISCUSSION MY STUFF AS WELL ON
THIS AS WELL.
BECAUSE YOU CAN THAT YOU KNOW
SHE MENTIONED YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE THE HIGHWAY
PATROL THERE AND AT SOME LEVEL
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME LEVEL OF
HIGHWAY PATROL'S.
APPROVAL BUT AS LONG AS THERE IS
A THERE ARE SOME STANDARDS OF
THE HIGHWAY PATROL CAN ACTUALLY
[inaudible]
OF REFERENCE WHICH FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE AREN'T
CURRENTLY.
ANY STANDARDS THAT THEY CAN
REFERENCE.
AND IF THERE ARE AND I'D LIKE --
TO GIVE THROUGH THIS BILL THE
HIGHWAY PATROL THE ABILITY TO
THE LEAST ESTABLISH THOSE
STANDARDS.
I THINK THAT'S FAIR I THINK THIS
THE HIGHWAY PATROL SHOULD
DEVELOP WHATEVER STANDARDS THEY
NEED TO DO DE TO DEVELOP AND
OBSERVE.
AND ENFORCED WHEN THEY APPROVED
THE PARTICULAR DESIGN FOR ACCESS
AND FOR SAFETY AND ALL OF THE
OTHER THINGS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM
ALSO ONE ON THE IDEA THAT.
YOU KNOW THE CONSUMPTION OF THE
PRODUCT IN THE VEHICLE REALLY
CAN'T BE SEEN FROM OUTSIDE TO BE
SHOWN YEAH.
BERNIE PUBLIC PLACE AND AND THAT
THEY'RE PREPARED NOTICES INSIDE
THE VEHICLE LETTING PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT THE LIMITATIONS ARE AND
WHAT WE WITH THIS MOTION SO
THERE.
THIS IS I THINK THIS WOULD BE A
VERY APPROPRIATE.
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE HIGHWAY
PATROL THE WAY AND IF THEY ARE
GOING TO BE USING LIGHTERS THAT
THEY BE LIGHTERS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR VEHICLE USE TO
EIGHT BUT I THINK THAT'S TRUE I
DON'T KNOW.
HOW IT WORKS TODAY WHEN YOU HAVE --
YOU KNOW PARTY BUS IN PEOPLE ARE.
DRINKING ON THERE AND SOMEBODY
IN THE BACK WANTS TO SMOKE THERE
AREN'T LIGHTERS OF THE
ELECTRONIC ONES THERE.
I WOULD GUESS THAT IF IT'S A
PARTY BUS THEY USE THEIR LITTLE
LIGHTER AND LIGHT A CIGARETTE
BUT I'M NOT SURE I'VE NEVER.
NEVER SMOKED IN HAVE A FROM A
FROM MY UNDERSTOOD.
ARE VERY SPECIFIC IN I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY'RE PROHIBITED OR
HOW IT WORKS BUT WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS.
OBVIOUSLY PART OF THIS.
OKAY THERE IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH NOT NOT REALLY.
EUROPE IS VERY FAIR THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
MOTION.
SO MOVED.
MOTION CLIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE DAY PASSED TO
THE FLOOR WAS SO I WAS SO I
MOORLACH BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE KING DODD HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER.
STONE WIENER [inaudible] ZERO
OKAY DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL
SENATE ONE NINETEEN I WOULDN'T
CALL I'M WITH THE OKAY THAT'S
RIGHT WE HAVE ALL THANK YOU
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THIS IS CENTER BARGES HERE
[inaudible]
CITY VECTOR.
ARE YOU SB SIX SO THREE ITEM.
TEN WELCOME.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN -- IN
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD WHICH TO
DATE IS.
IT ACTION PACKED DAY
[inaudible]
WHILE.
THANKS THERE IS LIKE.
SO WHAT I'D.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- SB SIX ZERO THREE
HAS AMENDMENTS AND WE OF AGREED
TO ACCEPT THE THOSE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- SB SIX OH THREE
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO PERFORM
ONE OF ITS CORE FUNCTIONS.
RATE REGULATION.
IN EFFICIENT AND TIMELY MANNER
FOR TEN SMALL RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES RANGING IN SIZE FROM
LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS TO JUST OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND SO THIS IS VERY THIS IS
THE AND THEN VERY SMALL CATEGORY.
FOR DECADES THE COMMISSION
HANDLED THE RAPE CASES OF THESE
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES.
THROUGH THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS UNDER GENERAL GENERAL
ORDER NINETY SIX BE.
TYPICALLY TAKING LESS THAN A
YEAR FROM THE FILING OF THE
FINAL COMMISSION VOTE.
GENERAL ORDER NINETY SIX B. SETS
FORTH THE RULES FOR THE VARIOUS
USES OF THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS. FOR EACH UTILITY SECTOR.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED A FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAY IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINE.
PHONE COMPANY RATE CASES.
SINCE THEN IT HAS ONLY MET ITS
DEADLINE FOR THE FIRST TWO OUT
OF NINE RATE CASES FILED.
EACH SUBSEQUENT RATE CASES TAKE
A LONGER AND LONGER CULMINATING
IN THE COMMISSION RECENTLY
ADOPTING RESOLUTIONS INTO RATE
CASES WAVING THE EIGHTEEN MONTH
STATUTORY DEADLINE FOR
PROCEEDINGS.
SO A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES FOUND
OUT THAT THE COMMISSION -- THE
P. YOU SEE WAS DENYING THEM
ACCESS TO THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS.
NGUYEN PINNACLES TELEPHONE THE
SMALLEST OF THE SMALL REQUESTED
TO USE IT FOR HIS RATE CASE.
THE COMMISSION FORCED PANICLES
INTO THE FORMAL PROCESS WHICH IS.
MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THE COMPANY
AND REQUIRES THE TIME OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE TO
PRESIDE OVER HEARINGS REVIEW THE
EVIDENCE IN RIGHT A PROPOSED
DECISION.
IT HAS BEEN ALMOST SEVENTEEN
MONTHS AND THE ALE JAY STILL HAS
NOT ISSUED A DRAFT DECISION.
AND PICKLES RATE CASE WAS
UNCONTESTED MENTIONED THAT.
SB SIX OH THREE SIMPLY RESTORES
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE ADVICE
LETTER PROCESS FOR SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANY RATE CASES IN
CODIFIES TIME LINES FOR THE
COMMISSION'S PROCESSING OF THEM.
TEN MONTHS FOR ADVICE LETTERS
AND TWELVE MONTHS FOR
APPLICATIONS.
SB SIX OH THREE ALSO CODIFIES A
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANY MAY
RECOVER ITS REASONABLE EXPENSES
DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
PARTICIPATING IN ITS RATE CASE.
WHICH IS THE EXISTING PRACTICE
ACROSS ALL UTILITIES SECTORS IN
EVERY STATE OF OUR GREAT NATION
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU KNOW THE WORD REASONABLE
GIVES THE COMMISSION FULL
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNT OF RECOVERABLE EXPENSES.
SB SIX OH THREE IN CLOSING WILL
HOPEFULLY RESTORE MORE EFFICIENT
COST EFFECTIVE AND TIMELY
PROCESS FOR BOTH THE COMMISSION
AND THE SMALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES.
ALONG SIDE WITH ME -- IS YOLANDA
BENSON OF CAL COM PAM LOOMIS
FROM C. I. T. C..
PATRICK ROSE FALL FROM COOPER
WHITE IN COOPER -- WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR COMMENT.
BE ABLE TO FIELD MORE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT I ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AND I JUST WANTED IT JUST FOR MY
A BENEFIT ARE THERE.
IS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL.
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OKAY I JUST OKAY A
WILL COME TO YOU AS SOON AS WE
HEAR FROM -- THE SUPPORTERS CAN
SO GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
IN A POSITION OKAY.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS -- THAT ARE
HERE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
INDEFINITELY YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT WHO WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH US AND ARE WORKING
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
TAKEN TODAY AS WELL.
AS MENTIONED SIX OH THREE IS
REALLY A PROCEDURAL CHANGE JUST
TO ENSURE THAT THE SMALL
COMPANIES HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
USE THE INFORMAL RATE OF A
PROCESS OF THE BILL IS NEEDED
FOR SEVERAL REASONS NUMBR ONE
THE COST IN THE BURDEN.
OF THE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FORMAL VERSUS INFORMAL ARE HUGE
FOR BOTH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND FOR OUR SMALL -- TELEPHONE
COMPANIES NUMBER TWO BECAUSE OF
THE DECISIONS AT THE MADE THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AT THIS JUST MAKE SURE THAT THE
INFORMAL PROCESS IS AN OPTION IT
DOESN'T REMOVE THE FORMAL ACTION --
FROM BEING TAKEN IT JUST GIVES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE INFORMAL
CONSIDERED NUMBER THREE WE ARE
VERY SMALL -- WE WE TAKE CARE OF
THE MOST RURAL AND REMOTE MORE
REMOTE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CONNECTION.
I WE SHOULD BE PARTNERING WITH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SERVING CALIFORNIA ALL OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THESE MOST
RURAL AREAS THERE SHOULD BE NO
ADVERSARIAL ACTION.
AND WHEN WE SAY RATE CASE WITH I
WANT TO CLARIFY WHEN YOU HEAR
RATE CASE YOU THINK -- THEY WANT
TO INCREASE RATES ACTUALLY IT'S
MORE OF A RATE DESIGN.
MANY TIMES THESE APPLICATIONS
ARE PUT IN BY OUR COMPANIES ARE
NOT EVEN ASKING FOR RATE
INCREASES TO THEIR SUBSCRIBERS
ARE TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
THIS REALLY IS ABOUT WORKING
WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
ENSURING THAT THEY RECEIVE ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT'S CRITICAL
FOR THEM DATA.
THAT IS CRITICAL FOR THEM TO
MAKE DECISIONS WITH OUR
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO GO
FORWARD ON COMPLETING THESE RAPE
CASES WE THINK THAT THE
INFORMATION IN THE PROCESS IS
TRANSPARENT IT'S ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THERE IS NO LIKE I SAY
THERE'S NUMEROUS DOCUMENTS AND
DATA THAT ARE GIVEN TO THE P.
YOU SEE.
CONTINUES TO ENSURE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PARTICIPATION BY
THE CAL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AS WELL.
ALL THIS INFORMATION IS THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED WHETHER IT WAS AN
INFORMAL OR FORMAL RATE CASE
THIS INFORMATION INSURERS
TRANSPARENCY.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND BAG I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
STILL GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS PAMELA
MISSED AND I REPRESENT THE TEN
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES THAT
RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM THE HIGH
COST AND A PROGRAM.
THERE ARE A COALITION FOR
LOBBYING PURPOSES AND THEY FULLY
SUPPORT SB SIX SO.
THREE BUILDING ON THE TESTIMONY
OF MISS BENSON SB SIX SO THREE
WOULD RESTORE THE COMMISSION'S
PRACTICE TO WHAT IT'S BEEN FOR
DECADES INCLUDING ALLOWING SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES TO RECOVER
THEIR REASONABLE RATE CASE
EXPENSES.
THIS IS THE COMMISSION'S
EXISTING PRACTICE FOR THE OTHER
UTILITY SECTORS.
BUT IN THE LAST ROUND OF RATE
OUR OF OUR RATE CASES THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SIR CAL PA HAS
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR ZERO
RECOVERY.
BASED ON THE MISINTERPRETATION
OF A SINGLE SENTENCE IN A TWENTY
FOURTEEN KEY YOU SEE DECISION ON
THAT HIGH COST SPEND A PROGRAM.
AT CAL PA I ARGUING THAT IF OUR
CORPORATE EXPENSES ARE CERTAIN
AMOUNT THEN WE SHOULD GET
NOTHING TO COVER OUR RATE IS
EXPENSES.
THE COMMISSION CANNOT COMPLETELY
IGNORE A REQUIRED EXPENSE JUST
BECAUSE SOME OTHER SET OF
EXPENSES ARE OF A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
SB SIX OH THREE SIMPLY RESTATES
EXISTING US SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT REGARDING RECOVERY OF
RATE IS EXPENSE.
WHICH IS THE STANDING PRACTICE
IN EVERY STATE ACROSS THIS
NATION.
THE BILL DOES NOT LIMIT THE
COMMISSION'S DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF EXPENSE
RECOVERED.
HELP HE IS ALSO ARGUING THAT
THIS BILL WILL SOMEHOW ALLOW
RECOVERY FOR THE REGULATORY AND
RATE CASE EXPENSE OF OUR
AFFILIATE.
EVEN AS RIDICULOUS AS THIS
ARGUMENT IS.
CAL PA IS FREE TO MAKE IT WHEN
ARGUING OVER THE REASONABLENESS
OF OUR RATE CASE EXPENSE.
THE HOPE BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED RATE CASE
EXPENSE AND PROCEDURAL BURDEN TO
THE RENEWED UTILIZATION OF THE
ADVICE LETTER PROCESS FOR A RAPE
CASES.
IN CONCLUSION THE TRIAL LIKE
ADVERSARIAL PROCESS OF FORMAL
RATE CASE IS NOT NECESSARY FOR
CAL PA TO DO ITS JOB OR FOR THE
COMMISSION FOR THAT MATTER.
CAL PA HAS INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY
TO INSPECT OUR FINANCIAL RECORDS
AND TO SUBMIT ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
COMMISSION AND BOTH THE FORMAL
AND INFORMAL PROCESS SEES.
REGARDLESS OF THE PROCESS
UTILIZED THE COMMISSION IS THE
ULTIMATE FACT FINDER AND IT HAS
ALL THE REGULATORY TOOLS TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE HIGH
COST FUND A PROGRAM -- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY.
SIR DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU WONDER YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW MARCUS AND
I'M WITH THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT OUR ROLE THAT THE PC.
WE ARE ONLY WE ARE THE ONLY
PARTY.
THAT THOROUGHLY EXAMINES THE
SMALL TELEPHONECOMPANY RATE A
JERSEY REQUESTS AT THE PC.
WE DO SO TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ARE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CUSTOMERS THAT THESE REQUESTS
ARE JUST AND REASONABLE.
WITHOUT OUR ANALYSIS THE PC
WOULD HAVE NO OTHER RECORD IN
WHICH TO RELY ON TO MAKE WELL
INFORMED.
DECISIONS IN CUSTOMERS BEST
INTERESTS.
WE NOW INTERPRET WHAT WITH
PROPERTY ARE WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
GUARANTEES THAT RATE EXPENSES
SUCH AS LEGAL ACCOUNTING.
OF FILING AND SO FORTH WOULD BE
DIRECTLY PASSED ON TO CUSTOMERS
WITHOUT REVIEW WHY.
IS IT -- BUT THIS BUILD STILL
REQUIRES REVIEW ON IT.
I DO NOT HAVE THE BILL FOR ME
BUT IT DIRECTLY ALLOWS US TO BE
A PASS TO AS LONG AS IT'S
REASONABLE.
AND THE VERY PURPOSE OF THE
GENERAL RATE CASE PROCESSES
DETERMINE WHETHER THESE OF THESE
AND OTHER COSTS.
ARE APPROPRIATE JUST AND
REASONABLE.
ON WE ALSO QUESTION THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE THE PC
CURRENTLY HAS.
A HIGH COST FUND DAY PRECEDING
OPEN TO LOOK AT WHAT MAKES IT
WHAT OUTSTANDING POLICY ISSUES
EXIST.
AND WAYS TO STREAMLINE THE
PRODUCT PROGRAMS ADMINISTRATION --
WE THOROUGHLY SUPPORT THE PHONE
PROGRAM WE RECOGNIZE ITS
IMPORTANCE.
BUT BEFORE THE CPU SEES RULE
MAKING IS COMPLETE WE ASK THAT
YOU.
PLEASE HOLD OFF ON DOING THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU -- OKAY.
I JUST WANNA MAKE.
YOU KNOW I I'VE I'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO REVIEW THIS AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU -- I THINK THIS BILL
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY THESE CASES TAKE SO LONG?
YEARS EVEN I MEAN.
AND IT DOESN'T STOP YOU SEE FROM
THE NEVER ABLE TO REVIEW BUT WE
NEED.
WE NEED THE PC TO WORK WITH A
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES
BECAUSE I MEAN FOR AS FOR SOME
OF SOME PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT'S
ALL THEY HAVE.
AND AND DIG IT'S ALREADY HARD
ENOUGH O KEEP THE TELEPHONE
COMPANIES IN BUSINESS OUT THERE --
AND AND PUTTING A RICH -- ON A
REGULATORY AN ADDITIONAL
REGULATORY BURDEN ON THEM WOULD
JUST MAKE IT MUCH DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO STAY IN BUSINESS AND I I
GUESS MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
GIVING PEOPLE.
THE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
SO. ONE WHEN I WHEN I LEARNED
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES BE FACED
OUT THERE REGISTER OF THE
REGULATORY VIEW I JUST THOUGHT
THIS IS THIS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO FIX.
AND AND I DON'T.
I YOU KNOW THE THE REVIEW HAS TO
BE THERE BUT I THE LOOK LIKE MY
QUESTION IS WHAT WAT IS IT
TAKES SO LONG WHY TO TAKE THREE
YEARS. TO RENDER A DECISION.
OR EVEN A YEAR.
COULD COULD WHAT WHAT IS THE CAN
CAN THIS BE DONE IN A MONTH.
I DON'T KNOW IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT IS IS PRACTICABLE.
UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
[inaudible]
SENATOR A THANK YOU I I CAN
PROBABLY ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE
BIT I MEAN IF YOU YOURSELF --
BETTER GOSPEL -- I'M THE
REGULATORY ATTORNEY FOR A LOT OF
THESE COMPANIES BEFORE THE
COMMISSION AND PARTICIPATED IN A
LOT OF THE RATE CASES.
INCLUDING GOING BACK TO WHEN
THEY USED TO BE HANDLED MORE
EFFICIENTLY THROUGH THE ADVICE
LETTER PROCESS. TO YOUR QUESTION
I THINK.
A LOT OF STATES DO THESE KINDS
OF CASES IN ABOUT SIX MONTHS --
AND SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD BE A REASONABLE
TIME TO TO HANDLE RUNNING SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANY WOULD TAKE SIX
MONTHS.
SOME STATES HAVE DIFFERENT
LAYERS OF OF PROCESS USE AND SO
IF IT FITS WITHIN CERTAIN
PARAMETERS IT CAN BE EVEN FASTER
THAN THAT -- BUT SO I THINK
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY THEY
COULD BE EVEN FASTER BUT TO
CONDUCT THE THE FULL REVIEW OF
OF THE REVENUES OF THE OF THE
INVESTMENTS AND ALL THE THINGS
GOING TO RAPE CASE.
MOST STATES ARE DOING IT IN
SOMETHING LIKE SIX MONTHS.
SO THIS TIMING THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR BUILDING QUITE A BIT MORE
TIME -- AND SO IS VERY
CONSERVATIVE IN ITS APPROACH I
WOULD SAY.
IF THAT ANSWERS MENTIONED DURING
THIS PROCESS THIS STILL ALLOWS
YOU TO SUBMIT WHAT.
WHAT -- RATE CHANGES YOU'RE
SEEKING.
YEAH THE THE ACTUAL CALCULATIONS
AND DATA SUPPORTING A PROPOSAL
IN A RAPE CASE WHETHER IT'S
SUBMITTED BY BY SLOWER BY
APPLICATION IT'S THE SAME.
AND AND SO.
THE THE COMMISSION HAS ACCESS TO
THE SAME LEVEL OF DETAIL.
WHETHER THEY DO IT WITH THE NAIL
JAY OR WHETHER THEY HAVE THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION REVIEW
THAT THE DOCUMENTS.
THAT ARTS BURKE.
I'M SORRY BUT I CAN'T HEAR A
THING OVER HERE.
THE TRICK OF THE EYE BETTER.
AND IF I MAY I I WOULD OUT W.
RIGHT TO ASK ANYWAY GO AHEAD.
SORRY.
IF I MAY I IT ISN'T THROUGH THE
THE CAL PA IS THE ONLY ENTITY
REVIEWING THESE THINGS FOR FOR
YEARS AND ANY INFORMAL AND
CHRYSLER PROCESS THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION DOES IT.
AND WHAT YOU FIND IS THAT WHEN
THAT OCCURS IT TURNS INTO MORE
OF AN ADMINISTRATIVE NUMERICAL
EXERCISE WHERE THE DATA IS
REVIEWED AND REASONABLE
DECISIONS ARE REACHED.
WHAT HAPPENS IN AN APPLICATION
PROCESS IS IT BECOMES MORE
ADVERSARIAL JUST BY THE NATURE
OF THE PROCESS?
BUT THE OFFICE REPAIR ADVOCATES
STILL INVOLVED.
CERTAINLY AND THERE ARE LOTS OF
ADVICE LETTER CONTEXT IN WHICH
THEY CAN SUBMIT A PROTEST -- AND
THEN THEY CAN BE PARTIES TO THE
INFORMAL PROCESS THEY COULD
SUBMIT THEIR VIEWS IN ANY WAY
THEY SEE FIT -- AND THEN
MEDICATIONS DIVISION WOULD
CONSIDER THAT.
IT WOULD ULTIMATELY RESULT IN A
RESOLUTION WHICH WILL WHICH
WOULD BE VOTED ON BY THE FULL
COMMISSION SAME AS A DECISION
COMING FROM.
AN APPLICATION PROCESS WELL I
JUST WANTED.
TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING ON THIS --
SO SENATOR THIS IS A GREAT BILL
AND AND I SUPPORT IT.
WE CAN.
GET THIS.
OVER TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
AND WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
THIS WE HAVE A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
JUST A QUICK A QUICK ONE THANK
YOU SURE CHAIRMAN -- JUST.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RECORD IS
CLEAN I THINK -- IT WAS EASY FOR
THERE TO BE MISUNDERSTANDINGS --
THROUGH THE ADVISER PROCESS
THERE IS A THOROUGH REVIEW.
ALL MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
APPRECIATES THAT -- IN THE
COMMISSION HAS TO OF RENDER A
VOTE FOR THAT AS WELL.
SO I THINK THE SAFEGUARDS ARE
ABSOLUTELY HIM PLACE
INEFFICIENCIES AS YOU TO
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFIED.
ARE IMPERATIVE.
THESE TELEPHONE COMPANIES ARE
VERY VERY SMALL IN IN THESE
RURAL AREAS THIS IS OUR LIFELINE.
AND IT SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
SPINE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE -- HE MISTAKES SO WE
CAN'T LET THESE -- SMALL
COMPANIES -- BE COMPLETELY PUT
OUT OF BUSINESS -- WITH
REGULATORY -- DIFFICULT SO I
THINK YOU SAID IT BEST AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CLICK THIS KALRA.
SB SIX A THREE D. PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS HUESO HI BUT
SO I'M MORE LACK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE KING DIED FIVE DIED
AYE ERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HILL
MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER STERN
STONE WIENER. ZERO OKAY WILL
GIVE THE ROLE OF THE FIVE YEAR
MEMBERS SENATOR DODD
[inaudible]
WHETHER MONITORING.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
SB TWO OH NINE WOULD ESTABLISH
THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE WARNING
CENTER A JOINT VENTURE OF CPUC.
CALLOW YES CAL FIRE.
IN UTILITIES TO CONDUCT FIRE
WEATHER FORECASTING THAT ALLOWS
FOR ACCURATE LOCALIZED WILDFIRE
RISK ASSESSMENT AND THREAT
WARNING.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE WHILE
FAR CHALLENGE OF CALIFORNIA IT
IS NECESSARY.
TO DEVELOP BETTER WILDFIRE --
WEATHER FORECASTING SKEWS ME
WEATHER FORECASTING A WILDFIRE
THREAT ASSESSMENT CAPABILITIES.
SEVERAL MAJOR DIFFERENCE
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN THE CURRENT
STATE OF FIRE WEATHER MONITORING
AND FIRE THREAT RISK ASSESSMENT
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
A LACK OF CRITICAL WEATHER DATA.
YES BUT ESPECIALLY LOCALIZE
NGUYEN DATA.
THERE'S A LACK OF STATE LEVEL
COORDINATION THE DEVELOP OF
WEATHER STATIONS BY UTILITIES.
THERE IS A LACK OF AGGREGATION
OF WEATHER STATION NETWORK DATA.
YEAH THERE IS A LACK OF
STATEWIDE FIRE THREAT POTENTIAL
FORECASTING WHICH LEADS TO
EFFECTIVE USE OF STATE RESOURCES.
LAST YEAR SB NINE OH ONE
REQUIRED THE CPU SEEING CAL FIRE
TO ENTER INTO AN ANIMAL YOU TO
COOPERATIVELY DEVELOP CONSISTENT
APPROACHES AND SHARE DATA
RELATED TO FIRE PREVENTION.
SAFETY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN
ENERGY DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE WILDFIRE
PREDICTION DEFICIENCIES I JUST
MENTIONED SB TWO OR NINE TAKES
THAT COLLABORATION REQUIRED IN
SB NINE A ONE ONE STEP FURTHER.
IT ALSO BRINGS CAL FIRE IN THE
UTILITIES DIRECTLY INTO THE MIX.
UNDER SB TWO OH NINE THE C. W.
W. C. WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ONGOING MONITORING OF FIRE
WHETHER IT'S RIGHT CONDITIONS.
AS WELL AS ITS ONGOING
IMPROVEMENT OF FIRE WEATHER
FORECASTING MODELS.
THE C. W. W. C. WILL RECEIVE AND
VERIFY INFORMATION PERTAINING TO
FIRE THREAT CONDITIONS UTILITY
PROACTIVE DINNER JASON.
THE ENERGY IS ATION OF POWER
LINES.
AND ACTIVE FIERY VETS.
THE C. W. W. C. WILL OVERSEE AND
COORDINATE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT
OF A STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
AUTOMATED WEATHER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STATIONS.
IN A STATEWIDE FIRE WEATHER
FORECASTS DURING THAT CASTING
MONITORING AT THE END -- THREAT
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM.
THE C. W. W. C. WILL WORK WITH
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO A
DOT C. W. D..
W. C. APPROVE WHETHER MONITORING
EQUIPMENT IN THE C. W. W. C.
WILL OVERSEE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A VALIDATED FIRE THREAT
POTENTIAL INDEX IN ENSURE THAT
EVERY GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION.
YOUR AREA IN CALIFORNIA IS
COVERED BY SUCH AN INDEX.
I'M AWARE THAT SO SOME VERY GOOD
WORK IS ALREADY BEING DONE IN
THE AREA FIRE THREAT -- WEATHER
PREDICTION INCLUDING THE WORK
AND ES DE GENIE.
IN OUR OWN CAL FIRE MY INTENTION
AN AUTHORING SB TWO OH NINE IS
TO BRING DISPARATE FIRE THREAT
PREDICTION.
ACTIVITIES TOGETHER -- TO
COORDINATE AND STANDARDIZE THE
RESPONSE PROTOCOLS TO THOSE
THREATS BY OUR ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES AND LOWERED THE
POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE
CATASTROPHICALLY.
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU RIGHT.
VERY WELL. TWENTY CHAIR MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND URGES ADOPTION
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
IF YOU'VE GOT THE THIRD MEMBERS
OUT THERE ABOUT THIS WEEK
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I NEED ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR SANDY OF GAS AND
ELECTRIC APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WORK ON THIS ISSUE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT -- IF THE SENDER IS
VERIFYING INFORMATION RELATED.
TO CONDITIONS I'M DINNER TODAY'S
STANDARDIZATION EVENTS AND OF
FIRE EVENTS THAT IT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE VERIFYING PRIOR TO OUR
ABILITY TO THIRTY TWO DE
ENERGIZED BY THEN THAT HAVE TO
SUPPORT AND REALLY BUT SHE DOES
WORK ON IT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GIVING A
FLEMING'S ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY WE ALSO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ME
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHARMERS RHYME PARINI
WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR IS DONE -- TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL MOVING FORDING CONTINUE --
OUR COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE A A
RECOMMENDATION HERE -- TO PASS.
ON THIS BILL -- TO MOVE WE HAVE
A MOTION.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS LIKE WE ASK FOR AB
THANK YOU.
SB TWO NINE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WAS SO.
I WAS SO I MOORLACH BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
I THOUGHT I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE WIENER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
WE CAN CONNECT AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE CHARGES TO CALL
THE MOTHER'S PERCENT
[inaudible]
AS CHAIR [inaudible] EIGHT FIVE
TWENTY RIGHT WHICH OF THE BILL.
A MAN YOU NEVER KNOW.
THANK YOU SIR.
BY THIS MEASURE ESTABLISHES A
BASIC SAFETY NET MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF FOR ELECTRICITY
CUSTOMERS LIKE DESIGNATED A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
SOMETHING THAT WE UNTIL ALL THIS
STUFF WE STARTED WAS THE PEACE
AND JIM ROLLED THE YEARS AGO
NEVER HAD TO THINK ABOUT.
BECAUSE THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIESWERE THE PROVIDERS OF
LAST RESORT -- THESE PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT AS SET FORTH IN THIS
VISUAL CONTENT WILL ENSURE
CONTINUOUS ELECTORAL SERVICES.
IN CASE A RETAIL ELECTRICITY
PROVIDER BELIEVES THE MARKET FOR
ANY REASON WHATSOEVER WHETHER
IT'S A BANKRUPTCY DECIDES TO
LEAVE WHATEVER THE SITUATION MAY
BE.
AND IS THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE OF THE LAST YEARS AND I
HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN ON IT.
A RETAIL CHOICES GROWN
DRAMATICALLY HOWEVER NOT ALL LOW
SERVING AS THESE WHO ARE
REGULATED LEAVING THOSE
CUSTOMERS POTENTIALLY.
WITHOUT KEY CUSTOMER AND PRICE
PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES I SAY
ACT AS THE PROVIDERS OF LAST
RESORT.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WHEN WE
HAD AN INCIDENT STARTING IN SAN
DIEGO -- ONLY 15% OF LOS SERVICE
WITH LOW RESERVE BY SOMEONE
OTHER THAN AN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY TODAY'S YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN QUITE WELL.
THAT NUMBER 44% AND WE CAN'T
LEAVE THOSE CUSTOMERS WITHOUT
BASIC PROTECTION LAST YEAR.
FOLLOWING A SERIES OF A PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WORKSHOPS
THERE WAS A CONSENSUS REFLECTED
IN THE P. UC'S QUOTE GREEN BOOK
KNOWN AS THE GAP ANALYSIS.
A IT DEFINING WHAT.
THAT POLAR IS NECESSARY
ADDITIONALLY AS WE YOU ALSO KNOW
THE GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM.
IDENTIFIED POLAR'S OBLIGATIONS
AS A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IN THE
WILD FOR ENERGY FUTURES REPORT
SPECIFICALLY I'M QUOTING.
THE REPORT SAYS IF I'LL USE
BECOME PRIMARILY POLES AND WIRES
BUSINESSES IT RAISES THE
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER THE I AO
UCHE SHOULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
POLAR SERVICE OR WHETHER ANOTHER
ENTITY SHOULD ASSUME THIS
RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE
HAD HAD ON FIVE TWENTY THE
INITIALLY DESIGNATES THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY IS THE
POLAR FURTHER DISTRIBUTION
SERVICE AREAS INCLUDED.
A INCLUDING FOR CUSTOMERS OF
CCA'S.
AND THE S. P. IS CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT PRACTICE HOWEVER WHAT IT
DOES IS IT PROVIDES SOME
FLEXIBILITY THAT ALLOWS AND I
USED TO TRANSFER THE POLAR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ANOTHER
PROVIDER.
THAT WANTS TO SPEAK TO SERVE
THAT FUNCTION ALLOWS THOSE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
WANT TO GET OUT VERSUS THOSE
DON'T [inaudible]
BUT STE. FOR CUSTOMERS.
AND SO IT'S A STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE IT I THINK IT'S SUPPORT
OF PORTENT STEP IN THIS LARGER
DYNAMIC AS WE LOOK TO RESOURCE
ADEQUACY -- PROVIDERS OF LAST
RESORT TOGETHER WITH SENT TO
PROCUREMENT WHICH IS REALLY THE
THREE STOOLS LEGS OF THE STOOL
THIS WERE MOVING AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DEAL IN THIS NEW DYNAMIC
MARKET.
A NINETY TALK.
YOU SEE PRESIDENT'S PICKERS
CHIEF OF STAFF WAS.
AHEAD OF THE PC WORKSHOP AND
ALICE'S FOR THE POLISH YOU SHE'S
THE MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE PERSON.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S NOT TAKEN A
POSITION SHE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE OF THE PROCESS AND
PRESIDENT PICKER.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME IS
BETTY TUCKER AND I AM TWO
PERCENTAGE IN EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
OR PRESIDENT MICHAEL PICKER OF
THE TPC.
AS SENATOR HERTZBERG NOTED --
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF PRESIDENT
PICKER AND NOT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE PC BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION ON
SB.
FIVE TWENTY AS YOU ALL ARE AWARE
MORE SO THAN EVER CALIFORNIA
ELECTRICITY USERS CAN GET THEIR
POWER FROM SOURCES OTHER THAN
THE TRADITIONAL I OWE YOU WHICH
IS ROOFTOP SOLAR DIRECT ACCESS
AND COMMUNITY TWENTY AGGREGATORS.
THIS MEANS CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS
HAVE MORE. TO FOR CITING THE
GREATEST WHICH IS LEADING TO LOW
DEPARTING FROM THE I'LL USE AT A
RAPID PACE.
BY THE END OF THE YEAR OUR
ESTIMATES INDICATE THAT ALMOST
44% OF ALL I OWE YOU LOAD IT
WILL HAVE DEPARTED.
WITH THE GROWTH AND LOW SERVING
AND ANY OPTIONS IN THE STATE.
AS OF SEPTEMBER THERE ARE NOW
THIRTY SEVEN ALEX HE'S UNDER PC
<c.yellow>URISDICTION WHO ARE SERVING</c>
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING. THREE I'LL
USE NINETEEN CCA'S AND FOURTEEN
YES PLEASE.
DESIGNATED ENTITIES NEED TO BE
READY TO PROVIDE ELECTRICITY IF
THE MARKET DOES NOT MEET
CUSTOMER DEMAND DUE TO A SUDDEN
EXIT FOR FAILURE OF A LOT OF
TRIMMING AND IT.
RIGHT NOW THE I'LL USE ARE
ESSENTIALLY AND DEFAULT PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT.
UNDER P. YOU CODE SECTION FOUR
FIFTY ONE BUT THERE IS NO
DEFINED PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT
IN STATUTE.
THE I'LL USE HAVE ALWAYS SERVED
IN THIS ROLE BY DEFAULT HAVING
AN OBLIGATION TO SERVE CUSTOMERS.
WE ARE SEEING A TRANSITION AND
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES IN THE
STATE AND NEED TO PLAN FOR
CUSTOMERS TO HAVE A PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT TO ENSURE ON
INTERRUPTED SERVICE.
THROUGH THE CUSTOMER CHOICE
PROJECT THE COMMISSION RAISE A
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS WE NEEDED
TO ANSWER TO ADDRESS FRAGMENTED
ELECTRICITY PROCUREMENT.
AND WE STOP AND SO HAVE RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ACTRESS CITY THAT
MEETS THE STATE'S AGGRESSIVE GHG
REDUCTION TARGETS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT PRIORITY
COMING OUT OF THE GAP ANALYSIS
WAS THE CREATION OF A PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT THAT WILL ENSURE
ON INTERRUPTED SERVICE AND
AFFORDABLE PRICES.
IN THE EVENT ALLEGE SERVING AND
IF HE FAILS.
WE ARE AGNOSTIC ON WHO SERVED AS
THE POLAR AND LONG AS THE LOW
TRIMMING AND EDDIE MEETS
CRITERIA CRITICAL THRESHOLD
REQUIREMENT.
SOME OF THESE HAVE BEEN RAISED
IN SB FIVE TWENTY ALL RUN
THROUGH A FEW.
INCLUDING ADMINISTRATIVE
CAPACITY AND FINANCIAL STANDING
TWO OF YOUR CUSTOMERS IN THE
EVENT OF AN INCUMBENT POLICIES
AND ABILITY. TO SERVE CUSTOMERS.
I DETERMINATION OF FINANCIAL
CAPACITY OR THE HEALTH OF THE
COLOR COULD BE DETERMINED USING
SOME TYPE OF FINANCIAL STRESS
TEST.
THAT ASSESSES COLLATERAL ON HAND
AMONG OTHER FACTORS.
ALSO THE POLAR SHOULD HAVE A
TRACK RECORD OF PREVIOUSLY
SERVING CUSTOMERS AND PREPARING
CARBON FREE RESOURCES.
SHOULD HAVE A KNOWLEDGE OF
RETAIL.
ELECTRICITY MARKETS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO COVER CERTAIN BINDING
REQUIREMENTS TO COVER
ADMINISTRATIVE IN PROCUREMENT
COST ASSOCIATED WITH
TRANSITIONING CUSTOMERS.
AMONG OTHER FACTORS TO BE
DETERMINED.
FINALLY THE PC WOULD NOT.
OBVIOUSLY SERVICE A POLAR BUT
WHAT HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER LOVE
DRIVING ENTITIES SERVING IN THIS
CAPACITY AND WOULD MONITOR THE
MARKET VERY VERY CLOSELY.
THE PC AT REGULAR INTERVALS OF
SUCH AS ANNUALLY WHAT IF THAT'S
REGISTERED POLAR TO ENSURE THEY
COULD MEET THE THRESHOLD
REQUIREMENTS.
AND WOULD CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE RELIABILITY OF THESE COLORS
PARTICULARLY IF THEY'RE A MAJOR
SHIFT IN THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL
MARKET.
SUCH AS WE ARE SEEING TODAY WITH
THE INCREASE IN THE SEGREGATION
OF ELECTRICITY CARMEN.
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS CAN CAL'S ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THERE'S
ONE AMENDMENT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEEK AND IT'S TO INSURE THATTHE
COMMISSION ACTUALLY CREATES AND
DESIGNATES RATHER THAN HAVING
THE AUTHORITY TO DESIGNATE AN
ENTITY.
AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE AND YOUR
COMMITTEE IS HOLD HELD A COUPLE
OF INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THE
SUBJECT -- IN THE BEGINNING OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IS MOVING TOWARDS THE
CCA THAT'S 40% OF OUR LOAD.
WE THINK IT'S A REAL POSSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE 15% OF OUR LOAD
STILL SERVED BY US IN THE NEXT
HIM FULLY YEARS.
MA'AM CUSTOMER'S ACCOUNT FOR
ALMOST 13%.
WITHIN THE TIME IS RIGHT FOR
THIS DEBATE AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS A REFERENCE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S WHILE FAT WIRE
WILDFIRE REPORT. FOR HE
MENTIONED THIS AS WELL AS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COMMITTEE
EIGHT MATT FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF
TURN WE'RE NOT OPPOSING THE BILL
WE HAVE A CONCERN LETTER ON WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS MAKING TO
TEE UP THIS CONVERSATION.
I THINK WE JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT WHAT WE THINK IS MISSING
FROM THE BILL AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
WOULD BE A TOPIC FOR
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD -- A
WE HAVE A FEW ITEMS FIRST OF ALL
THE BILL APPEARS TO REQUIRE THAT
THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT BE
AN EXISTING LOAD SERVING ENTITY --
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSIGN THIS FUNCTION TO A STATE
AGENCY OR AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED RETAIL
CUSTOMERS.
JUST AN EXAMPLE OF A PROVISION
OF THE BILL THAT MIGHT IN IT.
IN A VERDANT LEE RESTRICT --
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVE ARRANGEMENTS ALSO
WE'D LIKE TO SEE A GREATER
REFERENCES TO THE ABILITY OF THE
P. YOU SEE TO ENGAGE IN ONGOING
OVERSIGHT OF PERFORMED BY A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT TO SERVE
ITS CUSTOMERS WERE NOT SEEN.
ENOUGH THERE -- TO MAKE US
COMFORTABLE.
IT ALSO DOESN'T ESTABLISH THE PC
CAN REGULATE RATES CHARGED BY
THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT TO
RETAIL CUSTOMERS IN TERMS OF
SERVICE INCLUDING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS -- THERE'S ALSO NO
PROVISION EXPLICITLY PERMITTING
RETAIL CUSTOMERS TO OPT OUT OF
SERVICE BY ANOTHER PROVIDER TO
TAKE SERVICE FROM THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT IF A CUSTOMER
WERE TO SO CHOOSE.
AND FINALLY THE BILL DOESN'T
REALLY EXPLAIN THE RANGE OF
FUNCTIONS THAT WOULD BE
PERFORMED BY A PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT THERE'S A REFERENCE TO
ELECTRICAL SERVICE.
BUT WE'RE NOT SURE HOW MANY
DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS THAT MIGHT
ENCOMPASS -- AND IT MIGHT
ARTIFICIALLY CONSTRAIN THE PC
FROM CONSIDERING THE TRANSFER OF
OTHER RETAIL FACING FUNCTIONS TO
THIS ENTITY.
SO WE'RE JUST IDENTIFYING THESE
AS GAPS IN THE ARCHITECTURE WE
UNDERSTAND THE BILL IS NOT FULLY
FORMED AS PRESENTED TODAY AND
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
I'M AND ALTHOUGH WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THAT WE'RE STILL
NOT PERSUADED.
THAT THE CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR AUTHORIZING AN
ALTERNATIVE PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT SO WE'D LIKE TO KEEP.
THE THRESHOLD QUESTION OPEN OF
WHETHER WE ACTUALLY NEED TO MOVE
THIS FUNCTION AWAY FROM THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
AS THE CONVERSATION CONTINUES.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE PUBLIC.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYTHING.
THANK YOU ONE RESPOND ANY THOSE
COMMENTS OR THAT A LOT OF
CLOSING MY COMMENTS YEAH I DID
THAT I THOUGHT MOST AND WE'RE
REALLY -- THOUGHTFUL AND AND AND
THE COMMENTS THE ONLY THING IS
THE QUESTION OF IS IT TIMELY.
I THINK THIS QUESTIONS ABOUT
TIME IN THIS RESPECT TO CENTER
PROCUREMENT.
BUT MY SENSE IS THERE'S NOT TIME
WHEN THIS WITH THIS BEST.
FIGHTERS OF LAST RESORT THE THE
THE WORLD IS CHANGING IN A
DRAMATIC PACE AS SUCH SAN DIEGO
WANTS TO GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS.
EDISON DOESN'T TO DIFFERENT WE
IS TO TAKE A WHILE THESE THINGS
DON'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
AND I DO IS GOING OUT WRECKED
DISAGREE WITH WAS THE THAT THE
URGENCY TO MOVE ON THE POLAR
ISSUE.
ALTHOUGH I THINK ALL THE OTHER
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE WITH
RESPECT TO TURN WROTE ABOUT
FLINT HAVE TO INCLUDE.
THAT'S RIGHT VERY WELL.
OKAY CAN WE HAVE EMOTIONAL.
WILL MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE TWENTY DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS HUESO BY SO I MORE
LOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
CHIANG.
DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
I FEEL MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR ANOTHER
AUTHORED LISTS THIS.
GO THROUGH THE ROLE
.
NUMBER ONE SB I'M SORRY THANK
YOU.
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE FORTY SIX
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SB FORTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED
HER PREPARATIONS CURRENT VOTE.
THREE ZERO MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE NO CHIANG.
DIED [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
RUBIO SKINNER RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STERN STONE.
WIENER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
I ITEM NUMBER TWO SB. SEVENTY I
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BILL.
AS FOR THE MAINTENANCE -- THIS
CALL THE ROLL. TWO ITEMS TO SP
SEVENTY TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THREE ZERO HUESO
HI WITH SO I'M MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
CHIANG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL MCGUIRE
SKINNER STERN WIENER.
WIENER AYE. SEVEN ZERO OR HOLD
THE ROLE OF COMPRESSION MEMBERS.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB ONE FIVE FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRAD BIRD.
AND THAT ONE IS ALSO DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS -- I RECOMMEND I
VOTE.
THIS CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GIVE HAS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOTE EIGHT ZERO
MARLATT.
MOORLACH I FEEL.
WIRE RUBIO.
I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE
LET'S SAY -- WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR YEAH [inaudible]
NO.
THE WING IT.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- TODAY TO
PRESENT A BILL THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL.
REDUCE THE RISK AN IMPACT BOTH
OF WILDFIRES BUT ALSO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS THAT WE
NEED TO BE UTILIZING TO PREVENT
WILDFIRES.
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT THOSE HAVE ON VULNERABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND VULNERABLE.
I WANT TO START BY.
THE COMMITTEE -- FOR THEIR WORK
AND THE AMENDMENTS -- I WANT TO
FLESH OUT.
V..
I APPRECIATE THE THE POINTS
ABOUT -- PREVENTING ANY COST
SHIFTING [inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
I APPRECIATE THE POINTS ABOUT
RUNNING COST SHIFTING GOOD WITH
THAT.
SHE THE POINTS ABOUT EVEN IF THE
PC'S ABILITY TO SAY.
YES OR NO.
I THINK THAT'S FINE.
SO WILL ACCEPT THOSE I KNOW
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT AND AND I WANT TO
GIVE. ONE OF OUR SUPPORTERS SOME
SOME -- SOME ROOM TO DISCUSS
THAT -- BUT THE PART THAT'S
REALLY NOT FLESHED OUT YET IN
THE LEGISLATION AND IN THE
ANALYSIS IS.
ON THE BEHIND THE METER SIDE SO
WE ALSO DON'T WANT.
WE DON'T WANT.
THOSE IN THE WILL BE WHO ARE
GETTING SOME MICRO GREAT FOR
THEIR HOSPITAL TO GET
NECESSARILY THE SAME RATE OR OR
THE SAME COSTS THAT PROJECT THAT
SOMEBODY'S NOT BENEFITING SO.
THE BENEFICIARY HAS TO PAY HERE
WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE COST
SHIFTS SO I JUST WANT TO FIGURE
OUT SOME MECHANICS TO FIGURE OUT
THE BEHIND THE METER SIDE OF THE
NON CIRCUIT SIDE.
AS WE GO FORWARD BUT FOR THE IN
FRONT OF THE METER AT THE
CRITICAL CIRCUIT SIDE I I I DO
THINK THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME
CONNECTION TO THE BENEFITS TO
THE GRID SO.
SO I'M THERE ON THAT I JUST SORT
OF WANT TO GIVE YOU HAVE. TO
WORK WITH YOU GUYS GOING FORWARD
TO TO TO SEARCH OUT THE WITH
YOUR HOSPITAL A NURSING FACILITY
A FIRE STATION THOSE MICROGRAMS
ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON THE
CRITICAL CIRCUIT SIDE SO ONE
FLESH THAT AS WE GO FORWARD.
WITH THE IMMENSE TODAY.
AND WITH THAT.
HAVE AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
DIGGING FURTHER BUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABOUT.
YEAH YEAH CAN'T CAL'S WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR THE THOROUGH
ANALYSIS A DOES A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF POINTING OUT.
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING A MIKE
REGRET ON RESILIENCY.
AND ADDITIONAL RELIABILITY AS
YOU ALL ARE AWARE AND SPECIALLY
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I GUESS
OTHER MEMBERS OF SEVERAL OF YOU
HAVE BEEN DOWN TO OUR WEATHER
CENTER.
WE HAVE A STATE OF THE ART
WEATHER CENTER THAT WEATHER
CENTER HELPS US MAKE ALL KINDS
OF DECISIONS OPERATIONAL
ENGINEERING DECISIONS OTHER
THINGS THAT -- COME INTO PLAY
WITH OUR CLIMATE CHANGES THAT
ARE TAKING PLACE.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL AREAS
WITHIN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY
THAT COULD BENEFIT NOT FROM
MAKES SPECIFIC CUSTOMER -- BASIS
BUT A BROADER OF PUBLIC BENEFIT.
FOR SHERIFF'S SUBSTATIONS FIRE
STATIONS -- CRITICAL WATER
FACILITIES AND OTHERS WHERE WE
THINK THIS WOULD BE OF BENEFIT.
COUPLE YEARS AGO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MIKE AUTO APPROVED A PAST
ABILITY TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
THAT KIND OF WAS AHEAD OF ITS
TIME IN IDENTIFYING THE NEED FOR
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
WE TOOK THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
PROPOSE SEVEN PROJECTS ON WILD
FIRE MITIGATION.
THAT DECISION IS PENDING FOR THE
PC AND ACTUALLY TAKES A THE
REJECTS WERE HOPING TO GET THAT
TURNED AROUND.
BUT WE THINK CUSTOMER OWNED
MICRO GRIDS ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WHEN WE
IMPLEMENTED OUR DE ENERGIZING
PROGRAMS.
WE DID SOME ENGINEERING WORK TO
TRY TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF WHO
WOULD BE IMPACTED THIS WOULD BE
ANOTHER MITIGATION TOOL TO
LESSEN THE IMPACTS ON CUSTOMERS.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR -- WE THINK THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD WE ALSO
POINTED OUT -- THIS PROGRAM IN
OUR WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN
THAT WAS FILED COUPLE MONTHS AGO
MORE OPEN THE PC WILL PROVE THAT.
IN A TIMELY MATTER AND WE CAN GO
FORWARD WITH -- ADDITIONAL
MISSED MITIGATION MEASURES.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
COME UP TO THE MIKE.
LARA COME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
JAMIE MEDER FOR KELSEY CA NOT IN
OPPOSITION -- APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE --
AUTHORS OFFICE COMMITMENT TO
KEEP WORKING WITH US -- JUST TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FROM KEEPING AYE
CCA'S FROM DEPLOYING MICROGRAMS
IN THIS IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY AND
REAPING THE BENEFITS SO.
THANKS CONTINUE.
TO MOVE WHERE THE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M NOT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF TURN.
INTERMENT RENEWABLE GENERATION
AND WE ARE INTERESTED IN SEEING
THE ROLE FOR MICROGRAPHS BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED THIS BILL --
INAPPROPRIATELY PRIORITIZES
POTENTIALLY EXPENSIVE MIKE
REGRET INVESTMENTS WITHOUT
INSURING THEIR THE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
AND LEAST COST OPTION FOR
PROMOTING GRADE RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY -- THE BILL DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT
UTILITIES HAVE INVESTED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS DURING THE LAST
DECADE.
IN MODERN GREAT TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING SENSOR SWITCHES AND
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT --
PRECISELY TO PROMOTE RESILIENCY
DURING PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
OUTAGES -- DOES SOLUTION OF A
MICROGRAM MAY OR MAY NOT BE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS ABOUT RESILIENCY --
THEY ARE POTENTIALLY VERY
EXPENSIVE AND THAT'S WHERE WE
GET TO OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
RATE PAYER INTEREST STANDARD
THAT IS ARTICULATED IN THE BILL --
THERE'S A REFERENCE SECTION
SEVEN FORTY POINT EIGHT AS THE
BASIS FOR DETERMINING WHETHER AN
INVESTMENT IS IN THE RATEPAYERS
INTEREST -- AND IT IS -- IS A
PARTICULAR PROVISION THAT IS
NARROW IT'S USED IN THE CONTEXT
OF PROMOTING.
LOW EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
I INVESTMENTS IN OUR VIEW THE
STANDARD DOESN'T REALLY WORK FOR
THIS PURPOSE -- BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T CONSIDER THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS TO THE BROAD GROUP OF
RATE PAYERS WHO HAVE TO FOOT THE
BILL FOR THIS -- WE THINK THAT
MICHAEL GREAT INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE FUNDED BY THE UTILITIES
SHOULD BE EVALUATED USING
TRADITIONAL ANALYSES FOR THE
BENEFITS AND COSTS OF THE
INVESTMENT.
ON END CONSIDERING THE COSTS OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO
SOLVING THE SAME PROBLEM.
ON IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THE
BILL CURRENTLY CONSIDERS THE PC
ALLOWS THE PC TO COMPARE THE
BENEFITS AND COSTS OF THESE
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES -- IN
ADDITION THERE IS A COST
RECOVERY PROVISION THAT DIRECTS
THE RECOVERY OF COSTS IN
PROPORTION TO THE BENEFITS
RECEIVED BY VARIOUS GROUPS OF
REPAIRS WERE NOT SURE WHAT THIS
MEANS.
THE COSTS.
MAY OR MAY NOT END UP GETTING
RECOVERED FROM NON PARTICIPANT
CUSTOMERS VERSUS PARTICIPANTS WE
THINK THAT THERE'S A
CLARIFICATION HERE.
THAT ANY COST SHOULD BE
RECOVERED FROM ALL CUSTOMERS ON
A NON BY PASSABLE BASIS BECAUSE
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE WILL
GUARANTEE A LOT OF LITIGATION
OVER WHAT IT MAY OR MAY NOT MEAN.
ON AND THEN FINALLY WE WOULD
JUST.
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT ANY
MICROGRAM VESTMENTS BY A UTILITY
SHALL EARN A REASONABLE RATE OF
RETURN.
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
TRADITIONAL CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THIS
IS A MISSTATEMENT OF EXISTING
ALONG.
EXISTING LAW SETS RATES SO THAT
UTILITIES HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOVER THEIR RATE OF RETURN
THEY ARE NOT GUARANTEED THE RATE
OF RETURN THAT IS.
PART OF THE RISK FACTOR THAT
GOES INTO SETTING THIS COST
CAPITAL -- AND I WOULD JUST
CAUTION THE COMMITTEE GIVEN THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE THREE
MAJOR UTILITIES THAT THEY INTEND
TO SEEK HUGE INCREASES IN THEIR
RATES OF RETURN ON SHAREHOLDER
EQUITY.
IT'S REALLY NOT A PRO TO
ESTABLISH NEW RIGHTS FOR
RECOVERY OF SHAREHOLDER COST
INSURER EQUITY.
RETURNS -- AS PART OF STATE
LEGISLATION SO WE HAVE BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
WE ARE TRYING TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE
IN OUR FEEDBACK.
THANKS.
I THINK THAT WAS VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE US STEVE YOU
ARE -- I WOULD LIKE TO STRESS WE
NEED TO STOP USING THESE TRYST
TRADITIONAL WAYS OF EVALUATING
THE AT THE GRID -- THESE.
I'M A MANUFACTURING ENGINEER
WORKED IN THE FORTY YEARS.
I AT I I AM TOTALLY AMAZED THIS
IS CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S A
COLLECTION A SPREADSHEET.
THAT ARE USED TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT THAT'S WHERE THE TOP CARD.
OF CAME INTO SIGHT [inaudible]
DOT CHART.
WE KNOW THE SUN RISES EVERY DAY
WE DON'T WE NEED TO GO TO
DISCRETE EVENT SCHEDULING THE
KIND OF THING THAT TOYOTA USES
TO BUILD CARS JUST IN TIME.
I ANALOG SCHEDULING.
IS BATCHING Q..
SO YOU YOU SAY ALL I GET SO MUCH.
AND YOU ACT AS IF YOU HAVE
STORAGE I'VE EVEN HAD PEOPLE --
IT HURT PEOPLE'S TALK ABOUT
THINGS IN TERMS OF 30% CAPACITY.
BUT A IF YOU LOOK AT WIND I
TAKEN ALL CAL ISEL STUFF YOU
LOOK AT HOW UNRELIABLE WIND IS.
AND YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE OTHER --
SITUATIONS USE YOU LOOK AT THIS
DATA.
YOU ABSOLUTELY NEED TO CHANGE.
SENATOR BRADFORD'S STASHED
STORAGE THING.
I PUBLIC IN THIS AND I'M SAYING
THIS IS A WASTE OF TIME TO HAVE
ALL THESE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
THESE ANSWERS ARE TOLD THEY ARE
THERE WE ENDED THE MECHANISMS
ARE THEY ARE THE COMMISSION
DOESN'T USE THEM I'VE DOCKET IT.
BASIC SYSTEMS NOBODY EVEN CUT
ASK ME WHAT WHAT'S THIS DO OR
HOW'S THIS WORK -- I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE TO IT. TO TALK WITH --
WITH ANYBODY ON THIS WE EXCHANGE
THIS.
IT'S JUST CLIMATE CHANGE WE
CAN'T PLAN USING THESE
TRADITIONAL METHODS.
I'M I'M SORRY I'M PASSION ABOUT
THIS AND I'VE BEEN PASSIONATE
TODAY PROBABLY MORE THAN I
SHOULD HAVE.
SO OKAY PASSIONS GO THANK YOU
AND I AND WE COULD SOMEBODY
PLEASE LOOK AT THE POSITION
LETTER BUTTON.
THAT THING DOESN'T WORK.
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A BLACK HOLE
I PUT IN POSITION LETTERS YOU
GUYS SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN IN
YOU'RE NOT GETTING.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR.
WE WE DO GET LETTERS BY THE WAY
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AMENDMENTS.
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING WITH THEM
AND THEN WANT TO FLESH OUT THE
NON UTILITY OWNED PIECE OF IT
[inaudible]
GOING.
FOR OKAY VERY GOOD.
WE HAVE TO HAVE MOTION.
YEAH DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS I
GET ASKED TWO QUESTION BECAUSE
RESEARCHER.
CENTER STERN IS THERE EVIDENCE
THAT MIKE READS WORK EFFECTIVELY
IN AN EMERGENCY.
IS THERE EVIDENCE I WOULD GO TO
OUR EXPERTS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED ON THE FIELD.
BEEN USING THEM AT THEIR
CRITICAL CIRCUITS FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING COSTS YES WE HAVE
US SOME EXPERIENCE WE'VE GOT --
A COUPLE OF I CORPORATES ARE IN
EXISTENCE AND WE HAVE -- OTHERS
THAT WE SET UP. ONE OF THEM IS
FOR A LOCAL TRIBE -- THE WE SET
UP AND IF THEY HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE COVERED THOUGH
IS IF ALL YOUR LINES ARE ABOVE
GROUND.
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO DE
ENERGIZED BECAUSE OF WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND TREES OR ANYTHING
FLYING AROUND.
THAT'S AN INHIBITOR BUT IF YOU
HAVE THE THE DESIGN AND
ENGINEERING IS DONE WITHIN THAT.
DEFINED AREA WHERE YOU'RE
SEEKING TO PROTECT IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
ENSURE POWER.
AND SHARE POWER WITH OTHER.
YES YEAH OUR IDEA IN THIS IS
DEVELOPING IT FOR A LARGER
SYSTEM WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
DEVELOP IT FOR ONE PROJECT
CUSTOMER.
BUT MORE IN A CIRCUIT OR ON A
REGIONAL BASIS A LOT OF TIMES IN
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY NEEDS
COUNTY.
THE WEATHER CONDITIONS MIGHT BE.
ADVERSE OUTSIDE OF THAT
IMMEDIATE AREA BUT THE
TRANSMISSION LINES SPEEDING UP.
DON'T GIVE US ANY OTHER OPTIONS
IN THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
CAN BRING -- MICROGROOVE INTO
THAT COMMUNITY AND NOT HAVE TO
RELY ON THAT.
EXTERNAL TRANSMISSION SOURCE
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WERE LIKE.
WHEN THERE'S AN OUTAGE WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO BE IRELAND DID?
ADD MAJOR DISCONNECTED FROM THE
LARGER GRID AN ISLAND COULD BE
OF PARTICULAR.
THERE ARE STILL MAINTAINING
POWER COULD BE A LARGER.
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WELL ALL
DEPENDS ON HOW YOUR SYSTEM IS
ENGINEERED AND YOUR DIFFERENT
PATHS TO GET THERE YOU CAN GET
TO THE FREEWAY OR TO THE AIRPORT.
BY FREEWARE BY HIGHWAY --
HIGHWAY OR CITY STREETS IT'S THE
SAME KIND OF THING TO TELL YOU
DESIGNED THE SYSTEM.
AROUND WHATEVER CONDITION YOU'RE
TRYING TO AVOID.
SOME NEW THIS COMMITTEES I WANT
TO THANK CENTE STERN FOR
BRINGING A SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT.
CAN I JUST ADD ON THIS WORKS
VERY WELL WITH UNDER GROUNDING
AND AND I AND I TO THE I SUPPORT
YOUR PUSH ON TO AND AND I THINK
THIS ISN'T JUST A MICRO GREED
ONLY BILL EITHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF
BACK UP POWER SO THINK ABOUT
AGAIN.
A HOSPITAL OR SENIOR CENTER
THOSE PLACES THAT REALLY WHEN
YOU'RE ON RESPIRATORS OR YOU
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO THROUGH A
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
RIGHT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET
HURT. TO GO BACK TO DIESEL EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
IT'S THERE BUT IT'S NOT RELIABLE
DURING A FIRE I I WAS LITERALLY
HAULING TANKS A DIESEL PASSED
THE THE BLOCKADES TO TRY TO GET
OUR URGENT CARE CENTER BACK UP
AND RUNNING BECAUSE SOMEONE NEED
A TECHNICIAN.
I MEAN THAT'S NOT A GOOD
SITUATION TO BE IN IN A FIRE SO
I THINK.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST.
MICROGRAMS ARE THE ONLY WAY TO
SOLVE THIS I THINK IT'S GONNA BE
A HOST OF SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH
THIS.
THIS CITY SYSTEM BUT BUT I YEAH
I APPRECIATE THAT THE INTEREST I
THINK THERE'S AN INTEGRATED WITH
MOVIES FOR THANK YOU -- DON YES --
I'D LIKE ALSO -- APPLIED TO HER
STERN FOR BRING THIS UP THE AND
IN MY DISTRICT -- YOU KNOW -- SB
NINE A ONE I SUPPOSE EVEN.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO IT --
BECAUSE SB NOT A ONE HAD NOT
BEEN A FACTOR THAT THE CITY OF
CALISTOGA WAS SHUT DOWN.
NO WHERE.
I WAS THERE ANY WILDFIRE
IMMINENT IN THE CITY OF
CALISTOGA BECAUSE THE
TRANSMISSION LIGHTS WENT THROUGH
THERE.
YEAH THEY WERE SHOT DOWN THEIR
RESTAURANTS WERE SHUT DOWN THEIR
HOTELS WERE SHUT DOWN.
GROCERY STORES HOSPITALS.
I I JUST THINK THIS IS -- YOU
KNOW WHAT THE ONE ELEMENT OF
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THAT'S THE
MICRO GRADS.
IS WELL THOUGHT OUT AND I'D LIKE
THEY GUESTS THE GENIE.
I THINK FOR IN MAY IN MANY CASES
FOR DOING THE RIGHT THING.
I NOT ONLY OF THIS BUT AS YOU
AFTER THE WEATHER STATIONS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE TO TRY TO HELP --
YOUR CUSTOMERS OUR CUSTOMERS --
YOU'LL GET THROUGH THESE
CALAMITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS BACK GAS FOREVER THANK
YOU A QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN SEVEN FORTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL
BY WITH SO I MORE LOT
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE TING.
TING AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE
HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL I MCGUIRE RUBIO.
THE AYE SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN ICE DOWN WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WILL IT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OF THE PROPS OF MEMBERS AND WILL
WELCOME OUR NEXT PRESENTER.
CENTER CABALLERO WELCOME.
ITEM SIX SB.
THREE EIGHTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS I LET
ME START OFF BY SAYING I WILL
TAKE THE TWO OF THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ONE TO DELETE THEM
MERCED RIVER.
RIVER PROJECT REFERENCE.
AND NUMBER TWO TO INSURE THAT
THE HYDRO.
OUR PS CREDITS.
IS LIMITED TO MEET THE
COMPLIANCE.
REQUIREMENTS FOR TURLOCK AND
MODESTO IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
IN REGARDS TO THE SUGGEST A
REPORT ON THE DISTRICTS ALREADY
FILED THE OUR PS COMPLIANCE
REPORTS WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION.
AT THE END OF EVERY COMPLIANCE
PERIOD WHICH IS EVERY THREE
YEARS AND THEY FILE AN ANNUAL
POWER CONTENT LABEL WHICH
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF THE
DISTRICT POWER SOURCES IN ROUTE
READ YOUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROFILING AND SO.
RATHER THAN -- A REPORT IF WE
COULD JUST RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM THE ENERGY COMMISSION
UPDATING THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
PROGRESS OF THE DISTRICT'S.
PROGRESS TOWARDS -- OUR PS
COMPLAINTS I THINK THAT MY THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE BETTER.
AND SO THAT'S FINE THAT'S GREAT
GETTING TO WHAT WE WERE
INTERESTED GREAT THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I FIGURED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SB THREE EIGHTY SIX WOULD ALLOW
THE TURLOCK IN MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS WHICH JOINT
JOINTLY ON THE DON PEDRO
HYDROELECTRIC PROJECT TO
RECOGNIZE AS RENEWABLE THE HYDRO
ELECTRIC POWER THEY GENERATE TO
MEET THE RENEWABLE PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS A DISTRICT BELL AND THE
INTENT IS TO PROVIDE ECONOMIC
RELIEF AND EQUITY TO THESE
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS AND THE
RATE PAYERS THAT ALREADY PRODUCE
ZERO CARBON ENERGY.
LAST YEAR NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY
REQUIREMENTS WERE PASSED INTO
LAW.
WITH SB ONE HUNDRED THE
REQUIREMENTS DICTATE THAT
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOUL TO RETAIL
AND USE IT CUSTOMERS.
INCREASE UNTIL THEY REACH A 100%
ZERO CARBON ELECTRICITY BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THE GOALS ARE
LAUDABLE AND WORTHY BUT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM HAS INEQUITIES
THAT WE SHOULD NOT IGNORE AND
THEY'VE BEEN HISTORICAL
INEQUITIES SINCE THE OUR PS
SYSTEM WAS WAS THAT WAS DESIGNED.
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
MODESTO IRRIGATION DISTRICT
FIRST BEGAN PROVIDING CARBON
FREE HYDRO ELECTRIC ENERGY TO
CUSTOMERS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE GENERATED
FROM THE JOINTLY OWNED AND
OPERATED DON PEDRO RESERVOIR IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE NEW DON
PEDRO CONSTRUCTION WAS COMPLETED
TO INCREASE PLANT CAPACITY.
DESPITE OWNING THIS RESORT
RESOURCE.
ASIAN DISTRICT WAS REQUIRED TO
BUILD A THE FOUR MEGAWATT SOLAR
POWER PLANT IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN ORDER TO
MEET.
THEIR OUR PS REQUIREMENTS THIS
SOLAR PLANT COST A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
TWENTY YEARS.
LIKEWISE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE MODESTO IRRIGATION
DISTRICT HAS INVESTED SIXTY
MILLION IN CAPITAL FOR THE
MCENERY SOLAR POWER PLANT.
THESE INVESTMENTS WERE REQUIRED
SOLELY BECAUSE HYDROELECTRIC
POWER GENERATED AT THE NEW DON
PEDRO IS NOT RECOGNIZED IN THE
OUR PS.
THE DISTRICT S. THE FAILURE TO
COUNT THIS HYDROELECTRIC
PRODUCTION WILL COST OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO REACH THEIR TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS AND THE RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE CAPITAL EXPENDITURES.
EXPENDITURES ARE UNDERTAKEN
DIRECTLY BY RATE PAYERS IN A
REGION CONSISTENTLY CONSIDERED
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED I
CURRENT ENERGY RATE.
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT WILL
NEED TO INVEST THREE HUNDRED
MILLION MORE OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS.
BOTH DISTRICTS ARE FORCED TO
MAKE MASSIVE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
IN UNNECESSARY AND NOT
UNNECESSARY PROJECTS FOR THEM
WELL SIMON SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEVALUING ITS OWN RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCE. TO BE CLEAR THESE
IRRIGATION DISTRICT PROVIDE
WATER AND ELECTRICITY TO THE
RATE PAYERS.
THE ENERGY PRODUCED BY THE SOLAR
PURCHASES IS NOT NEEDED FOR THEM
TO MEET THEIR RATE PAYERS NEEDS.
THIS DIVERT TO RATE PAYER MONEY
FROM IS STAYING IN THE LOCAL
ECONOMY AND STAND STEAD SENT IT
OUT.
OF THE REGION TO SOLAR ENERGY
PRODUCERS.
ENERGY COSTS ARE THE HIGHEST IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE IT IS
VERY HOT IN THE SUMMER AND VERY
COLD IN THE WINTER.
AND THE TIERED RATE SYSTEM HURT
FOR REPAIRS THE MOST.
ADDITIONALLY TURLOCK IRRIGATION
DISTRICT IS ONE OF EIGHT
BALANCING AUTHORITIES IN THE
STATE AND HAS TO BALANCE RETAIL
DEMAND GENERATION AND MUST MEET
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY.
BOTH SOLAR AND WIND AND YOUR
ENERGY OR INTERMITTENT SOURCES
AND CANNOT PROVIDE DIRECT
RELIABILITY THAT THEY REALLY
NEED.
TURLOCK IN MODESTO IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL ENERGY THEY DO NOT
NEED SIMPLY TO MEET THE NEW AND
DATE.
INSTEAD OF LOCKING UP MONEY NOW
FOR SOLAR THE DISTRICTS MUST
THEN SELL OFF AT A LOSS ALLOWING
THEIR HYDRO TO COUNT WILL FREE
UP REPAIR FRIEND TO GO TOWARDS
GETTING THEM TO THEIR 1100%
CARBON FREE AND GRADE
RELIABILITY.
LIKE STORAGE -- LIKE STORAGE.
SB THREE EIGHTY SIX IS A NARROW
BELL THAT WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED
ECONOMIC RELIEF TO COMMUNITIES
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES A MUCH SOLAR
ENERGY THAT IT.
THAT IT HAS TO PAY OTHER STATES
TO TAKE IT TO AVOID AN OVERLOAD --
SO THERE ISN'T GOING ANYWHERE
LAST YEAR THE STATE APPROVED AT
ALL NEW HOUSES HAVE MUST HAVE
SOLAR PANELS THEY WILL STILL
HAVE TO MEET THE 1100% ZERO
CARBON ENERGY MANDATE BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND HERE WITH ME TODAY IS JAMES
MCFALL MODESTO IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS AND JOSH WHITE REIMER
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAID
JAMES MCCALL AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER OF
WITH ELECTRIC RESOURCE DIVISION
ADMINISTER RIGESA DISTRICT -- SO
IN CHARGE OF ENERGY PROCUREMENT.
LIKE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN IN FRONT
OF YOU AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR CARRIER FOR
PUTTING ASIDE HERE.
FOR AS YOU HEARD MR GEISHA
DISTRICT PROVIDES.
YOU'RE ADDITION WATER DOMESTIC
WATER FOR THE CITY MODESTO AN
ELECTRIC SERVICE. FOR A HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS. FOR A MEDIUM SIZED
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED UTILITY
WITH THE COMMAND OF ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS.
AND RETAIL ENERGY SALES OF ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED GIGAWATT
HOURS.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL TO
COUNT LARGE HYDRO TOWARD THE
DISTRICTS ARE PS REQUIREMENTS
GIVEN THE FINANCIAL IMPACT TO
OUR RATE PAYERS IN A REGION THAT
IS RECOGNIZED BY THE STATE AS
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED.
APPROXIMATELY 35% OF THE
DISTRICTS.
ELECTRIC SERVICE.
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE WITHIN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
BUT ASK YOUR GUEST MISTREAT OWNS
ABOUT 352% OF THE ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED MEGAWATT DON FUTURE
HYDROELECTRIC FACILITY.
ON AVERAGE WE RECEIVE ABOUT 8%
OF OUR ANNUAL ENERGY FROM THE
FROM THE FACILITY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO STRESS THAT --
THIS ENERGY PRODUCED BY DON
PEDRO IS ONLY USED TO SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS ELECTRIC NEEDS NOT
SOLD INTO THE MARKET.
DURING THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
STATE'S OUR PS PROGRAM THE
DISTRICT MADE SEVERAL RENEWABLE
ENERGY PURCHASES.
AND GIVEN THE NASCENT MARKET AT
THE TIME PRICES FOR THOSE RIP
PURCHASES WERE ORDERS OF
MAGNITUDE HIGHER THAN
TRADITIONAL POWER PRICES.
WE ESTIMATE THAT SINCE. TWENTY
TEN EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ENERGY COSTS IN ORDER TO
PURCHASE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND WE EXPECTED TO GROW BY AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH.
TWENTY THIRTY ALTHOUGH THERE'S
NO WAY TO RECOVER THIS CLASS OR
VOID COSTS RELATED TO CONTRACTS
THAT ARE ALREADY EXECUTED.
ALLOWING DON PETER TO COUNT
TOWARDS THE OUR PS PROGRAM WOULD
SAVE MIT CUSTOMERS AN ESTIMATED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. THREE
TWENTY THIRTY AND WHILE THE
SOUNDS MODEST COMPARED TO THE
EXPENSE.
AS THE AS YOU ALL KNOW EVERY
LITTLE BIT HELPS IN A TO THOSE
CUSTOMERS IN THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
IN SUMMARY.
THE ABILITY TO COUNT THIS LARGE
WRITER RESOURCE TOWARDS OUR PS
REQUIREMENTS WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF TO OUR RATE PAYERS
IN THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK YOU
AGAIN FOR BY PROVIDING THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
VERY WELL -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOSH WHY AROUND TE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER AT
THE TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
IT'S MY PLEASURE BEING FROM THE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO TEST. FOR THE
SB THREE EIGHTY SIX WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING FOR
THIS IMPORTANT DISTRICT BILL.
AND HELP TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
SOME CONTACT AROUND OUR UNIQUE
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES IN OUR
DISTRICT.
YEAH HE WAS STABBED US IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS THE
FIRST PUBLICLY OWNED IRRIGATION
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
TODAY EIGHTY EIGHTY PROVIDES --
GEISHA WATER TO MORE THAN FIFTY
EIGHT HUNDRED GROWERS OVER
SERVICE TERRITORY THAT IS.
A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES.
IN ADDITION TO EIGHTY PROVIDES
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
ELECTRICITY TO A GROWING RETAIL
CUSTOMER BASE THAT IT NOW
EXCEEDS A HARD THOUSAND
RESIDENTIAL.
FARM COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL
MUNICIPAL ACCOUNTS.
GIVEN RELIABILITY IS OF UTMOST
CONCERN TO OUR WE ARE ALSO ON
BALANCING THE FORTY WHICH MEANS
THAT WE HAVE THE REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE MOMENT TO MOMENT GRID
RELIABILITY. TO OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY DIRECTLY IMPACTING THE
TYPE AND GENERATION WE OWN AND
OPERATE.
DE ID HAS A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO
THAT INCLUDES WIND SOLAR
GEOTHERMAL SMALL HYDRO.
A BIO MASS NATURAL GAS AND LARGE
HYDRO.
WE'VE ALWAYS COMPLIED WITH THE
R. P. S..
AND IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO CENTER WAS 20%.
DE ID IS UNIQUE AMONG UTILITIES
DO THE FACT THAT WE OVER WE ARE
OVER SUPPLIED WITH EXISTING
POWER AND HAVE NO UNMET LONG
TERM RESOURCE NEEDS.
WE ARE ALSO UNIQUE IN THAT WE
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS IN MY DE
OWN AND OPERATE THE DUMB PETER
PROJECT ON THE TO ON THE RIVER.
A DON PEDRO PROJECT IS NOT PART
OF EITHER THE STATE OR FEDERAL
PROJECT.
A RATHER IS BUILT BY THE
DISTRICTS AND IS LOCALLY OWNED
OPERATED AND FINANCED BY US.
ON AVERAGE DON PEDRO PROVIDES
20% OF T. ID'S ANNUAL ELECTRIC.
LOAD.
BUT IN BUT DURING WHAT YEARS
THIS CAN BE AS HIGH AS 35% --
PEDRO'S OPERATE ON A WATER FIRST
PRIORITY MEANING THAT RELEASES
ARE MADE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL IN
IRRIGATION DEMANDS AND THE POWER
PRODUCES NOT SOLD INTO THE
MARKET.
RATHER THE CARBON FREE RESOURCE
IS SUPPLIED TO T. ID'S CUSTOMERS.
YETI SPORTS THE STATE'S CARBON
GOALS AND HAVE SUBMITTED IN OUR
INTEGRATED RESOURCES PLAN OUR
PLAN TO ME SB ONE HUNDRED
PLANNING GOALS.
HOWEVER IF THE ANGLES THE SAME
COUNTING OUR HYDRO NOW WOULD
ALLOW FOR NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
DEVELOP THAT COULD ASSIST WITH.
REQUIREMENTS OF BEING A BOUNCING
AUTHORITY RATHER THAN GOING OUT
TO BID FOR POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS WE DON'T NEED.
CAN'T USE OF COST EFFECTIVELY
HOUSE OUR CUSTOMERS LOAD.
WE SIMPLY WANT TO COUNT THE
EXISTING COVER FOR YOU YOUR
RESOURCES THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
HAVE PAID.
FOR DOES NOT REMOVED THE ID'S
NEED FOR FUTURE PROCUREMENT OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AS MOST
CERTAINLY ALL FUTURE POWER
PURCHASES WILL BE RENEWABLE.
IT SIMPLY ALLOWS T. ID TO AVOID
BUYING BUYING POWER THAT WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A NEED.
FOR IN SUMMARY TID SUPPORTS SB
THREE EIGHTY SIX BECAUSE AS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE NEEDED
RECOGNITION FOR OUR RATE PAYERS
EARLY INVESTMENT IN CARBON FREE
GENERATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO SHARE T. A. B. C. NEWS
STORY.
THE AUTHORS WERE TO WE HAVE
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MISSION IS WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AFTER THIS IMPORTANT
DISTRICT BILL AND MOVING THE
CONVERSATIONFORWARD ON THIS --
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU TO
HAVE OPPOSITION.
YOU I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THEM THE
MOVING OF THE GOAL POSTS IN THE
R. P. S. -- HOW WILL IT THERE AT
THE OUR PS IS RELATED TO THE
CONTENT LABEL WHICH WERE FORCED
TO STATEWIDE BE ABLE TO COMPARE?
AND SO HOW WILL THIS LARG HYDRO
THAT'S NOW ELIGIBLE HYDRO SHOW
UP ON THEIR I I IS THERE
SOMETHING SHOULD BE IN THERE TO
SAY IT'S NOW ELIGIBLE LARGE
FIGHT GO.
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. 31%
TO DROP IN -- CARBON SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE BUT NO GOES UP AND
DOWN.
I HAVE A CHART THAT DOES EVERY
COUNTY IN THE STATE.
ARE THE AND THE REASON WHY
PASSION ABOUT THIS IS.
I AM I HEAR PEOPLE SAY IT'S MUCH
GREAT EVERYTHING ELSE. 35%
INCREASE IN CARBON. 35% INCREASE
CARBON THEY DO NOT DELVER THE
RENEWALS THAT'S MY PASSION.
I DON'T WANT GOAL POST MOVE I
ACTUALLY CUT LOOK AT THE OUR PS
THINGS LIKE THIS IS SOME
ARTIFICIAL THINGS BECAUSE OF
PEOPLE TO DO THINGS.
MAKE.
DECISIONS ON BUYING STUFF IF
THEY WERE TO FOCUS ON THE CARBON.
WORK FROM THE HIGHEST CARBON --
AREA TO THE LOWEST.
THAT'S HOW A BUSINESS CUTS ARE
COST AND AND DOES IT MOST
EFFECTIVELY SO I HAVE SOMETHING
IN THERE TO NOTE THAT THE POWER
CONTENT A LITTLE IS RELATED.
HAVE SOMETHING IN THERE SO THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THEY LOOK AT IT
WE KNOW THIS IS A SPECIAL CASE.
AND THEY DIDN'T JUST SUDDENLY
JUMP THANK YOU THANK YOU WELLS
[inaudible]
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON MORE
WAS LYNN WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS HERE TODAY
OPPOSING THE BILL BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE.
IT'S UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE LAW IT WOULD CREATE AN
UNLEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
UTILITIES ACOSS THE STATE AND
IT WOULD UNDERMINE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS FOR CLEAN
ENERGY ADVANCEMENT IN OUR STATE.
BY AND LARGE LARGE HYDRO CROSS
THE COUNTRY ACROSS OUR PS
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY IS NOT.
YES ELIGIBLE BECAUSE ONE OF THE
PRIMARY PURPOSES OF IN OUR PS IS
TO ENCOURAGE.
INVESTMENT IN NEW CLEAN ENERGY
RESOURCES AND REDUCE RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL RESOURCES.
CALIFORNIA VERY DELIBERATELY
EXCLUDED LARGE HYDRO FROM ITS
OUR PS BECAUSE SOME UTILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A LOT OF IT
ESPECIALLY DURING GOOD WATER
YEARS.
AND IT WOULD CREATE A VERY
UNEVEN PLAYING FIELD FOR
UTILITIES IN TERMS OF MEETING
THERE ARE YES MEETING SOME
UTILITIES WOULD HAVE A VERY LOW
COMPLIANCE BURDEN WHILE OTHER
ONES WOULD HAVE A VERY HIGH
COMPLIANCE BURDEN. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THIS BILL PASSED TURLOCK
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS WOULD
LIKELY NOT NEED TO MAKE ANY
CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENTS. FOR A
GOOD NUMBER OF YEARS ALMOST A
DECADE.
WHILE CONTINUING TO RELY ON
NATURAL GAS AN UNSPECIFIED
MARKET PURCHASES FOR A
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF ITS RETAIL
SALES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
WAS 40%.
WE'RE NOBLES TODAY ARE EXTREMELY
COST EFFECTIVE AND THE PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO GO BEYOND CARBON
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY PASSED ITS
FIRST OUR PS IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
BECAUSE IT WANTED TO MAKE
UTILITIES LESS VULNERABLE TO
SUPPLY SHORTAGES FROM ANY ONE
FUEL TYPE. ONE OF THE MAJOR
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE IS
GOING TO BE HIGH HOTTER AND
DRIER WEATHER WHICH MEANS LESS
ABILITY TO GENERATE HYDROPOWER
OVER TIME.
WHEN A UTILITY IS HEAVILY
RELIANT ON LARGE HYDRO AND FINDS
A WAY TO NOT MAKE INVESTMENT IN
RENEWABLES?
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA PURCHASE
DURING THE DRY YEARS THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SCRAMBLE AND
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO
PURCHASE NATURAL GAS AND THAT'S
NOT GOOD FOR REPAIRS AND THAT'S
NOT GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT?
FINALLY THERE ARE ALREADY
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW THAT
PROVIDE UTILITIES WITH
FLEXIBILITY IF THEY CAN'T MEET
THEIR OUR PS TARGETS FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS INCLUDING
COSTS.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY AND WOULD CREATE AN
OPENING FOR OTHER UTILITIES WITH
HYDRO IN THEIR PORTFOLIO. TO ASK
FOR SIMILAR TREATMENT WHICH
WOULD UNDERMINE THE PROGRAM FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF TURN WE'RE
HERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
I'M AS I'M IS WHISTLING POINTED
OUT THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD IS THE CENTRAL POLICY
MECHANISM THAT THE STATE HAS TO
ACHIEVE ITS LONG TERM CLIMATE
AND ENERGY GOALS AND THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY.
WOULD DO SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE TO
THE DURABILITY AND SUCCESS OF
THE STATE'S OUR PS PROGRAM.
IT'S ALSO COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY
I'M AND IT WOULD PROVIDE UNFAIR
TREATMENT TO ONE SET OF RETAIL
PROVIDERS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN STEPS
IN RECENT YEARS TO ACCOMMODATE
THE SITUATION FOR PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES THAT HAVE A LARGE
SHARE OF HYDROELECTRIC
GENERATION IN THEIR PORTFOLIOS.
THERE HAVE BEEN PROVISIONS IN SB
THREE FIFTY AN SP ONE HUNDRED TO
ADDRESS UTILITIES THAT HAVE HIGH
RELIANCE ON IN ADDITION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ADOPTED A COST
CAP.
THAT HAS BEEN UTILIZED BY THE
MERCED IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
OTHER WORDS IF IT COSTS TOO MUCH
TO COMPLY WITH THE OUR PS
TARGETS.
AND IRRIGATION DISTRICT HAS THE
RIGHT. TO ESTABLISH A COST CAP
AND TO EXERCISE THAT COST CAP AS
A WAY TO PREVENT IT FROM BUYING
RESOURCES THAT IN THE WORDS OF
THE SPONSORS.
THEY DON'T NEED AND THEY FIND TO
BE TOO EXPENSIVE.
WE BELIEVE THIS ISSUE HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED.
PROBLEM IS THAT THE INCLUSION OF
A LARGE HYDROELECTRIC ASSETS IN
THE OUR PS PROGRAM WOULD SIMPLY
UP AND THE CAREFULLY DEVELOPED
ELIGIBILITY RULES AND IT COULD
LEAD TO A MASSIVE REDUCTION IN
THE ANTICIPATED QUAL QUANTITY OF
NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE PRODUCED
UNDER THE STANDARD.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW WE WOULD
DISTINGUISH SITUATION FOR
MODESTO INTERLOCK FROM THOSE OF
MANY OF THE OTHER PUBLICLY OWNED
AN INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES THAT
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL LARGE HYDRO
ELECTRIC RESOURCES IN THEIR
PORTFOLIO.
IF EVERYONE WERE ALLOWED TO
COUNT THOSE RESOURCES THAT OWN
THEM.
WE WOULD SEE APPROXIMATELY A 15%
REDUCTION IN THE OUR PS.
PROGRAM IN OTHER WORDS INSTEAD
OF UTILITIES HAVING TO GET 233%
BY TWENTY TWENTY THEY WOULD ONLY
HAVE TO GET EFFECTIVELY 218%.
WHICH WOULD TAKE US WELL BELOW
THE TARGETS THAT WERE ADOPTED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
IN ADDITION I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT BOTH TURLOCK AND MODESTO
DID APPROVE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD PROCUREMENT PLANS IN
NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR AFTER THE ENACTMENT OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED BOTH OF THOSE PLANS
SHOW THAT THESE TWO IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS.
ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
EXISTING RESOURCE COMMITMENTS
THROUGH THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE UNDER THE ACCELERATED
TARGETS.
IT'S ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
ADOPTION OF THE RELIEF REQUESTED
AND SB THREE EIGHTY SIX WOULD
RESULT IN ONE OF TWO OUTCOMES
ONE NO NEW PROCUREMENT WOULD BE
NEEDED BY THESE UTILITIES
ESSENTIALLY IN PERPETUITY UNDER
THE EXISTING OUR PS.
BUT MORE TROUBLING IT APPEARS TO
ALLOW THESE YOUR GEISHA
DISTRICTS TO RESELL RENEWABLE
POWER THEY ALREADY HAVE UNDER
CONTRACT.
ESSENTIALLY TO TAKE RESOURCES
THAT THEY BOUGHT TO COMPLY WITH
THE OUR PS IN ITS CURRENT
CONFIGURATION AND TO REMARKET IT
TO OTHER MARKET PARTICIPANTS IN
ORDER TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO US THAT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS HAS
ACCEPTED TODAY DO YOU PREVENT
THAT OUTCOME.
WE THINK AT A MINIMUM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SHOULD BE IN CHARGE
OF OF ISSUING A REPORT TO STUDY
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
THESE CHANGES -- AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT AMENDMENT FROM
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ADOPTED
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY WE BELIEVE
THAT THE COST CAP LIMITATION.
IS SUFFICIENT TO DEAL WITH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THESE
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS AND IF THIS
BILL WERE TO MOVE FORWARD AND TO
BECOME LAW.
YOU CAN BE GUARANTEED THAT EVERY
SINGLE HYDRO OWNING UTILITY WILL
HAVE A BILL BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE NEXT YEAR SEEKING
IDENTICAL RELIEF AND THAT WILL
ON WINE THE STATE'S POLICY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA TODAY
ALSO REPRESENTING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND WERE
POSTED THE BILL.
REALLY FOR A COUPLE OF KEY
REASONS THREE NOBLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD HAS BEEN THE BEST.
THE STATE HAS HAD FOR REDUCING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE POLLUTION.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND OTHERS HAVE NOTED THIS
[inaudible]
IT'S NOT.
ON IMPORTANT IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AS THE
STATE IS THE COUNTRY AS THE
WORLD LOOKS TO CALIFORNIA TO BE
A LEADER IN REDUCING.
THE WORST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT A PROGRAM LIKE THE
YOUR PS IS SO SUCCESSFUL AND
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT
REACHING PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
ADOPTED IN OTHER STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
AND TODAY IS THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION HAS WRITTEN.
JUST RELEASED THEIR REPORT ON
DIRTY AIR IT'S PROGRAMS LIKE THE
R. P. S. THAT HELPS TO REDUCE
OUR AIR POLLUTION.
CALIFORNIA LEADS IN THE WORST
AIR POLLUTION ONCE AGAIN WITH
CITIES UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
CONTINUING TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE LAUNCH OF OUR KIDS.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN YEARS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING TO ROLL BACK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE AND MOVE THE
BALL.
JUST AS WE CAN ON PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS.
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS THANK YOU.
LOT ABOUT ON BEHALF OF THE END
OF PRODUCES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
NUMBER SECURE CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION AND
RESTATING THE POINTS ALONG THAT
COMES WITH THE UC ASKING.
THANK YOU. FOR CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
ECHOING THE COMMENTS MADE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY URGING YOUR
NOTEBOOK [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WELL WE DO THAT I'M GONNA STEP
UP FOR FIVE MINUTES AND HAVE.
AS CHAIR OVER AND I'LL BE RIGHT
BACK LOSING GERMAN.
DINNER HILL WAS IT DID YOU HAVE
YOUR HAND UP TO NUMBER.
FIRST LET ME MOVE THE BILL AND
LET ME THANK THE SENATOR FOR
THIS COMMONSENSE MEASURE.
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR PS PROGRAM
THAT IS NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
WE EXCLUDED LARGE HYDRO AND
SMALL HYDRO OUT OF THAT OUR PS
PORTFOLIO SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
AND THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE IT WE HAD COUNTED EARLY
WHICH IS CLEAN DISPATCH BOWL AND
RELIABLE.
WE WOULDN'T BE IN THIS POSITION
HERE TODAY FOR YOU FIGHTING FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY.
BUILDING UNNECESSARY RESOURCES
THAT MEET OUR COMMON CLIMATE
GOALS HI JOE WAS CLEAN IT'S BEEN
RELIABLE IT'S DISPATCH WILL.
AND AND IT'S IT'S IT'S A SAFE
AND TO SIT HERE NOW AND SAY THIS
IS HYDRO THE RIGHT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AS FOR PERSON WHO
SPENT FOUR YEARS AT LA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
AND BIOLOGY MAJOR IT'S INSULTING
BECAUSE THAT'S THE FARTHEST
THING FROM THE TRUTH
[inaudible]
AND WE WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
EMBRACE HYDRO BUT WE WERE
SELLING TECHNOLOGY.
AND TO SIT HERE TODAY AND SAY
THAT WIND AND SOLAR IS ABOUT
CLIMATE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO WIN IN SOLAR
THIRTY YEARS AGO IT WAS ABOUT
GETTING OFF OF FOREIGN OIL IT
WAS DUE?
TO THE DECISION TO GET RID OF
FOREIGN OIL HEARING.
ARE CALIFORNIA IN AMERICA AND
THAT'S WHY WE START BUILDING
WIND AND SOLAR LONGER CAN
FREEWAY DONNA RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IN PALM SPRINGS IT WASN'T ABOUT
CLIMATE ONCE WE REALIZED WE
COULD MAKE MONEY ON SELLING.
WHEN UNTIL IT BECAME ABOUT THE
MONEY SO I SAVE ALL THE MONEY
THIS IS A COMMONSENSE MEASURE
AND I SUPPORT?
ANY OTHER COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
NANCY SKINNER [inaudible]
I'M.
IT IS TRUE THAT OUR OUR PS IS
NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
BUT THIS ACTUALLY.
WHILE THE FEAR IS BY SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS THAT THIS WOULD OPEN
UP.
YOUR PS -- TWO BIG HYDRO IN
TERMS OF YOUR COM MY COLLEAGUES%
COMMENTS FROM GUARDINO IT IT.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY DO THAT IT
DOES IT DOES IN EFFECT CARVE OUT
FOR A COUPLE OF YOUR NATION.
AND I NOTE IN THE ANALYSIS OUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH ONCE
AGAIN.
I THINK OUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
HI IN THIS SET OF BILLS THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS BINDER TODAY I MEAN
THERE IT'S USUALLY VERY VERY
GOOD I'M ALWAYS IMPRESSED BY ITS
VERY IMPRESSIVE TODAY.
AND IT INDICATES THAT.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED ON THAT HE
ARE YOU USE WHICH THE IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL OUR HAVE LOTS OF
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS TO COMPLY
WITH YORK YES.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE -- MORE COST
LIMITATION OPTIONS.
SO AND AS WAS.
INDICATED ALREADY IN TESTIMONY
THE ASIAN DISTRICTS HAVE OPTED
FOR THOSE THINGS AND OF ALREADY
EVEN MADE THEIR PROCUREMENTS
[inaudible]
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO.
I DON'T SEE THE NECESSITY FOR
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW AND DUE TO
THE FEAR THAT IT WOULD CAUSE
OTHER.
ENTITIES TO WANT TO COME TO US
AND OPEN UP THEN THIS KIND OF
CAN OF WORMS [inaudible]
I'M.
I DON'T THINK IT'S WISE TO DO IT
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
AND I'M.
ADDITIONALLY.
THAT WHILE I UNDERSTAND I DIDN'T
HEAR THE OPENING THAT YOU ARE
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS.
THE THERE IS COMMITTEE REFERENCE
ON IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT.
LIMITING THE ABILITY TO SELL.
THIS SUPPLY AND ALSO REQUIRING
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO DO THAT
REPORT AND I DON'T BELIEVE THOSE
WERE.
OKAY REPORT WAS NOT RIGHT SO IT.
IF I IF I MAY THROUGH THE CHAIR.
I'M THE THAT THE INFORMATION IS
ALWAYS IS ALREADY REQUIRED TO GO
TO TO THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
SO RATHER THAN ASK THE
COMMISSION TO DO A REPORT.
IT'S TO DO A LETTER -- IS SO WE
WE WE JUST CHANGED IT SO THAT
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A FULL
REPORT IS JUST THE DATA THAT'S
BEING GIVEN.
I'M ON OUT ON A ANNUAL BASIS
THAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED AS PART
OF THE REPORTING.
I'M.
WE DID TAKE THE ON THE OTHER
AMENDMENT [inaudible] FIVE SO
THAT'S AN IMPROVEMENT BUT I
THINK FUNDAMENTALLY.
IT'S STILL NOT CLEAR
[inaudible]
WHY?
THIS BILL IS NEEDED.
BECAUSE BE I'M.
THE ADDITIONAL RELIEF.
AGAIN MAYBE THERE MAYBE THEY'LL
BE A DEMONSTRATION CAST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AT LEAST DISTRICTS
WILL NEED SOME ADDITIONAL RELIEF.
BUT BUT SO FAR.
THERE IS NO -- THERE'S BEEN NO
DEMONSTRATED NEED FOR THAT.
RELEASED.
BY THE DISTRICTS OWN ACTION.
AND IN FACT -- THE MERCED.
CATION DISTRICT AS FAR AS I KNOW
IT'S NOT EVEN BEEN THAT ENGAGED
IN THE BILL SO.
I'M I'M NOT COMFORTABLE MOVING
FORWARD I DO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESSING NEED
YOUR DISTRICT BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT THAT NEED [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
THAT THERE.
IT MAY BE MORE CLEAR THAT THERE
IS A NEED IN A FEW YEARS BUT AT
THIS MOMENT IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
THAT NEEDS PRESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATE COVER EURO -- WOULD YOU
PLEASE RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT WE'VE HEARD IN
OPPOSITION YOUR BILL THAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
I'M A FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST
SAY THAT -- MERCED IS ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS IS NOT INCLUDED IN
OTHER WORDS WILL BE.
ELIMINATED FROM THE BILL SO THE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED WITH
MERCED -- THEY'RE THEY'RE ON A
DIFFERENT TRACK.
AND INITIALLY WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON THE BILL THEY WANTED
TO BE INCLUDED IN NOW DON'T.
SO THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED -- WILL
BE -- AMENDED OUT AND THEN -- IN
REGARDS TO THE THE THE NEED TO
DO THIS AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT
IN TIME IS THAT M..
IN IN ANY.
IN ANY PROCESS YOU HAVE TO PLAN
AND YOU HAVE TO START SPENDING
MONEY AND YOU HAVE TO START --
FIGURING OUT HOW YOU GET A
FINANCE -- THESE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS ARE NOT CHEAP -- THESE
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS HAVE SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- TO GET
THEMSELVES UP TO COMPLIANCE ARE
NOT ASKING TO ROLL BACK THAT
COMPLIANCE THEY THEY WILL THEY
HAVE LONG TERM CONTRACTS IT WILL
STAY IN THOSE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS.
AND THOSE ARE COMMITMENTS THAT
THEY MAKE THEY MADE AND QUITE
FRANKLY THAT ENERGY THEY BUY AT
A PREMIUM AND THEY SELL IT OFF.
THEY HAVE TO SELL IT CHEAP TO TO
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF THE STATE THEY
DON'T NEED IT WE DON'T NEED IT
IN THE STATE SO.
WE ARE CREATING THIS OBLIGATION
ON THE AIR GET IRRIGATION
DISTRICT -- TO BY THESE --
EXPENSIVE SOLAR AND WIND
PROJECTS AND THEN TO SELL OFF
THE ENERGY AT A LOSS TO THEIR TO
THE RATE PAYERS AND AND THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHY YOU NEED WE
NEED THIS BILL NOW.
IS BECAUSE THERE ARE THERE ARE
PLANNING TO SPEND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
PROJECTS.
PAST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS
THAT -- IT THAT SB -- ONE
HUNDRED PLACES ON THEM NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO IS THAT -- YOU
KNOW I FIND IT INTERESTING AND I
AND I REALLY WANNA I WAS GONNA
TAKE THAT -- CENTER BRADFORD STE
COMMENTS AS MY CLOTHES IS THAT
THIS REALLY HIT ME YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU WHEN WHEN PEOPLE START
TALKING ABOUT UNFAIR TREATMENT.
AND IT'LL UNDERMINE THE PROGRAM --
IT KIND OF INFURIATES ME BECAUSE
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT FOR THE
MOST PART.
ON I'M LEGISLATORS COME FROM
URBAN AREAS AND THEY DESIGN THE
RULES OF THE GAME TO TO BENEFIT
URBAN AREAS AND THEN AS A AS A
RULE RESIDENT AND LEGISLATOR
TRYING TO GET INTO THE
DISCUSSION BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT WHEN ANSWER SB.
ONE HUNDRED WAS MAKING ITS WAY
AROUND THE LEGISLATURE I TRIED
VERY HARD TO GET.
THIS KIND OF RELIEF FOR THE
IRRIGATION THESE TO PUT TWO
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS -- BECAUSE
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE TO THE
RATE PAYERS TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE TO THE RATE PAYERS --
THE REASON THAT.
HYDRO WAS NOT INCLUDED HAD TO DO
WITH THIS AND INVESTMENT THAT WE
WANTED TO MAKE IN OTHER FORMS OF
ENERGY SO EVERYBODY.
WAS GONNA GET TREATED THE SAME
AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT EQUAL
TREATMENT IF IT IS ON THEY THEIR
RATE PAYERS.
HAVE BEEN HURT.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN MADE TO
INVEST.
IN WHAT IS REALLY GOOD ENERGY
SOLAR AND AND WIND ENERGY IS
TREMENDOUS ENERGY I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S NOT BUT BUT AS CENTER
BRADFORD SAID WE WE WERE REALLY
LOOKING.
AT THE REDUCTION OF FOSSIL FUELS
WE WANTED TO GET OFF OF THAT AND
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH FAIR
AT THE BEGINNING. TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA CALL HIGH WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA COUNT HYDRO AND
LET'S MAKE THE STANDARD FIRE.
BECAUSE THEN YOU THEN THEY COULD
HAVE GOTTEN CREDIT FOR THEIR OWN
ENERGY AND BUT THEY HAD TO MEET
HIGHER HIGHER -- TARGETS DOWN
THE ROAD.
THEY MADE THE INVESTMENTS NOW
AND THE RATE PAYERS ARE PAYING
FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO GET CHEAPER --
SOLAR ENERGY -- AND THEY'RE NOT
ASKING TO TURN BACK THE CLOCK
THEY'RE JUST ASKING FOR THAT THE
EQUITY THAT -- WILL ALLOW THEM
TO TELL THE REPAIRS WE CAN TAKE
A DEEP BREATH FOR FOR A MINUTE --
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE THESE THESE HUGE
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT DON'T
BENEFIT US WE ARE NOT USING THAT
ENERGY.
NUMBER ONE IT AND THEN NOT THAT
FINALLY THEY'RE NOT ASKING. TO
SELL OFF.
THE ENERGY THAT THEY PRODUCE
FROM HYDRO IF IT ALL GOES TO THE
RATE PAYERS.
IT IS THAT THEY'RE NOT IN AND WE
AGREED TO THAT AS AS AN
AMENDMENT AS WELL.
SO I'M IMMEDIATE INTO IN TERMS
OF OF OF IS THIS A RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND IS IT NOT A CLEAN
ENERGY I'M IT'S IT'S MIND
BOGGLING TO ME THAT ANYBODY
WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S THAT NOT
RENEWABLE AND THEN IT'S NOT --
IT'S IT'S NOT [inaudible]
CARBON FREE.
IT IS.
AND SO ON WE JUST IF IT'S A
FAIRNESS ISSUE IT'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE AND QUITE FRANKLY IT IT IS
A REPAIR HUGH.
ON THE EQUITY STANDPOINT YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
BUT IT YEAH I'M KIND OF A NOTE.
PERSON SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHY.
PERHAPS YOU AND SENATOR BRADFORD
DIDN'T DO A BILL THAT SAID THAT
HYDRO PRICE.
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THIS [inaudible]
DEBATE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WHEN I WAS
TRYING TO DO IS TO HELP THE RATE
PAYERS THAT HAVE BEEN --
BURDENED AND AND IN PARTICULAR
IN IN IN A REGION WHERE I'M VERY
LUCKY IN -- IN IN THE COASTAL
REGION.
WE DON'T HAVE AIR CONDITIONING
CONDITIONERS IN OUR HOUSE AND IN
IN IN THE WINTER AND SUMMER IT'S
SIXTY DEGREES ALL YEAR ROUND SO
I'M ALWAYS IN THE FIRST YEAR IN
TERMS OF PAYING MY ELECTRIC
BILLS.
BUT I'VE ALSO SPENT TIME IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY YOU BETTER HAVE
AN AIR CONDITIONER AND YOU
BETTER HAVE A REALLY GOOD HEATER
IN THE WINTER.
AND SO -- I HAD A LEGISLATOR
TELL ME LAST YEAR THAT THAT
LIVES FULL TIME IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
THAT HIS ELECTRIC BILL WAS SIX
HUNDRED BUCKS ONE ONE OF THE
MONTHS BECAUSE HE HAD LITTLE
KIDS AT HOME.
AND AND THEY NEEDED THE AIR
CONDITIONER ON AND I I WAS
APPALLED AT THE IDEA THAT YOU
HAVE TO PAY THAT THAT MUCH AND
AND THAT'S WHAT.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT EXEMPLIFIED
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH SHE SAID
IT IT.
IN IN IN A REGION WHERE THE
WHERE WHAT YOU USE TENDS TO BE
HIGHER IN THAT IN THAT REGARD
WHAT YOU DON'T WANT IS TO HAVE A
HIGHER RATE BECAUSE YOU YOU'RE
TRYING TO MEET SOME --
OBLIGATION THAT'S BEEN SET THAT
REALLY DOESN'T BENEFIT YOUR
RESIDENTS AT ALL.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE HAD TO
DO THEY'VE HAD TO MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS AND SO.
YOU KNOW MAYBE WE I UNDERSTOOD
THE ISSUE IN TERMS OF THESE TWO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT DISTRICT
BECAUSE I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING TO THEM IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WORKS IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE -- BUT
I'VE I FIGURED IF I COULD HELP
SOLVE IT HERE -- WE CAN SEE
LATER ON WHAT.
CAN'T PREDICT WHAT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN LATER ON I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE OTHER HYDRO IS LOCATED
IN AND WHAT IT.
IMPACT IS QUITE FRANKLY.
I DON'T EITHER THAT'S WHY I WAS
KIND OF ASKING BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WANNA STAY RIGID TO A PRINCIPLE.
THE RBS TOLD THAT.
THAT THAT MAKES NOW.
EXEMPTIONS AND THAT'S WHERE THE
STRUGGLE IS I'M JUST CURIOUS IN
THIS YEAR VALLEY THEN ARE.
SINCE YOU'RE PAYING HIGHER RATES
PERHAPS WE SUBSIDIZE THAT WITH.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD YOU YOUR
LOCAL STORE.
DO NOT AGREE ARE ARE THE ARE ARE
YOUR REPAIRS TO THE RATES THE
RATES ARE HIGHER IT'S THE USAGE
THAT SO MUCH HIGHER THAT CAUSES
THE HIGHER BILLS IN YOUR
SUBSIDIZING THAT [inaudible]
THROUGH.
WHAT THE RESERVES ARE HIGH I YOU?
OR YOU ARE JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THE HYDRO YOU CAN AFFORD.
TO CHARGE RATES THAT ARE LOWER
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE PAYING HIGHER
RATES FOR THE SOUL.
I THINK OUR OUR RATES ARE LOWER
BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSE
PORTFOLIOS THAT WE BOTH HALF AND
AND THE THE ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN OVER THE YEARS TO TRY TO
KEEP OUR RATES LOW BECAUSE WE
ARE APPEAR YOU -- SO IT IS FAR
SUBSIDIZING I DON'T THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO FORMA SUBSIDY
ALTHOUGH ALL THE REVENUE WE GET
GOES BACK GOES BACK TO THE RATE
THE RATE PAYERS AREN'T FEELING
ANY PAIN.
THE REPAIRS ARE THE ONES WHO WHO
MUST HAVE A HIGH VOLUME.
AND IN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY YES
MOST FOLKS WOULD HAVE HIGHER
VOLUMES AND THEN FOLKS ELSEWHERE
IN THE STATE LIKE LIKE ON THE
COASTAL REGIONS AND STUFF SO SO
THAT'S WHAT CAUSES THE HIGHER
BILLS EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE THE
LOWER RATES YEAH.
WELL THEN IN YOUR PARTICULAR
AREA WE SUBSIDIZE NAT WITH.
SSI BENEFITS AND WELFARE AND ALL
THE REST APRIL THE BILL I WOULD.
THAT I COULDN'T ONE ZERO GRAM
WEDNESDAY PROGRAM YEAH I'VE
SETTING AND OTHER.
THAT I'M NOT SURE YEAH.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER STERN YEAH THANK
YOU.
ARE YOU MISTER CHAIR RIGHT NOW
WHO'S MISTER CHAIR HERE MISTER
SURE JUST FOR THE MINUTE JUST
FOR THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK CENTER
FOR BRINGS FORWARD -- I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS SORT OF
RURAL URBAN DIVIDE AND THIS
NOTION OF SOME DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT I I WE'RE ONE CALIFORNIA
HERE MANY GREAT IS ONE GREAT I
KNOW THAT THEIR DISTRICTS IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT.
HAVE DIFFERENT CHALLENGES TO SEE
A WHOLE LOT OF COLD BY THE WAY
AND IN.
THE DESK SO. 16% OF THE POWER
MAKES THERE SO WELL THAT'S WHAT
IT SAYS IN THE ANALYSIS FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
RIGHT BUT SO I MEAN THERE'S GAS.
LEFTOVER COAL YOUR CYCLING OUT
EVERYONE'S TRYING TO GET OFF
THAT BUT THE BROADER ISSUE IS
THAT.
INLAND OF LOS ANGELES THE INLAND
OF ALL THESE OTHER REGIONS WE
ALL HAVE CHALLENGES BUT I'D SEE
RENEWABLES IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
I MEAN FRESNO IN KERN COUNTY OR
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
GENERATORS OF THE WORLD KERN
MAKES MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTY IN THE STATE
ANY OTHER REGION IN THE WORLD
AND ALSO HAS OIL.
TO JUSTIN ENERGY GIANT
[inaudible]
AND I'M.
I I DON'T SEE THIS IS -- THE
DARK IS ALREADY COUNTS HYDRO I
MEAN IT DOESN'T COUNTY KIND OF
HYDRO YOU GUYS WANT BUT IT
COUNTS.
BUT A SMALL HYDROELECTRIC
FACILITY THIRTY MEG WATER LESS
PLUS CONDUIT HYDROELECTRIC
FACILITIES PLUS INCREMENTAL
INCREASES.
FROM EFFICIENCY IMPROVEMENTS IN
EXISTING FACILITIES I STILL SEE
THERE'S ROOM FOR HYDRO I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL WANT TO HAVE
A BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT.
WE WE DID A DEAL ON SB ONE
HUNDRED AND I I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY.
A RUN ON WIND IT.
HERE.
I DON'T SEE THE BURDENS YET --
YOU KNOW I MEAN SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THE
D. W. P. CUSTOMERS THE EDISON
CUSTOMERS TRUST ME WE'RE USING A
LOT OF AC TWO IT'S AND IT'S I
MEAN.
AND THERE'S PLAN I MEAN THE
ELECTRIC RATES I THINK YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY SOME OF THE LOWEST
RATES IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AMONG THOSE YOUR OCCASION
DISTRICTS OF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
SO I DON'T HEAR THE RATE.
ANGST I'M HERE A HECK OF A LOT
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUR DISTRICTS
WITH LOCAL RESOURCE IN ASSETS
AND PUT PEOPLE TO WORK.
SO I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR SENSE
OF THAT I MEAN.
HEY I READ I RESPECT THAT.
YOU GOTTA FIGHT FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY AND THIS FEELS
BURDENSOME BUT I SEE MORE IS
OPPORTUNITY SO I CAN YOU CAN YOU
GUYS COME.
TO TERMS YOUR STRATEGY MAY GET
YOU WANT TO COUNT THINGS YOU'RE
ALREADY DOING BASICALLY TORTURE
OBLIGATION BUSINESS FROM JUST
REDUCE.
YOUR OBLIGATION UNDER THE RP A
SO LET ME JUST START OFF BY
SAYING THERE IS NO.
INTENT HERE [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
I'M.
NO IN INTENT HERE.
TOO DISPARAGE [inaudible]
OUR PS.
AND IT AND THE SYSTEM THAT WAS
SET UP.
WHAT THE COMMENT I WAS MAKING IS?
HE IS SENATOR YOU RIGHT NOW JUST
SAID WEEK WE HAD A DEAL.
I'M NOT SURE WHO IS AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
BUT I I CERTAINLY WASN'T TALKED
TO ABOUT.
THE IMPACT ON RURAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT.
AND WHEN I TRIED TO BRING IT UP
WITH THE AUTHOR.
THE ANSWER QUITE FRANKLY WAS I
DON'T NEED YOUR VOTE.
AND SO THIS IS THE DIRECTION
WE'RE GOING TO GO IN NOW I'M NOT
BEING DISRESPECTFUL I'M JUST
SAYING THAT WAS THAT WAS EXACTLY
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN AND FOR
THAT REASON -- I DIDN'T SUPPORT
IT BUT BUT THESE BOTH OF THESE
IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
HAVE STEPPED UP.
AND THEY'VE MADE VERY EXPENSIVE
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR PURCHASES
OF SOLAR.
IT'S NOT ENERGY THEY NEED FOR
THEIR RATE PAYERS.
IT IS ENERGY THAT THEY HAVE TO
BUY BECAUSE OF THAT REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN THEY HAVE THEY SELL IT
OFF IS AT A DISCOUNT.
AND SO THE RATE PAYERS ARE
PAYING THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS INVESTMENT AND THEN HAVING
THE ENERGY SOLD OFF.
AND AND AND AND AND THE WHOLE
POINT OF IT IS IS THAT IT IT WAS
A SYSTEM.
THAT WAS NOT SET UP THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE FROM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
AND SO NOW TO SAY WELL YOU BUTTE
YOU'RE GONNA UNFAIRLY CHANGE THE
SYSTEM.
IT JUST DOESN'T WASH WITH ME
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM.
IT WAS A SYSTEM THAT
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED HYDRO FOR
A PARTICULAR PURPOSE.
AND THAT PURPOSE WAS TO GET OFF.
THE USE OF FOSSIL FUELS
[inaudible]
SO.
NO I'M NOT I AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
YEAH CENTER SENATOR IS TRY TO
BREATH [inaudible]
I'M.
WE ALL COULD HAVE RESTORATIONS
ANY EXPRESSED SOME WITH THE
ORIGINAL BILL BUT I THINK
[inaudible] TO TO DEFINE IT AS
THE EXCLUSION OF THAT THE LARGE.
BLUE XIN WAS PARTICULARLY
DETRIMENTAL TO RURAL AREAS I
MEAN.
LED W. P..
AT THE POINT THAT THE ARK YES
WAS ADOPTED.
HAD OVER 25% OF ITS POWER MIX IN
LARGE RIGHT.
IT SHIP IT NOW JUST IS
PURCHASING.
JEANNIE AS A 20% MORE TRIED
GROWN IT'S MIXED.
THE SFPUC.
HAS A THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE MEGAWATTS OF LARGE HYDRO IN
ITS ELECTRICITY MIX.
ONLY THIRTEEN MEG WHAT EVERY
NOTE SO IT'S JUST NOT.
ACCURATE TO PUT IT THAT WAY.
AND I'M.
I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE OBJECTION THAT AT
LEAST I HAVE MUCH MORE THAT WE
BUILT IN.
BE A COST COMPLIANCE MEANING TO
BE A COST LIMITATION COMPLIANCE
TO PROTECT PO USE AND THE
DISTRICTS AB EXERCISES THAT.
AND SO IT JUST AGAIN FOR ME IT'S
HARD TO SEE WHAT WE NEED IS
RIGHT NOW.
CENTER BRAD YEAH I I WANNA GO
WOULD SOONER STERN STATED THAT
WE'RE CLEARLY ONE CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
BUT IT'S MANY PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THE DISCUSSION.
OF ENERGY AND VARIOUS POLICIES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN NEED IN KERN COUNTY
AREN'T CENTRAL VALLEY IS FAR
DIFFERENT FROM LOS ANGELES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
THE COMMENT THAT WAS MADE THAT
NOW.
UTILITIES WILL INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES WILL GO BACK SOON HI I
MEAN I USING A HYDRO.
THEY SOLD OFF THEIR PART POWER
PLANTS BECAUSE OF DEREGULATION
SO.
THEY'RE STILL THERE BUT THEY
DON'T ONLY MORE SO THEY WOULD
STILL HAVE TO GO OUT AND
PURCHASE ARE FROM WHATEVER BUT
THIS IS A REVIEW OF ONE TO
CONTINUE TO FRAME HYDRO AS IF
IT'S NOT RENEWAL.
WE SEE IT WORKING IN BRITISH
COLUMBIA WE SEE IT WORKING WE
HAD TRIED TO DO A DEAL WERE
RUNNING THE RIVER IN BC.
THE BRING IMPORTS ALL KNOW YOU
CAN'T BECAUSE THE BUCKET ONE
BUCKET TWO BUCKETS.
IT ALL HAS TO BE IN STATE.
WE COULD HAVE HAD CHEAPER POWER
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AGO IF WE
WERE OPEN.
TO ALL THE DIFFERENT RESOURCES
OUT.
ARE AVAILABLE YOU'RE HEARING A
COMMUNITY THAT IS NOW BUYING.
SOLAR BECAUSE IT'S MANDATE IT
BUT SHE ADDING OUT THE LOWER
WOULD BECAUSE IT'S ON NECESSARY.
THAT IS HUSTLING BACKWARDS TO ME
AND THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE SO IT'S NOT.
ENERGY RATE THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT STEM
CONSUMPTION BECAUSE THEY USE
MORE ASH OUT THE SENATOR STATED
IN THE WINTER AND THE SUMMER AND
WE DO.
AND COAST TORN URBAN AREAS SO
THAT'S TO RULE SHOULD NOT WHAT
THE PAPER BUT HOW MUCH THEY HAVE
TO USE SO.
ALLOWING HIM TO NOT HAVE TO MAKE
THOSE UNNECESSARILY UNNECESSARY
PURCHASES OF SOLAR OUR
INVESTMENT IN SOLAR ONLY THE SHE
HAD A PART IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAY.
THAT'S THE WHOLE DOCTOR VOTE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIX THAT IN
YOUR HER SHE HAS A SOLUTION TRY
TO HELP US FIX TO DUB URBAN WE
ALL PULL POINT ON VERY WELL
STATED CENTER THANK YOU.
OKAY OF SOME NIGHT.
YEAH YOU KNOW I CAME IN HERE
KIND OF NEUTRAL ON THIS WANTED
TO LISTEN TO BOTH SIDESOF IT
YOU KNOW I I TOTALLY AGREE THAT
WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
INCENTIVIZE.
YOUR HYDRO IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YEAH OUT PARTICULARLY
LARGE HYDRO GOING FORWARD.
BUT IT SURE SEEMS TO ME AND YOU
KNOW I WASN'T HERE AT THE TIME
THAT THINGS WERE DONE IT'S
AWFULLY EASY.
TO TAKE SHOTS AT THE PAST.
THE PEOPLE THAT -- IMPLEMENTED
THE R. P. S. DID THE BEST THING
THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD DO AT
THE TIME IS RIGHT.
IT JUST BUT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
SITTING HERE.
JUST IGNORING THE FACT.
THAT WE DO HAVE A CLEAN SOURCE
OF ENERGY.
ARE ALREADY [inaudible]
BEING GENERATED.
AND SO I I I I DON'T KNOW IT'S
IT SURE SEEMS TO ME LIKE ON YOU
TILL WE DON'T WANT INCENTIVIZE.
YOU PARTICULARLY WHERE YOU HAVE.
YOUR UTILITIES AND HAVE A LARGE
PORTFOLIO OF HYDRO AND HAVE THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS THERE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT.
YOUR FORMULAS OF HOW WE DEAL
WITH THAT GOING FORWARD.
IF THAT THESE ARE BEING USED IN
THEIR BEING USED EFFECTIVELY AND
IT IS CLEAN ENERGY JUST.
I DON'T KNOW FOR ME IT DOESN'T
PASS THE SMELL [inaudible]
VERY WELL.
DID YOU ON MY CLOSING COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS
AND THEIR CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
I'M FOR ME IT'S AN EQUITY ISSUE
AND IT'S A DISTRICT.
THANK YOU ARE TO HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
OKAY OF CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB SIXTY PASSES AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR.
WHAT'S SO I WAS SO I MORE LOT.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG ILL.
ILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER.
STERN NO STERN NOTES DOWN.
STONE AYE WIENER.
MORE LIKE I IT'S A ROOM IF THE
ROLE OF PERHAPS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT.
WE'RE GONNA GO.
BACK ON AND CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THE ROLE BEGINNING WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB FORTY SIX BY --
CENTER REJECTION WE HAVE A TO
PASS AS AMENDED RECOMMENDATION
AND RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL [inaudible]
THE ROLE.
SB FORTY SIX PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PART ABOUT
[inaudible]
SEVEN ONE CHIANG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
I DOWN.
DOWN NOW HI.
I REMEMBER ONE INNER I YOUR YEAH.
AND YOU WON THE MIKE IS ON I
BELIEVE THE ROLE OF A FRACTION
OF MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO CENTER NIELSEN.
WE HAVE A FEW PASSES AMENDED
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE THIS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TIME VOTE SEVEN
ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CHANG.
CHANG I FEEL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE.
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB.
ONE FIFTY FIVE IS A TO PASS AS A
MAN BEEN AMENDED RECOMMENDED I
VOTE ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SB ONE FIVE FIVE TO PASS THEM
AND HAVE PROCREATION TO CURRENT
ABOUT ELEVEN ZERO HEALTH.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
SB ONE NINE NINE BY HILL.
WE HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
I VOTE.
AND I LOVE IT SECOND.
IT'S CONSENT CALENDAR ACTUALLY
YEAH.
SB ONE NINE NINETY PAST
APPROPRIATIONS.
NUMBER THREE ZERO MORE LOT
[inaudible] FOUR FOUR MOORLACH
I CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SKINNER BY IN OUR EYES STERN
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
THE ROLE IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE SB TWO OH NINE SENATORS
DODD -- HIGH RECOMMENDATION.
SB TWO OH NINE DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN OR FOUR ZERO A LOT.
MORE LIKE I CHIANG.
CHING I FEEL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
I STERN STERN AYE STONE STONE
AYE WIENER.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB THREE EIGHTY
SIX AND BY SENATOR COVER YET ALL.
WE HAVE A TO PASS AS AMENDED
MOTION PLEASE ALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SB THREE EIGHTY SIX THE BEST
AMENDED TO THE FOR CURRENT AT
SEVEN ONE WHERE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
ALL THE OTHER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER.
CALL THE OUT OF CABALLERO.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SIX AS THREE EIGHTY
SIX HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
SKINNER MCGUIRE AYE [inaudible]
SKINNER WIENER.
IT WILL CLOSER ROLE THAT BILL IS
OUT.
ANOTHER ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP
FIVE TWENTY SENATOR HERTZBERG WE
HAVE -- DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WELL WE HAVE THE PAST MOTION I
RECOMMENDATION CLERK PLEASE
COSTS OF MEMBERS.
SB FIVE TWENTY TWO HAS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE FOUR
ZERO MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHING I HILL KILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE A SKINNER [inaudible]
FIVE ALL RIGHT.
HER EYES STERN STERN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
TWELVE ZERO ITEM OF NUMBER.
EIGHT SB FIVE FOUR AND MY NINE
BY SENATOR HILL.
WE HAVE A BUT TO PASS A MOTION
OF A MOTION TO APPROVE --
RECOMMEND I VOTE.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GIVE CAST TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
THREE ONE RADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI DAD I MCGUIRE RIGHT MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE WIENER [inaudible]
SENATE [inaudible]
CASH.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THEM AS
WELL.
AS WE ARE COMING BACK.
IS PRESENT THE PROCESS WILL.
EITHER WAY THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
TO GET OUT [inaudible] THREE SB
FIVE FIFTY BY HILL.
WE ALSO HAVE A PROMOTION TO DO
PASSED MOTION -- RECOMMEND I
HAVE A LOOK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE FOR ONE CHIANG.
SAYING I DIED.
DIED I AM MCGUIRE RIGHT MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO.
THE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
KEEP THE ROLE OF TRAPS AND
MEMBERS -- SB SIX OH THREE BY.
GORGEOUS.
AND ON WE HAVE A DO PASSES
AMENDED -- RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
CLICK IS CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS
SB SIX F. THREE D. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE FOR YOU.
MOORLACH MORE LIKE I AGING.
CHIANG I KILL.
KILL AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
OKAY LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSOLUTE NUMBERS -- SB SIX TWO
FIVE ITEM.
ELEVEN CAN A BUS.
SENATOR HILL -- TO PASS.
WITH THE PROMISE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR -- CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE OPSEU MEMBER SB SIX TWO FIVE
DAY PASSED TO THE FOR CURRENT
VOTE FOUR ZERO MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE I CHIANG.
DODD CHANG I DIED.
DIED I REQUIRE.
REQUIRE AYE RUBIO.
REVIEW AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN -- STERN AYE STONE STONE
AYE WIENER.
ITEM TWELVE SB.
SIX SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR
BRADFORD -- TO PASS AS AMENDED
MOTION RECOMMEND I VOTE CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB SIX SEVEN SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
WHERE I RUBIO?
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
YEAH. TWELVE SIR OKAY -- THAT
BILL WILL KEEP IT OPEN.
IT IS WINTER COMES BACK.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN OF FOUR
OF I CENTER BRADFORD WE HAVE A
DO PASS MOTION RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SIX ONE MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH NO CHIANG.
KILL.
KILL I AM MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE A WINNER. NINE BILLION
THE ROVER PREPS AND MEMBERS OF
ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN TO SOME
CENTER BRADFORD.
WE HAVE A A TO PASS MOTION
RECOMMEND I VOTE.
THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KIND OF
BY ZERO MORE LOT.
RIGHT MORE LIKE I CHIANG
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HELL NO [inaudible]
THERE [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN TRY STERN AYE WIENER AYE
SKINNER AYE. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TO
ONE I WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS -- SB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR BY SENATOR STERN.
WE HAVE A TO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDED I VOTE CLERK THIS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO PASS
THE MENTORSHIP PROCREATION
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO MOORLACH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE A STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO. ELEVEN ONE LIMóN ONE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT BILL --
LET'S GO BACK -- TO ITEM.
ONE WE SEE HERE AND I REVIEW
YOUR THINGY CAM ON ITEM.
ONE MCGUIRE YOU STILL HERE --
ITEM ONE MCGUIRE.
RIGHT. THIRTY FORTY SIX THE PAST
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ABOUT NINETY OF CHIANG MCGUIRE.
WHERE I? FOR A CLOSER ROLE ON
THAT.
ONE ON ON NIELSEN ITEMS TO
ACQUIRE.
ITEM TO KNEEL. SEVENTY TWO
PASSES AMENDED PREPARATIONS
TWELVE ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THEY WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THE
BILL IS NOW -- ITEM [inaudible]
THREE MCGUIRE.
I SB ONE FIVE FIVE TO PRESS THEM
AND TO APPROPRIATIONS MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
RULES [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY AS THE ONE NINE NINE CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND ABOUT NINE ZERO TO PASS A
PROVISIONS HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE. ONE NINE NINE ZERO ONE
NINE NINE CONSECUTIVE WONDER.
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE WHERE I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE.
WIENER HE'S ON HIS WAY.
THE ONE AND AND SAID HE'S ON HIS
WAY IS WHEN ON THE WAY.
OKAY THEN WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF
I AM.
FIVE SB TWO OH NINE CENTER DODD
GAPS OF MEMBERS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE WIENER [inaudible]
ITEM. SIX ONE IS OUT -- ITEM SIR
[inaudible]
A CLOSER [inaudible]
MENSA [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WIENER.
YES I WOULD JUST WAIT OKAY
[inaudible]
YOU'RE GOOD. SIX ON SIX NO NO NO
NO YOU DID IT IT'S OUT.
HOW DO WE CLOSE SOMEONE
[inaudible]
IN ANSWER.
BUT ONE OF THE HIGHER ISSUE SAYS
THE CLOTHES THAT I DON'T
REMEMBER CLOSE ENOUGH.
SORRY.
NOTE THAT ON HE WAS SILENT ON A
COUPLE OF THEM NO I DON'T THINK
HE WON HELLO
.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE BY SENATOR DODD --
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER.
SB. TWO OH NINE TWELVE ZERO
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT BY SENATOR HILL.
SB FIVE FOUR NINE CURRENT VOTE.
TEN ONE CHANGES.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
NINE SB FIVE FIFTY BY CENTER
HILL.
CALVET ELEVEN ONE WIENER THIS IS
MINE [inaudible]
WIENER I ITEM NUMBER TEN BY
SENATOR GORGEOUS.
KERN VOTE TWELVE ZERO WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN BY SENATOR
HILL.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO WIENER
[inaudible]
I SEC.
IT WAS CLOSED WE CLOSE HELLO.
I DON'T KNOW AGAIN WE HAD A
DEBATE ON THIS BUT ANYWAY.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE CALVET TWELVE ZERO WIENER.
I DON'T START NUMBER TWELVE
RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THAT NINE TO
CHIANG WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN BY CENTER
BRADFORD.
AT KERN VOTE EIGHT ONE CHIANG.
HERTZBERG MCGUIRE WIENER.
THIS IS IMPORTANT [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FIVE WIENER I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SAY THAT I'M.
VOTING ON THAT THERE WILL BE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN.
ONE OKAY. FOR THOSE IS OPPOSED
THE ROLE ON NUMBER SIX SO I WAS
VOTE AGAINST THE BILL SO OKAY
ACCORDING TO STAYING OFF BUT I
WAS.
I DID NOT HAVE THE ROLE NOT BEEN
CLOSE I WOULD HAVE VOTED.
OKAY.
GOOD TO KNOW.
HI SO WHERE TURNED